Previously on Bobamex und Ziegen, die wie Menschen schreien. Moment, ach so, wir haben ja ein neues Feature. Ein Feature nur für uns. Ist geil, oder? Das ist so der Ton, der immer kommt, wenn ich hier so eine Kapitelmarke setze.
Jetzt reicht's aber auch mal.
Ja, der Sound ist jetzt noch nicht optimal.
Glaub uns, der Ton ist nicht so geil.
Und jetzt sollen wir jetzt glauben, dass die Hörer das jetzt auch hören.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zack Return.
War jetzt gemein.
Wieso kam das gerade als so frisch die Mate, wenn ich hinein laufen ließ?
Nee, ich hatte so ein Hustlachflash.
Das sind die schlimmsten auf jeden Fall.
Eins von beiden kann man immer nicht aufhören.
Übrigens, meh fällt mir zu ein. Das ist nicht wirklich meh, aber es gibt zum Beispiel im Wildpark Pooing, das ist so bei München irgendwo da draußen. Da gibt es so komische kleine Schafziegen, irgendwie keine Ahnung, was so schafziegig ist, so kleine Braune und die machen wirklich richtig meh, mit M vorne dran.
Brought to you by MobileMeh, Ausgabe Nr. Vielleicht wird das schon der Name für uns, MobileMeh, einfach so M-I-H, so voll meh, meh, MobileMeh, meh, stimmt, würde passen. Ja, MobileMeh, warum kommt man auf sowas nicht? Tja, zu spät, wir müssen uns was anderes einfallen lassen. Auf jeden Fall habe ich schon gesagt, 106 ist der Zähler, der hier durch rattert und rauscht. Ja, und unsere Kalenderprogramme haben gut funktioniert, außer dem von Huckel. Der ist leider ausgeschieden in der Qualifikation heute, also quasi im Halbfinale rausgekickt worden. Denn man muss sich ja hier auch immer wieder neu bewähren, bis man es hier in die Sendung schafft. Das ist also wie Champions League eigentlich. Und jetzt kommt das Finale. Alle zwei Wochen Finale, das ist ein Gefühl, da können Bundesliga-Fans eigentlich nur von träumen. Aber MOBA Max Führer...
Das Qualifikationsspiel besteht darin, Kalender zu lesen.
Genau, und einzurichten und am Laufen zu halten.
Da wird es schon ein bisschen haarig.
Deswegen ist ja Champions League.
Heute also Champions League hier bei MOBA Max. Mal gucken, ob die Themenlage da mit dem Anspruch auch mithalten kann. Weil irgendwie waren es ja auch so etwas saloppe zwei Wochen, die ja da alles vorbei strichen. Und das, obwohl CeBIT ist.
Ce was?
CeBIT. Das ist diese Messe, die...
In deiner Heimatstadt.
Die nur für diese Messe gebaut wurde, oder?
Ja, ich habe einen Teil meiner Jugend auf der CeBIT verbracht. Einen nicht ganz unsignifikanten.
Oh je, und den Rest hast du unterm Stein verbracht, oder was? Das sind doch nur zwei Wochen im Jahr.
Na, einmal raus aus dem Keller, CeBIT, und dann wieder rein in den Keller, ne? Wie das so ist.
Einmal kurz durch die Sonne in die Messehalle. Die neonbeleuchtete.
Oder durch den Schnee.
Du müsstest dein Mikrofon auch so ein bisschen prägnanter einstellen, finde ich. Ja, es könnte noch so ein bisschen mehr Biss haben.
So? Schmeckt das überhaupt? Wenn es jetzt Biss hat, ich kann hier noch ein bisschen aufdrehen.
CeBIT ist doch mal eindeutig 80er Shit eigentlich. 90er vielleicht noch so ein bisschen.
Ich richte ja auch von 80ern. Recht hast du. Nee, ja logisch. Also ich meine, 90er ging ja schon bergab. Aber so ein 80ern war das mal echt der Treffpunkt. Also total.
Für einen, der in Hannover wohnt.
Nö, nein. Nein, nein, da traf sich die Welt.
Ich war ja einmal an einem Stand mit der Firma, irgendwie zwei Tage.
Ich glaube, das muss jeder mal in seinem Leben durchgemacht haben.
Und habe da was präsentiert und das war, oh je, lass mich lügen. Ich glaube, das war sogar Samsung. Irgendwie.
Du warst bei Samsung?
Nee, ich war nicht bei Samsung, aber die Firma, bei der ich war, die hatte irgendwie so kooperationsmäßig, waren die da bei dir.
Aber da muss ich ganz schnell was einschieben, warte mal ganz kurz, ich war auch mal für eine Firma auf der CeBIT und rat mal, bei welcher Firma ich untergekommen bin.
Ja, so hat jeder seine Leichen im Keller.
Auf jeden Fall, das Geile war, da stand in der Ecke von dem Stand dieser Samsung-Roboter, der sah aus wie ein Japaner, mit einer Aktentasche in der Hand und der stand den ganzen Tag dort und hat sich nicht bewegt.
Warte mal, ein Samsung-Roboter, der aussieht wie ein Japaner?
Ich nehme an, es war ein Roboter, weil der hat sich nicht bewegt. Also da stand halt ein japanisch aussehender Typ mit Aktentasche.
Du weißt schon, dass Samsung aus Korea ist?
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen.
Okay, asiatisch aussehen.
Wenn wir jetzt in so einen japanischen Podcast reinschalten, wollen wir ja auch nicht, dass die Frankreich und Deutschland durcheinanderbringen. So ein Deutscher hier mit der Besitzer-Baut im Arm.
Wir sehen doch alle gleich aus für die.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich wollte ja immer ein bisschen spitz finden.
Jaja, du hast ja recht. Auf jeden Fall stand er da mit der Akkentasche stundenlang, ohne sich zu bewegen und guckte nur.
Wobei ich dir zustimmen würde, das ist sehr japanisch. Ja, vielleicht, weil er einfach aus Japan damals noch, da konnten sie selber noch kein bauen.
Und dann, ja, irgendwie war da wenig los.
Ja, es ist generell eigentlich wenig los auf diesen Messen.
Jedenfalls nicht hachsam.
Das ist eigentlich auch direkt die Antwort, also ist das Internet. Beziehungsweise das Internet hat die CeBIT so langweilig gemacht. Das hat man richtig gemerkt. Also mit dem Aufkommen von Datennetzen wurde die CeBIT automatisch immer uninteressanter. Weil früher musstest du ja noch wirklich, oder was heißt man muss, aber es war zumindest so, dass da auch wirklich interessante Techniker waren. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, so auf dem Commodore stand und so weiter.
Oder bei Atari.
Atari hat so richtige Entwickler, die da auf dem Stand waren und wenn auch nur ein Tag von den zehn Tagen, die die CeBIT so lief und du Glück gehabt hast, dann konntest du dir da halt einen schnappen und mal richtig mal tacheln das Riegel. Das war zwar dann auch schon ein bisschen Glück, aber es war immerhin möglich. Mittlerweile ist das ja einfach nur noch so eine SalesDroid-Marketing-Sprech- und sonst wie PR-Veranstaltungen.
Früher war das auch noch ein Treffpunkt, deswegen bin ich früher auch noch hingegangen, weil man sich dadurch halt eben ein Dutzend anderer Dienstreisen sparen konnte, wenn man das gut getimet hat. Weil alle fuhren da irgendwie hin, man hat sich dann vorher mal abgesprochen, du bist dann auch da, dann können wir uns ja auch mal zusammensetzen auf ein Bier oder so. Das war eher wie so ein Hörer-Treffen, wo man einfach mal sagt, man trifft sich dann mal, aber heute, wie gesagt, das Internet ist sozusagen die ständige Mitgliederversammlung der CeBIT heutzutage, wenn man das so will.
Ja, trotzdem sind da noch staunlich viele Leute und vor allem sind die Medien auch immer noch so total darauf gedrillt, dass ja dann da die dicken News kommen und so. Natürlich gibt es halt schon so eine leichte Häufung, aber so richtig der Brüller ist das irgendwie auch nicht. Ja, das ist schon irgendwie eine dicke Nachricht, dass da eine Grafikkarte für den Macintosh vorgestellt wird. Oh wow, ja dafür haben wir jetzt wirklich so ein riesiges Messezentrum dahinstellen müssen.
Na ja gut, aber zugegebenermaßen dafür, dass es irgendwie nur noch einen Mac gibt, wo man überhaupt Grafikkarten reinstecken kann, finde ich das bemerkenswert, dass sich ein Hersteller traut, Grafikkarten für einen Mac zu bauen.
Naja, die bauen sie ja eh und…
Aber wo wollen sie denn die verkaufen? Weil der einzige Mac, den du erwähnst, man nur reinstecken kann, wird ja in Europa nicht mehr verkauft.
Ja, es gibt ja genug Leute, es müssen ja welche, die schon einen haben, ne?
Das ist ja auch vor allem…
Naja gut, aber eine Grafikkarte ist auch ein klassisches Upgrade-Target. Also das ist halt wirklich so genau das Ding, was alle, die so einen Teil haben, reinstecken wollen, um aus ihrem drei Jahre alten Schrott, den sie nicht aktualisiert bekommen, weil Apple ihnen nichts Neues anbietet, zumindest so halbwegs gefühlt einen neuen Rechner macht.
Ja, aber da uns jetzt gerade in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung haarklein erklärt wurde, dass es keine Spieler gibt, die den Mac benutzen, ist jetzt ja nur die spannende Frage. Das zählt ja alles nicht, weil das ist ja alles alt und so. Aber da gab es ja jemanden, der meinte, nee, das wäre alles Kack und das macht ja keiner. Seine technischen Argumente waren ja durchaus richtig.
Richtig, Hardware-Gamer werden schon wahrscheinlich PC benutzen, aber ich meine, es gibt ja auch normale Gamer.
Es gibt auch Casual-Gamer.
Genau. Es gibt vor allem auch Leute, die von so einer Grafikkarte einen Nutzen haben, die keine Gamer sind. Und das sind die eigentlichen Käufer eines Mac Pros.
Ja, aber was machen die denn jetzt für Features? Erzähl mir doch mal ernsthaft, was machen die damit, was sie nicht schon mit der Karte haben machen können, mit der sie das Ding gekauft haben. Das sind doch irgendwie nur Leute, die das i5-Klotzen haben und Videoschnitt oder sonst noch was machen.
3D-Leute vor allem. Also Leute, die halt in 3D-Content bearbeiten.
Content bearbeiten, Konstruktionen? Mit Autodesk oder irgendwie Konstruktions-Tralala?
Autocut oder was auch immer.
Das gibt es überhaupt für den Mac noch?
Ja, das gibt es wieder für den Mac. Das ist ja auch alles wieder zurückgekommen und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es da einen notorischen Mangel gäbe. Man kann sich jetzt noch mal lange darüber unterhalten, ob jetzt der PC die bessere Plattform mittlerweile ist für 3D oder es der Mac ist, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es da niemanden gibt. Und auch Fotoshopper sitzen da mit dem Mac Pro und die sind einfach für jegliche Beschleunigung dankbar und wenn du halt da mehr Pixel, Render, OpenCL, Performance rauskommst aus einer Grafikkarte, dann beschleunigt das einfach mal einen guten Satz an Plugins.
Also du siehst mich ja puzzelt, weil ich benutze das nicht und deswegen frage mich, wo nutzt denn so eine Krötensoftware wie Fotoshop überhaupt irgendwie Grafikbeschleuniger?
Na, also erstens ja. Ja, also ich kann dir jetzt im Detail jetzt nicht genau aufzählen, wo Fotoshop noch mal explizit die Grafikkarte als solche nutzt. Aber du hast ja das im Betriebssystem auch integriert. Also da ist viele Plugins, die mittlerweile OpenCL benutzen und OpenCL ist wiederum auf die Grafikkarten-Engine optimiert und wenn du da was schnelleres hast, dann läuft natürlich auch der ganze OpenCL-Kram schneller. Also das bedingt sich aneinander. Die reine Render, Textur, Redraw, Performance, wenn du da irgendwie so ein BMW auf deinem Bildschirm in 3D mit Full-Shading und Pipa-Po und Raytracing und All Features on vor deiner Nase hin und her schaukelst, dann kannst du einfach nicht genug Performance haben.
Das ist nicht alles so wahnsinnig unglaublich scheiße proprietär, dass es wirklich funktioniert, dass man einfach seine Grafikkarte auswechselt und schon wird die Welt wieder bunt.
Ja, und dafür gibt es überhaupt vor allem den Mac.
Es gibt für alle mögliche Standards, aber die Frage ist, wer nutzt die? Das ist bei der Netzwerksgeschichte genauso, jetzt auch Standards bis der Arzt kommt, nutzt bloß keiner.
Aber OpenGL ist ja auch nur so ein Standard und da gehen die nicht auch mit allen Grafikkarten.
Ich will das jetzt ja nicht disputen, ich bin nur so ein bisschen...
Das, um der Grafikkartearbeit irgendwie zu entlocken, ist OpenCL und das ist ein Standard. Vorher war das bei Nvidia und Osteam, glaube ich, hieß es bei AMD und Apple hat ja groß angefangen rumzuzicken, weil die ja gerne die Hersteller gegeneinander ausspielen und Apple hat gesagt, hey Jungs, kommt mal klar, wir wollen hier hin und her switchen können zwischen euch und wir machen jetzt mal OpenCL und ihr könnt OpenCL machen und dann sind wir unabhängig von euch und hat das irgendwie durchgedrückt.
Ja, das Coole an OpenCL ist, dass du, wenn du so OpenCL-Kernels, wie die so schön geschrieben hast, dann kannst du ja halt auch auf den Prozessor laufen lassen.
Du, ich kenne das Konzept. Was mich bloß wundert, ist, dass jetzt Tim sagt, dass so eine Krötenbude wie Adobe hingeht und das auch wirklich benutzt. Weil gerade solche Buden sind ja normalerweise dafür, machen ja ihre Software für Multiplattformen und machen dann lieber alles selber. Als dass sie irgendein Feature auf irgendeiner Plattform irgendwie benutzen oder so. Ja, siehst du auch bei Microsoft, natürlich gibt es...
Ja, aber selber machen ist da, da wären sie schon doof, wenn sie jetzt anfangen, selber auf bestimmte Grafikkarten zu targeten.
Naja, in CUDA kannst du schon unterstützen. Das ist schon sinnvoll, halt auch sowas zu machen. Aber die eigentliche Arbeit besteht ja nicht darin, jetzt irgendwie diese 50 Zeilen Code in CUDA oder in OpenCL zu schreiben, sondern die eigentliche Arbeit besteht darin, den Algorithmus so lange umzuschreiben, bis du in der Lage bist, ihn so parallel zu haben, dass du ihn auf so einer Grafikkarte rechnen kannst. Und wie jetzt der Standard dahinter heißt, mit dem du das dann dem Shader beibringst, das ist, glaube ich, zweitrangig. Das ist dann nicht so entscheidend. Aber du musst den Algorithmus erstmal hingekriegt haben. Und dann kannst du auch in einem Nachmittag so ein paar von den Dingern in OpenCL neu schreiben, glaube ich. Vielleicht überschätze ich mich da ab.
Hier gibt es so einen Forumseintrag oder so einen Blogpost von so einem Adobe-Dings, da steht ein bisschen was drin für Photoshop und GPU-Benutzung. Also zum Beispiel Adaptive White Angel Filter, Liquify, Oil Paint, Warp and Puppet Warp, Field Blur, Iris Blur, Tilt Shift. Also die nutzen alle so OpenCL-Kram. Also das nutzen die schon bei Photoshop da ordentlich.
Ja, also ich meine, mich freut es ja. Ich bin ja ein Fan von Standards und ich bin jedes Mal erfreut, wenn es einen Standard gibt, der sich durchsetzt und die Leute den auch benutzen.
Ich kann dir sagen, dass das eine der größten Vorteile von Mac und damit auch von Mac Pro ist. Du hast einfach schon immer dieses hohe Maß an Integration gehabt. Also unter Windows, das mag sich mittlerweile auch etwas geändert haben, aber das war einfach über Jahrzehnte immer derselbe Scheiß. Da kommt eine neue Grafikkarte raus und jeder einzelne Softwarehersteller passt für eine bestimmte Grafikkarte oder einen bestimmten Hersteller oder einen bestimmten Typ Grafikkarte seine Software an. Jeder kommt da irgendwie mit eigenen Treibern, weil Windows nicht mit irgendeiner Integration daher kam. Während Apple eigentlich mal relativ schnell dabei war, solche Dinge irgendwie unter irgendeinen Mantel zu machen. Der kann dann buggy gewesen sein und so weiter. Und wir haben ja auch gerade mit OpenGL die Problematik, dass das alles so den Eindruck macht, dass Apple da nicht vorwärtskommt, weil sie halt kein OpenGL 4.0 unterstützen. Aber trotz alledem, es gibt immerhin diese Frameworks, in die du dich reinpluggen kannst. Und OpenCL war da halt genauso ein Move. Dazu kommt, dass du ja auch allein schon durch Quartz und Quartz Extreme, also das ganze Grafikframework des Macs, setzt ja nun schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange auf die Grafikbeschleunigung. Also Fenster hin und her schieben, Redraws etc., das ganze Buffer-Management im Bildschirm.
Aber gerade eben für solche Sachen hätte ich gesagt, da können die Grafikkarten schon seit Langem. Dass sie diese Specs mit 60 Frames pro Sekunde machen, dann ist das doch egal. Dann brauchst du da nicht mit 300 Frames angucken.
Na gut, schneller heißt immer, dass du früher zu was anderem kommen kannst. Sicherlich sind die Grafikkarten schon schnell genug, um nur das zu machen. Aber wenn du nebenbei auch noch ganz viele andere Sachen tust, ist es halt gut, wenn das eben auch so schnell wie möglich weg ist. Also kurz gesagt, es gibt selbstverständlich Bedarf für schnellere Grafikkarten-Performance, weil die eben gleich, out of the box, wenn du das Ding reinsteckst, von sehr vielen Subsystemen verwendet wird, ohne dass du jetzt groß darauf warten musst, dass irgendeiner das explizit unterstützen muss.
Bitcoin nutzt übrigens auch OpenCL natürlich. Diese Bitcoin-Körner, die da SHA-256 rechnen, das ist auch ein OpenCL-Körner. Und da geht es ab. Also die holen da irgendwie so raus, so viel wie geht. Also wenn die da ein halbes Megasch mehr rausholen, dann gibt es einen neuen Körner. Also wir haben da auch optimiert bis zum Abwinken.
Wie heißt denn jetzt diese neue Grafikkarte, wenn wir jetzt von der schon so viel geredet haben?
Das ist eine AMD 7950. Das ist sozusagen die Zweitbeste. Also was heißt Zweitbeste? Also es gibt ja Single- und Dual-Grafikkarte. Also diese Dual-Dinger sind ja voll, sind halt zwei drin. Das ist so richtig für die Hardcore-Gamer. Und die normale Single-Chip-Karte ist die 7970. Das ist das Topmodell von AMD zumindest. Und das 7950, das was diese Zafir-Firma jetzt für den Mac Pro rausbringen will, dass es sozusagen eine Stufe drunter ist, irgendwie hat ein paar Schäder weniger oder irgendwie so. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau. Und es, also entweder hat es ein paar Schäder weniger oder sie ist ein bisschen langsamer getaktet. Jedenfalls ist sie knapp drunter unter dem Topmodell. Und das ist schon das aktuelle, der coole Scheiß eigentlich.
Zafir ist jetzt nur der Distributor oder was?
Also der Hersteller der GPU des Chips ist ja AMD. Und AMD selber verkauft ja keine Grafikkarten. Also, ne, tun sie nicht. Und es gibt ja tausend Hersteller, die halt Grafikkarten mit AMD-Chip verkaufen. Also Zafir, High Color, Asus und so weiter. Und Zafir ist halt einer davon. Und es gibt von AMD immer so eine Referenzdesign, so eine Standardplatine. Und die anderen benutzen, die machen ihren Kühlkörper obendrauf oder das Gehäuse ist teilweise sogar auch Standard. Und umso länger eine Grafikkarte draus ist, umso mehr fangen die an, eigene Gehäuse, eigene Kühllösungen und teilweise irgendwann machen sie dann auch ihre eigenen Platinen.
Aber elektronisch sind die komplett identisch.
Am Anfang schon, da ist das Referenzdesign später dann irgendwie nicht mehr. Also ja, der Stein und so, das ist alles gleich. Also die unterscheiden sich dann nicht, wenn du in deinen Rechner reinsteckst.
Na gut, aber es muss ja jetzt dafür auch Software von Apple geben, damit diese Karte auch unterstützt wird.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz. Es gibt nämlich noch keine Treiber für diese Karte. Aber es wurde in diesem Netcast Org, was ich auch schon erwähnt hatte hier, für diese Mac Pro-Umfläscherei und was es da nicht alles gibt, und Grafikkarten-Umfläscherei. Da haben die auch schon berichtet im November oder so, als die erste 10.8.3 Beta rauskam, dass da Treiber für diese 7000er-Serie von AMD drin sind. Und wenn das 10.8.3 hier gleich rauskommt, in wenigen Minuten wahrscheinlich, dann ist da dieser Treiber drin. Und dann wird wahrscheinlich diese Grafikkarte unterstützt. Und ich denke mal, Saphir weiß schon, dass Apple das macht und warten wahrscheinlich auch darauf, dass es jetzt demnächst mal rauskommt. Ich glaube ja nicht, dass sie da eine Aktion mit Apple zusammen machen, weil ich glaube, Apple hatte immer kein Interesse, dass irgendwelche Hersteller da so was bringen. Dann würde die auch nicht so hässlich aussehen, wenn die das mit Apple zusammen machen würden. Ich glaube, da würde Apple sagen, ey, das geht gar nicht. Ja, war aber heise heute. Denn wie bei PC-Hardware-Game oder wie auch immer die heißen, da war irgendwie so ein Link mit Video sogar. Ich glaube, der Vertreter von CeBIT wurde da ein bisschen, also der Vertreter von Safi auf der CeBIT wurde ein bisschen überrascht, weil er irgendwie gar keine Ahnung, er hätte sich vorher mal ein bisschen reinhören können. Ich glaube, er war auch nur so Salesperson oder so. Und ja, den haben sie ein bisschen ausgefragt und er konnte gar nicht so richtig antworten. Höchstwahrscheinlich, weil der Journalist kannte sich aus, der den ausgefragt hat, meinte, alles klar, es sieht ja nach Referenzdesign aus und alles klar. Man kann ja sogar das Bios hin und her schalten. Die modernen Karten haben das Bios zweimal drauf. Du kannst mit so einem kleinen Schalter hin und her schalten, weil dann kannst du deinen Bios flashen und Updates reinmachen und aber zur Not immer auf das Original-Bios zurückschalten. Das sind so Gamer-Features und so. Und höchstwahrscheinlich kann man sich auch einfach, wenn die Karte mal draußen ist, kann man dieses Bios auslesen, sich eine ganz normale Standardkarte holen, die nicht irgendwie Apple-Preise hat und den Apple-Stecker dabei. Kann man sich bestimmt nochmal 100 oder 150 Euro sparen und flash das Bios da rein und dann geht's. Also ich glaube, die ganzen Hardware-Hacker hier bei Netcast Org, die warten da nur drauf, dass diese Karte mit dem Bios drauf rauskommt und dann geht's ab.
Was haben die denn jetzt gesagt, wann die erhältlich sein soll?
Na, das steht doch nicht.
Soll kosten, wann genau, erhältlich, unklar. Na toll.
Ja, aber der Preis ist schon ganz schön happig, glaube ich.
450 US-Dollar, also 400 Euro ungefähr.
Also eigentlich die 7970, die noch mal ein Stück besser ist, die kostet eigentlich jetzt hier so, die kriegst du für 350 Euro, vielleicht auch schon ein paar Euro billiger. Und das ist aber schon auch noch die bessere Karte. Also die müsste ja eigentlich so ein bisschen drunter liegen. Und warum die da 450 Dollar kosten soll, ist mir noch nicht so klar. Also angeblich, weil da noch diese Kabel beiliegen, die man braucht. Du kennst es ja, ne? Aber, ja, also ich bin gespannt, was da kommt. Ich hoffe, dass sie dieses BIOS da auslesen können und auch in eine andere Karte reinschieben können. Und dann würde ich wirklich mit anholen, weil ehrlich gesagt, dieses weiße Gehäuse, das geht gar nicht. Also ihr könnt mir erzählen, was ihr wollt, dass die in den Rechner kommt. Und man macht den zu. Aber, also, ne.
Stehst du auf blaues Licht oder was?
Die AMD-Karten sind typischerweise eigentlich immer schwarz-roh. So schwarz mit vielleicht noch so einem roten Streifchen. Aber dieses weiße, ja, das ist ja nicht mal, das ist ja so ein, ne.
Kannst auch rumschmetzen.
Ja, aber die normalen Karten von denen sehen auch genau nicht so aus. Also sie haben noch nie sah eine Karte so hässlich aus wie die da.
Aber Entschuldigung, eine Grafikkarte nicht zu kaufen, weil sie scheiße aussieht.
Ja, da sieht man mal, dass du gar keine Ahnung von diesem Markt hast. Da werden nicht nur Grafikkarten verkauft, die müssen natürlich auch noch cool aussehen. Was denkst du denn?
Der, der gerade hier am lautesten lacht, ist der, der gerne sein Rechner ableckt.
Aber guck mal, hier meint jemand im Chat, dass die normale HD 7950 für 234 Euro zu bekommen ist. Also das heißt, wahrscheinlich wird diese, ich weiß ja nicht, was jetzt ein Euro kostet, lass uns mal runterrechnen, entspannt hier, dass die 400 Euro kostet. Das sind immer noch 160 Euro mehr als die normale. Dafür, dass da höchstwahrscheinlich nur ein anderes BIOS drin ist, was 128 Kilobyte groß ist.
Außerdem so schlecht sieht sie nun auch nicht aus, oder?
Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, wie die aussieht. Wir gucken mal, wie die andere aussieht.
Fragen wir doch mal, würdest du denn dran lecken?
Das ist das Referenzdesign, so sieht die Standardkarte aus.
Diese furchtbaren Fotos, wo du dann draufkommst auf der Webseite.
Und die noch kleiner ist.
Die groß an sich zu kriegen, die genauso groß oder noch kleiner ist, ja. OEM heißt es dann. Preistendenz gleichbleibend. Naja, also mir ist es wirklich ziemlich egal, muss ich sagen, wie die aussieht. Ich gestehe jetzt ein, dass die ganz okay aussieht so. Aber ich bitte dich, das ist mir wirklich scheißegal.
Was noch cool sein könnte, ist, dass wenn wir dieses Bios von dieser Karte auslesen, dass man das vielleicht sogar in eine 7970 reinschieben kann, weil die sind ja jetzt nicht doll anders, die Karten. Meistens ist das Bios ja nur dafür da für Lüftersteuerung und PCI-ID oder irgendwie so ein Schnickschnack und macht gar nicht so richtig selbst. Ja, ist da kein Treiber drin oder so richtig. Mal sehen, das könnte...
Ja, aber einen Treiber brauchst du ja trotzdem, oder?
Den hast du ja.
Der ideale Gamer-PC, der hat so oben auf dem Gehäuse, oben noch mal so einen PCI-Slot einfach, wo man dann so freischwebt die Karte...
Nee, du hast ja keine Ahnung, Tim. So ein richtiger Gamer-PC, der hat halt so eine Seitenwand, wo eine Plexiglasscheibe ist. Du kannst da komplett reingucken und ist innen natürlich beleuchtet, ist ja klar. Blau. Ich hoffe nicht, aber es geht...
Natürlich, aber ist meistens blau.
Ich hab auch zu Hause so ein Gamer-PC. Ich brauch ja eine große Kiste für meine Bitcoin-Rig, weil ich hab ja ein Masterboard, wo man vier Grafikkarten reinstecken kann. Also brauchst du ordentlich viele Slots, auch mit großem Abstand, weil du siehst ja, die brauchen ja ja zwei Slots, diese Grafikkarten, weil sie so fett sind. Du hast ja auch so eine bei dir drin. Und deswegen hab ich auch so ein Gamer-Hardware-Gehäuse da, weil sonst das alles da nicht reinpassen würde. Und dann hab ich auch so einen Klopper.
Ja gut, aber ich finde, gerade wenn man blaues Licht hat, macht sich eigentlich so eine weiße Verpackung viel besser als so eine schwarz-rote. Weil schwarz-rote und blau ist die Abpassung.
Dieses weiß, das geht einfach überhaupt gar nicht.
Weil es ist nicht das richtige weiß.
Das kommt noch dazu. Es ist ja so komisch, milchig glänzend. Ja gut, das ist das Foto. Da gab es so ein Video, ich habe das gesehen. Das geht einfach nicht. Das sieht auch billig und scheiße aus.
Das gibt es auch echt. Wahrscheinlich kannst du für 50 Euro auch noch mal draufzahlen.
Aber ich meine, er hat natürlich recht. Für 200 Dollar Aufpreis kann man schon ein ordentliches Gehäuse verlangen, oder?
Da hätte ich dann auch nicht so ein Plastik, sondern dann würde ich es natürlich auch schön gefräst.
So ein Brushed Aluminium.
Brushed Aluminium, natürlich.
Ja, das würde besser aussehen.
Mit Erdbeergeschmack. Wenn ich da mein Indos grob reinhalte.
Und Noppen.
Um mir dann so den PCI-Porn zu geben. Du, Karte, du. Hier schaue ich jetzt mal richtig auf den Leib. Komm, zeig mir deine Pins, du Sau.
Ich bin jedenfalls gespannt, was da demnächst kommt. Und dann gucken wir mal, was die mit den Videos da drin so machen.
Hier gibt es gerade im Chat den Hinweis bei NVIDIA. Da gibt es auch so dicke Teile. Da gibt es hier auch schön...
Ja, das ist die Titan. Weißt du, was die Karte kostet? Das kostet, glaube ich, 1.000 Euro oder so.
Ja, und ist das hier auch Titan?
Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist so eine Doppel-CPU-Karte. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Aber das kann ja keiner bezahlen.
8.000 Euro?
1.000.
1.000 Euro.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Aber das ist eine von denen richtig... Da geht was. Also NVIDIA, Titan. Ja, es gibt so diese Doppelkarten. Von Asus gibt es auch eine. Der ist Asus Ares, so wie der Kriegsgott. Und ich glaube, die kostet 2.000 Euro. Die kommt in so einem Alu-Koffer irgendwie mit einem drum und dran. Hat auch Wasserkühlung und so. Und das sind richtig... Ja, das sind wirklich für die Verrückten.
Na, wir gucken mal, bis die Preise fallen. Ich meine, wenn die Leute meinen, das Ding kommt für 450 Dollar auf die Straße, dann kostet es wahrscheinlich gleich von Anfang an schon mal 400. Ich meine, das sind jetzt so Distributorenpreise in dem Sinne.
Ja, die Titan kostet 950.
Talking about Mac Pro. Ich habe jetzt bei mir hier mal ein kleines Plattenupgrade geholt und wollte mir nochmal einen Tipp bei euch holen, weil ich habe jetzt irgendwie Slots freigemacht und mal diesen zweiten CD-Slot, der nicht gebraucht wird, für die SSD verwendet und mir da so einen kleinen schicken zweieinhalb auf fünf ein Viertel Zoll Adapter, wo man theoretisch sogar zwei SSDs reinschrauben kann, Platz genug ist ja dafür, da reingebaut, sodass ich dann meine vier dicken Slots irgendwie einfach Platz hatte. Und dann habe ich dann einfach mal...
Kurze Zwischenfrage, euer Ernd. Der Slot, also der Anschluss oben für das Optical-Dings, was für einen SATA-Speed hatten der? Weil es war früher bei Apple so, dass halt das für den optischen Anschluss, die hatten SATA 1 und die Platte dann SATA 2, bei den Laptops war es dann schon für den optischen SATA 2 und für die Platte SATA 3. Also die waren immer so ein bisschen hinterher die optischen. Da könntest du ja mal schauen, aber ich vermute mal, dass SATA 2 ja da schon auch eine Weile draußen war, dass beides SATA 2 ist.
Ich habe das in Erinnerung, dass das jetzt, hatten wir nicht extra darüber gesprochen, dass das quasi auch äquivalent sei, aber du hast natürlich...
Ja, aber es war wie gesagt früher wirklich so, dass für die optischen Drives immer eine Nummer drunter hatten.
So, schauen wir mal.
Und dann klick mal drauf auf deine... Was ist das, die Samsung hängt da drin? Na 3 Gigabit ist ja SATA 2, ist ja schon mal super.
Ja, aber die Samsung hängt auch am 3 Gigabit.
Nee warte, aber guck mal, hast du noch nicht geruscht, die hätte 3 Gigabit, denn dein DVD-Laufwerk hat sogar nur auf SATA 1. Aber sie kriegt 3 Gigabit. Kriegt 3, ja, da sieht man auch schon, da ist ja der Chipsatz ICH10, der kann halt SATA 2.
Mehr geht da auch nicht.
Gut, das ist ja schon mal gut zu wissen. Das heißt, ich kann mir da oben auch eine SSD reinkleben und hab dann 4 Slots frei. Und du hast jetzt 3x3 TB gekauft, oder was?
4.
3x4 oder 4x3?
4x3.
4x3. 4 TB gibt es auch, aber ja.
Ja, ist zu teuer.
Also 3x4 wäre teurer gewesen als deine 4x3.
Genau. Weil vorher hatte ich das alles so mit 1 TB Platten voll, aber ich brauchte jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr Hub. Und hab jetzt aber im Prinzip so die...
Welche Platten hast du geholt?
Sieh doch da. Wer ist denn digital?
Ja, aber...
Steht oft vor der Nase auf dem...
WD-30-EZ, sind das die Red...
Ja, da hab ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht...
3 TB Säge und davon available nur noch 1,76. Da hast du schon wieder die Hefte voll genagelt. Auf allen 4?
Nein, nein. Das ist nur die eine. Das ist sozusagen mein Working-Set. Da ist mein ganzer Studio, Recordings, Climbing.
Und die anderen sind noch leer.
Und die anderen sind im Prinzip leer. Wobei, ich hab die jetzt erstmal so zusammengeraded, um sie erstmal in Betrieb zu nehmen und einfach mal Time Machine drauf gemacht. Also ich benutze sie vor allem als internes Time Machine. Backup, damit ich einfach immer ein schnelles und halbwegs zuverlässiges Time Machine hab. Und irgendwann soll dann sozusagen, sobald ich die Büchse mal auf 10.8 geaktualisiert habe, vielleicht dann vielleicht den Hauptkram auch nochmal auf Fusion Drive umstellen und dann eben nochmal ein zusätzliches externes Time Machine vielleicht auch nochmal mit dazu machen, weil man kann irgendwie nicht genug Backups haben.
Da gab's glaube ich auch in unserem Kommentarumfeld nochmal, in welcher Leute, weiß ich, oder wartet ihr bei Mobile Max in den Kommentaren, jedenfalls so die Frage, wie man Time Machine und so, wie man Fusion Drive macht und trotzdem noch eine Rescue-Partition hat und so weiter und so fort. Hat man das schonmal angesprochen oder so?
Nee, das hab ich gerade durch, weil ich das...
Aber du weißt, wie das geht. Ja, kann ich dir sagen.
Und zwar das Besondere...
Aber das wolltest du dir anbieten, weil ich es auch gerade neulich gemacht habe.
Ja, du kannst mich ja korrigieren. Also meines Wissens ist einfach das Ding so, wenn du jetzt vorher so mit dem normalen Disk-Utility, wenn du da so RAID machst, dann nimmst du halt immer die ganze Platte. Und wenn du da auf Kommando-Zeite dieses Fusion Drive mit dem Core Storage Layer benutzt, dann kannst du da auch direkt auf Partitions gehen. Vielleicht geht es mit Disk-Utility auch, ich weiß nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall der Clou ist, dass man eben vorher eine, also die SSD vorher partitioniert, da ein Gigabyte quasi Partition frei macht und dann das Fusion Drive mit der zweiten Partition und der anderen Festplatte macht.
Also Fusion Drive aus einer Partition und einem vollen Drive.
Aber du kannst die Rescue-Partition nicht auf die Festplatte machen?
Doch, kannst du auch, ist egal.
Ist wurscht.
Du kannst auch zwei Rescue-Partitions machen.
Habe ich jetzt nicht ausprobiert, keine Ahnung. Aber so kann man das machen.
Aber wie gesagt, der Knaller ist genau deine Aussage. Nämlich, dass viele Leute dachten, man kann immer nur ganze Drives zusammenbündeln zu einem Fusion Drive. Und das war halt einfach keine Ahnung, wo diese Aussage herkommt. Das ist definitiv falsch. Du kannst einfach auch eine Partition oder mehrere Partitions oder komplette Drives kannst du beliebig kombinieren und die in einen Fusion Drive reinschmeißen. Und er macht halt was draus. Und die Rescue-Partition darf halt nicht in einem Fusion Drive liegen. Aber kann man denn im Fusion Drive mehr als zwei machen? Das habe ich noch nicht. Also es gibt nichts, kein Kommando, was dir das verbietet. Ich habe es bloß noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also was geht, was ich ja gemacht habe, ist, wenn du das Fusion Drive einmal hergestellt hast, kannst du die Bootcamp-Partitionen davon abtrennen. Also du hast das Fusion Drive hergestellt und hast installiert und sagst dann dem Bootcamp-Manager, hier Bootcamp. Gut, du hast ja das Problem, dass du kein CD, DVD-Laufwerk mehr hast. Zumindest auf dem Macbook Pro. Aber du kannst einfach dem sagen, hier, partitionier mir das mal. Mach mal da 100 GB runter für Windows und dann macht der.
Du hast ja wie gesagt, das Fusion Drive ist ja wieder ein logical Drive, was du wieder partitionieren kannst. Nur was man da eben nicht drauf machen kann, ist du kannst da keine Rescue-Partitionen drauf machen.
Nein, nein, er partitioniert ja nicht das Fusion Drive, sondern er macht ja die, also auf der Festplatte macht er ja den Teil, der Fusion Drive ist kleiner und macht dann in der Festplatte dann halt eine neue Partition für Windows.
Wenn man angenommen, ich hab schon irgendwie eine 2 TB Platte oder so und will nachträglich Fusion Drive machen, geht das oder muss man alles umkopieren?
Du musst leider alles umkopieren.
Du musst das Platten machen, ja. Das ist wie eine neue Partition machen.
Weil du legst noch so ein Layer dazwischen. Du hast ja jetzt momentan auf der physikalischen Platte deine Partitionierung und nicht dieses Core Storage dazwischen. Du musst dieses Core Storage dazwischen kriegen. Das kriegst du nicht unter ein laufendes Qualsystem.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt normalerweise sich normal eine Platte irgendwie anlegt und die dann eine Weile benutzt, dann ist noch kein Core Storage da. Weil solange man nur Standard Half-S benutzt, hat man gar kein Core Storage darunter.
Wenn du schlau genug bist, kannst du dir gleich das Core Storage anlegen, wenn du sagst, ich will dir später noch was machen. Doch, du kannst ja ein Core Storage aus einem Wolken machen.
Das Core Storage wird angelegt, wenn du 5V anmachst. Dann legt er ein Core Storage-Layer dazwischen, mit dem er die Verschlußung macht.
Ja, aber dann kann ich trotzdem nicht nachträglich einen Fusion-Arch-PVM machen.
Nee, weil der wieder drunter liegen würde. Du musstest einmal auf deinen Backup-Platte rüberknuckeln und dann wieder reinstallieren.
Was mache ich denn jetzt mit meinem 3x3-TB-Bank?
4x3 dachte ich.
Na, eine ist hier also normaler Müll.
Die eine ist eigentlich die Primärplatte, die ich gerne mit der SSD noch zu einer Fusion Drive verheiraten will, aber das geht ja erst ab 10.8.2. Und aus technischen Gründen fährt dieser Rechner noch auf 10.7.
Soll ich dir das schnell klicken, wenn er nicht drauf ist?
Ich dachte aus Datenschutzgründen.
Ich habe mir das schon mal geklickt und dann war mein Setup im Arsch. Das Problem ist, dass ich hier…
Weil du geklickt hast.
Nein, weil ich Schwierigkeiten hatte hier mit dem Dante-Netzwerk und dem 10.8.
Also was machst du mit deinen drei Platten? Da machst du deinen Backup rein von der ersten Platte, wie gerade beschrieben, damit du nämlich deine erste Platte frei hast, um mit Fusion Drive reinzumachen.
Ja gut, aber sagen wir mal, ich habe das dann auch schon getan. Du hast sozusagen die intelligenteste, sinnvollste Nutzung. Ich meine, schreit so ein bisschen nach ZFS, oder? Du schüttelst den Kopf.
ZFS auf dem Mac, ich weiß nicht. Schönes Spielzeug, aber…
Die fällt dir jetzt vom Glauben ab, oder was?
Nein, ZFS ist super toll und ich würde auch natürlich auf meinem Mac ZFS benutzen, wenn ich eine Platte habe, wo mal irgendwie ZFS-Sachen drauf sind, damit ich sie lesen kann. Aber um dauerhaft meine Sachen drauf zu speichern, weil beim Mac habe ich öfter mal irgendwie, dann geht wieder irgendwas nicht und sonst wie. Ich habe da noch nicht so das Vertrauen irgendwie. Auch müssten da öfter mal irgendwie Updates kommen oder sonst wo, und ich müsste wissen, dass die Leute sich da weiterhin aktiv kümmern und so. Das ist irgendwie gerade nicht der Fall. Also dazu ist dieses Fallsystem doch… Das ist jetzt nicht wirklich Rocket Science, aber es ist auch nicht ganz easy peasy. Da muss schon einer sein, der irgendwie sich auch weiterhin um Probleme kümmert und so und das sehe ich auf dem Mac gerade nicht so richtig leider.
Gut, dann kann ich kurz hier ein Reingrätschen. Und zwar mal wieder haben ein paar Leute angefangen, ZFS auf dem Mac zu portieren. Und zwar ist das jetzt die ZFS on Linux Fraktion. Ja, und zwar die haben ja das Problem, dass sie ja ZFS mit GNU-Code verheiraten müssen. Das heißt, die müssen peinlich genau ein Layer dazwischen machen.
Aber wieso? Solange sie es nicht mit dem Kernel zusammen ausliefern, ist denen doch alles egal. Darum ging es doch, oder?
Ja, aber irgendwie waren die also relativ krass dabei und haben halt einen wirklich krassen Layer zwischen Linux und ZFS gemacht. Und sind jetzt die, die gesagt haben... Was denn für ein Layer? Naja, ein Layer, mit dem du ZFS an den Kernel adaptierst. Ja, nicht nur License, auch technischer Adapter-Layer, aber so beides. Und der Layer ist halt, wie soll ich sagen, am dicksten. Der scheint so am meisten zu isolieren zwischen ZFS und dem Betriebssystem. Während es ja bei Solaris ist ja mehr oder weniger komplett ineinander gewachsen. Bei FreeBSD haben sie ja auch am Kernel rumgeschraubt, nur um ZFS unterstützen zu können. Und bei Linux haben sie eben nicht am Kernel geschraubt, sondern haben alles in den Layer getan. Sie sind jetzt der Meinung, wir haben den besten Layer und wir können unseren Layer jetzt besser an OS X anpassen als alle anderen, die in dem Boot sitzen. Und deswegen haben sie jetzt angefangen, ihren Layer zu portieren. Sie sind jetzt so weit, dass er zumindest mal zu großen Teilen kombiniert. Also da ist noch nicht so viel passiert, aber ich finde das sehr spannend, dass gerade aus dem Lager jetzt Leute ankommen und sagen, das ist eigentlich ein interessantes Problem. Lass uns das mal angehen.
Oder welcher Lizenz ist ihr Kram dann?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Ich schmeiße das mal in den Chat. Es gibt da ein GitHub-Repository, das irgendwas tut. Keine Ahnung, was da jetzt genau tut. Aber man sieht, 10h ago, da passiert auf jeden Fall mal irgendwas.
Na dann brauchen wir die Hoffnung ja noch nicht aufgeben.
Gut, deshalb beantwortet er jetzt aber noch nicht die Frage, was ich mit meinen drei Platten machen soll.
Porn-Game-Videos.
Also ich habe ja sozusagen die Möglichkeit, mit drei Platten nur irgendwie striped oder Concatenated zu machen, dann habe ich da irgendwie die vollen neun. Oder die Miroir, dann habe ich halt irgendwie nur drei.
Ja, aber wenn der Concatenated ist, hast du auch das Problem, wenn einer irgendwie rumkackt, ja dann hast du die anderen auch nicht mehr so richtig...
Ist mir schon klar, ich könnte ja auch so ein RAID 5 machen, aber das geht ja mit den Bordmitteln vom Mac jetzt auch nicht.
Die Frage ist, was willst du darauf abspeichern? Willst du darauf temporär viel Scheiße abspeichern und das möglichst schnell? Oder möchtest du einen Storage haben, wo du sagst, der ist so sicher, was ich darauf speicher, geht mir nie verloren?
Na ja, beides wäre halt eigentlich ganz geil.
Ich will immer alles.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn da so netto 6TB bei rauskommen würden, wäre ich jetzt auch erstmal ganz zufrieden. Ich finde aber auch den Gedanken, dreimal so viel Kapazität in diesem Backup-Medium zu haben, wie in dem originalen Medium, auch ganz gut, weil dann kann ich nämlich sowohl da jetzt so meine ganzen Incremental-Backups reinmachen mit großen Dateien, Recordings und so weiter, eine Sendung hier, mal wieder 10GB auf Platte weggenuschelt. Und auch mal schnell noch mal was auslagern und umkopieren und Pippa-Bow und was Dickes auspacken und so. Naja, das ist halt so.
Also was vielleicht, dir schwer durch die Denke geht, aber kannst du vielleicht auch mal überlegen, ob du eine Platte einfach als Speer vorsiehst.
Ungenutzt?
Also ich habe ja neulich gesprochen über diesen Thunderbolt Pegasus-Teil da, diese Promise Pegasus. Das ist ja auch ein R6, den wir da haben in der Druckerei. Und eine Platte davon habe ich explizit als Speer vorgesehen. Das stammt noch so aus meiner Erfahrung, als ich früher so mit Zahn-Hardware rumgebastelt habe oder so. Weil das ist nämlich durchaus praktisch, wenn das Ding seine Redondanz wieder selber herstellen kann, ohne dass es erst darauf wartet, dass ihm jemand eine neue Platte reinschiebt, wenn was kaputt gegangen ist.
Aber das kann doch die Bordmittel nicht führen, ne?
Doch, kann das Mac-Gezeugs nicht auch eine Sperrplatte vorsehen? Müssen wir jetzt mal nachgucken.
Ich kann natürlich jetzt ein Mirror aufmachen über alle drei, dann habe ich drei.
Dann mirrerst du drei, das ist aber schreibmäßig nicht so schlau. Das könnte dir deine Lesegeschichte noch deutlich verschnellern, aber das Schreiben wird dadurch nicht besser, wenn du das dreimal schreibst. Ja, vor allem der Platz ist halt so.
Aber Mirror ist schon eigentlich das coolste Relundanzsystem.
Mirror, was die Relundanz angeht, cool. Aber wie gesagt, wenn du dann noch eine Sperrplatte hast, dann heilt sich das System auch vorne alleine. Dein Ding ist ja eh den ganzen Tag an, oder? Also auch wenn du mal wieder auf Reisen bist oder so was?
Wie funktioniert dann das Syncing unter... Also ist ja ein Software-Mirror dann hier von Mac. Ich weiß nicht, wie deren Syncing funktioniert, wenn mal eine Platte mal kurz nicht da war.
Ich glaube, besonders intelligent ist das jetzt nicht so.
Also mein Mac Mini, ich habe ja diverse davon. Ich habe ja auch einen Amilan zu stehen, der auf so einem Root-Nameserver da steht. Und davon hat es mal eine Platte weggeratzt, von den internen. So richtig weg. Und ich hatte einen Mirror drauf, und der hat nicht gezuckt, der lief einfach weiter. Er hat mir so eine Mail geschickt, die ist so... Mir ist dann ein Eingeweide gestorben. Aber ich mache hier mal weiter. Also immerhin, so weit sind sie schon mal. Also ich kenne auch andere Relundanzsysteme, auch habe ich auch schon entdeckt, die du wahnsinnig teuer einkaufen musst. Und dann geht dann einfach die zweite Not aus Solidarität mit der ersten runter. Weil sie sind ja in SYNC. Und wenn die erste stirbt, dann muss die zweite natürlich auch sterben.
Viel schlimmer ist, wenn eine Platte kaputt ist, und der Rechner bootet auch und kommt wieder hoch. Und der ist der Meinung, dass die kaputte Platte die ist, die gerade funktioniert. Oder er synkt halt von der kaputten auf eine neue, weißt schon.
Also diese halb kaputten, bei mir war das glücklicherweise so, dass diese eine Platte richtig komplett gestorben ist. Das heißt, da hat er ja gar keine Chance mehr, was falsch zu machen. Aber das fand ich schon mal ganz okay, dass er wirklich im laufenden Betrieb einfach sagt, mir ist hier gerade was verstorben, schade drum, aber ich mach mal weiter. Das fand ich schon mal ganz okay.
Wie viel Schreibspeed und so weiter, was hast du denn so für Anforderungen eigentlich?
Das ist einfach für mich gar nicht so der Punkt. Ich hab mir jetzt auch nicht so die super hochdrehenden Platten, sondern die sollen vor allem leise sein. Das ist für mich das Widerstand.
Green Series ist ja genau richtig dafür. Wobei, für Nostorage man ja diese Red Series holt, ne?
Weil?
Na, weil, gute Frage.
Weil die nicht hängen bleiben. Das ist doch dieser Fehler-Timeout. Also, die Green Series, die, wenn die einen Blog nicht lesen können oder irgendein anderes Problem haben, dann versuchen sie es noch ein paar Mal.
Bist du zwei Minuten?
Bist du zwei Minuten lang, bevor sie dann die Hufu hochnehmen. Und die Red Series, die sagt halt gleich, ist nicht.
Weil die geht davon aus, dass du halt einen Büro hast. Und jetzt stell dir vor, du hast eine Aufnahme hier am Laufen, du willst irgendwie dein Audio aufnehmen und du hast dann zwei Minuten lang, kann deine Daten nicht wegspeichern. Du hast da gerade oder ein Video oder so. Und du musst gerade wegspeichern, weil sonst dein Programm dir platzt. Und das kannst du dir keine zwei Minuten leisten.
Dafür braucht man gleich eine andere Platte? Das kann sein, dass es nicht reicht.
Das ist nicht eine andere Platte. Da ist auch wieder nur eine andere Firmenwehr drin, die dafür sorgt, dass die Fehlermeldung ein Stück schneller kommt. Aber das braucht man schon.
Das ist eine edlere Firmenwehr. Da muss man schon 30 Euro mehr für bezahlen.
So viel ist nicht. Das sind meistens 10 Euro oder so. Außerdem ist es halt schick rot. Das ist der Farbenwichtig und so, haben wir ja vorhin gehört. Cars Radio zum Beispiel, hier. Cars Radio CCCD habe ich ja hier mich gekümmert. Und dann habe ich auch zwei rote geholt. Und die rockt jetzt wieder die Kiste. Das hast du ja mitbekommen. Da geht jetzt alles wieder. ZS wäre es natürlich.
Ich habe in meinem FreeBSD-Server 6 x 2 TB in einem RAID Z2 drin. 6 x 2 TB in einem RAID Z2. Das sind dann 8.
Bleiben 4 Datenplatten übrig. 4 x 2, 8.
Genau.
Also RAID Z2 heißt, wo zwei Platten dann redundant sind.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt ja schon einen RAID Z3 sogar.
Und Geschwindigkeit ist da überhaupt kein Thema.
Aber schnell ist auch nicht, oder?
Naja, das ist halt ein Atomboard und da passen halt maximal 4 GB Speicher drauf. Deswegen ist er speichermäßig immer an der Oberkante. Ansonsten, also der Prozessor, der eidet irgendwie bei 5% Last, wenn ich da das Ding voll ausfahre. Ja, nee, nee, ein anderes.
Aber eins von den aktuellen. Also nicht ganz.
Ja, von diesen 525.
Probier mal ein 4 GB Modul reinzustecken. Ein Kumpel hat das gemacht und der hatte plötzlich 6 GB. Also ein 2er war noch drin. Also das Ding kann noch mehr, es steht nur nicht da, muss man ausprobieren.
Der Chat beschwert sich für uns schon die ganze Zeit auch wie ich finde durchaus zu Recht, dass sie sagen, ein Backup gehört in ein anderes Gerät oder in ein anderes Haus.
Stimmt ja auch.
Auch.
Okay.
Ja, ich mache sowieso meine Backups mit ARK auf S3. Also die Daten an sich sind erstmal so safe außerhalb und so weiter. Wenn jetzt hier alles brennt, dann…
Ja, brennt oder reicht das schon, wenn der Nachbar über dir seinen Badeband stöpselt, nicht?
Was auch immer. Also ich kann auch irgendwie von woanders meinen kompletten Datenbestand recovern. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, du willst aber auch schnell und auch mal ohne Internet…
In der Time-Machine blättern.
In der Time-Machine blättern können. Und dann willst du auch nicht auf so eine lahmarschige Time-Capsule warten, die einen Arsch nicht hochkriegt und wo du dann irgendwie immer so Cursor hoch und dann so zehn Sekunden später schält sich dann immer wieder so ein Dateilisting irgendwie über deinen Bildschirm. Das macht irgendwie auch keinen Spaß.
Deswegen finde ich einfach die lokalen Power.
Ja, und nach genau, spätestens drei Monaten kommt dir dieses Teil entweder mit ich bin voll oder die Integrität konnte nicht sichergestellt werden. Um mich meiner Integrität zu versichern, lösche ich jetzt am besten mal alles.
Ja, den Screenshot, den er jetzt gestern auf Twitter hatte, war das bei Holgi? Das habe ich auch schon ein tausendmal gehabt.
Wir waren dann so, oh ja, okay, das waren jetzt die Backups der letzten zwei Jahre. Scheiß drauf. Ich mache dir ein neues.
Am Ende des Tages ist halt wieder ein Half-SQS-System drunter.
Time Machine, ich meine, das ist eine geile Time Machine. Da setzt du dich rein, drehst an dem Schalter irgendwie auf minus 2000 BC, und dann sagt er, ja, ich kann aber nur bis 1974. Das ist auch sehr schön. Geile Time Machine.
Da könnte man auch schon was mit anstellen.
Na ja, super spannender Spielfilm, der da rauskommt. Na gut, 1974 hatte er auch schon was.
Ja, das ist aber auch ein Problem von diesem, wenn Time Machine auf ein Server back-up't, dann legt er dort ja immer ein...
Sparse Bundle....
ein Bundle an, also ein Disk Image, was ein Sparse Bundle ist. Und das kann mal kaputt gehen. Ich kann das mal raussuchen, ich hab da so einen Blogpost irgendwann mal gefunden, wie man den in der Regel wieder repariert kriegt.
Und wie gesagt...
Da muss man ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen, je nachdem, wie schnell die Kiste ist.
Selbst das ist schon ein roher Ei, aber auch das liegt auf einem HFS-Plus-File-System. Das Sparse Bundle liegt bei dir nicht auf dem HFS-Plus-File-System?
Ich finde ja, so ein lokales ZFS, was mit so einem Remote...
Aber in dem Sparse Bundle ist wieder ein HFS-Plus-File-System drin, wollte ich nur sagen.
Also solange du die Platten ja noch alle umbenutzt hast, kannst du ja mal so ein ZFS Experiment wagen. Kannst du einfach mal so testen.
Ja, also...
Dann machst du drei Platten...
Also wie gesagt, ich kenne mal den Link in den Chat.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall für Tests machen würde, ist, also du machst zum Beispiel ein RAID-Set. Und dann ein Test wäre auf jeden Fall auch auf dem Mac irgendwie Platten rausziehen, shuffeln und wieder reinstecken und neu starten, gucken, ob auch alles genauso wiederfindet. Sollte eigentlich mit Leichtigkeit gehen, aber testen würde ich es trotzdem. Und dann würde ich halt auch testen, was passiert, wenn eine Platte kaputt ist und er sozusagen das mit zwei Platten irgendwie wieder an Start kriegen soll. Also bei ZFS auf Mac ist es gar nicht so, dass es funktioniert. Das traue ich dem alles zu. Ich will halt nur wissen, ob es in den Fehlerfällen genauso gut reagiert wie auf den anderen OSen. Da bin ich mir auf Mac eben nicht so sicher.
Und wenn du noch einen Bonus machen willst, dann nimmst du erstmal drei kleinere Platten, machst mit denen einen Pool. Und wenn du den Pool dann am Laufen hast, dann wechselst du Stück für Stück die kleineren Platten durch größere aus. Guckst nach, ob sich der Pool vergrößert, wenn du alle getauscht hast.
Z-Pool Replace, kleine Platte, große Platte, und dann legt er los. Muss ja nicht voll sein, dein Testsystem, dann ist er auch ganz schnell dabei, weil ZFS kopiert ja nur das, was wirklich belegt ist. Also das ist ja das Schöne an ZFS. Da auch so ein Sync zum Beispiel geht ratzfatz, wo andere komische Syncs immer die ganze Platte syncen, ob da nun Daten drin sind oder nicht, wissen die halt nicht und ZFS weiß das.
Ja, für solche Sachen ist es schon das File-System, das man haben will.
Das ist eigentlich für alle Sachen das File-System, das man haben will.
Nicht für ganz alle, aber...
Ja, die große Frage ist, werden wir jetzt in den nächsten Tagen einen Mac OS 10.9 sehen? Also erstmal ist die Frage, werden wir überhaupt mal...
10.3.8 wäre schon mal... 10.8.3.
10.8.3 meine ich ja.
Tim ist beim nächsten OS gerade.
Ui, ich habe gar keinen Mac-Etext gehört. Haben wir das wieder aufgegeben?
Ich habe bisher nur ein einziges Vögelchen zwitschern hören.
Zum Thema 10.9? Und?
Und?
Das waren wirklich gute Nachrichten.
Wirst du noch konkreter?
Ich überlege gerade, wie konkret ich jetzt gerade werden kann.
Mach mal kurz den Stream aus.
Du hast Vögelchen, die zwitschern nicht so, dass du...
Ich habe mir gerade überlegt, was sozusagen der... Also mir ist gerade eingefallen, dass sozusagen nicht explizit gesagt wurde, wie der Informationsweitergabe-Codex so aussieht. Deswegen muss ich den jetzt mal kurz, wie sagt man das schön, inferieren.
Du wartest jetzt auf eine SMS, oder was?
Nein, nein. Tatsächlich warte ich schon den ganzen Tag auf eine SMS, weil irgendwie mein Telefon keine mehr empfängt. Heute irgendwie, ich habe noch keine einzige SMS bekommen.
Redest du von SMS oder IMS oder MMS oder iChat oder Java oder WhatsApp oder Join?
Clemens, kennst du SMS TAN? Wenn dein Telefon keine SMS empfängt, kannst du auch kein Online-Banking mehr machen.
Ich frage jetzt nur, du bist ein Profi, du benutzt die richtigen Termine.
Genau, deswegen bin ich ja auch in diesem Podcast.
Wenn er die richtigen Termine benutzen würde, dann hätte er ja nicht gesagt, dass er noch keine SMS empfangen hat, weil man kann den Service nicht empfangen, sondern nur die SMS.
Er benutzt sogar den richtigen Plural von Terminus. Das muss man mal sagen.
Ich habe gehört, und sagen wir mal, auch noch wird hier ein gesteigertes Gerücht, dass Apple tatsächlich in diesem Audio-Segment das so beheben will, dass Kanalauswahl, also Device-Auswahl, Audio-Device-Auswahl und Kanalauswahl auch noch irgendwie in diese AV-Foundation-Layer reinkrabbelt.
Da waren wir nicht gerade bei Fallsystemen. Das ist ja jetzt voll der Themenwechsel hier.
Naja, ich wollte jetzt mal das Thema auf die nächsten Betriebssysteme lenken.
Du hast gerade eine SMS bekommen.
Ich habe eine SMS bekommen?
Ah, doch. Konnte ich dir das vorher sagen? Das Netz sagt man, das nehme ich. Willkommen im Land der Delivery-Notifications.
Ich brauche von meinen Banken keinen Empfanger.
Oder jemand.
Hast du dein Passwort bei der Bank geändert?
Nein, ich habe ein neues iPhone 5. Das andere war ja schon drei Monate alt. Und da ist das heutzutage ja durch, so ein iPhone. Also da war dann der einen Ausschalter im Arsch. War das bei dir nicht auch so?
Ja, oben, das geht fast gar nicht.
Genau, ich habe jetzt wieder... Ich habe jetzt neu.
Hast du angerufen und gesagt, hier, was ist los, Jungs?
Ich bin dahin gefahren.
Wohin, nach München? Nur für ein neues iPhone?
Nee, Hamburg.
Nur für ein neues iPhone?
Nicht nur für ein neues iPhone.
Wie heißt es? Ach die.
Ja, da war ich auch schon.
Ja, siehst du mal. Deswegen war ich in Hamburg und deswegen bin ich da gleich mal vorbeigelatscht und habe kommentarlos ein neues Gerät in die Hand gedruckt bekommen. Das dauerte keine Sekunde, da Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten.
Irgendwer meint, der zu mir, dass man auch anrufen kann und dann kriegt man auch ein neues. Aber du musst erst eins einchecken. Aber wenn du 30 Euro bezahlst, dann schicken sie dir erst sogar eins und dann musst du... Wie, nee, hat mir einer so gesagt.
Wenn du 30 Euro zahlst, dann... Dann kriegst du Vorabtausch. Dann kommt der Boote. Dann kannst du, während der Boote da ist, das auspacken. Du kannst dein altes einpacken und dann nimmst du es gleich wieder mit.
Ach so sogar? Das heißt, ich muss nicht mal das Haus verlassen?
Nee, ein Kollege von mir, neulich gemacht.
Wenn du dein altes Schnellgeluch gelöscht kriegst.
Das heißt, wenn der klingelt, irgendwie so lange habe ich es am Stecker, wenn ich weiß, dass er kommt, wenn der klingelt, zieh es ab, Backup sozusagen, das gerade frisch beendet, mach es aus, drück noch einmal alles hier, mach dich, mach dich alle, mach dich, mach dich, mach dich, löscht dich, löscht dich weg und gib ihm das und nehm das Neue, steck ran und...
Naja, wie das bei diesen OBS-Leuten ist, die sind natürlich ein bisschen nervös, wenn es länger dauert, aber im Prinzip geht das ja.
Ja, ich kann da...
Ein Kollege von mir gemacht vor ein paar Tagen.
Naja, also nochmal zurück auf die 10 neuen Geschichten. Wann denkt ihr, kommt das jetzt irgendwie?
Das Beta oder das 10 neue selbst? Der normale Zyklus.
Die Ankündigung davon.
Also der normale Zyklus wäre jetzt im Sommer irgendwann WWDC. Zur WWDC wird es vorgestellt, die Entwickler kriegen die allererste super wackelige Beta und irgendwann im Herbst ist es dann in den Online-Läden.
Ich rede aber von der Ankündigung.
Aber die Ankündigung haben wir immer schon vor dem WWDC, genau.
Immer ist gut.
Also ich sage mal so, warum sollte Apple irgendwas vor Ankündigung, bevor sie den Entwicklern eine Beta geben? Weil sie das letztes Jahr auch so gemacht haben. Ja, gut, da hatten sie aber auch zur Ankündigung auch direkt den Entwicklern die Beta gegeben. Die konnte man dann quasi direkt runterladen. Kann natürlich sein, dass es jetzt im April oder im Mai dann schon die entsprechende Ankündigung plus runterladen und so weiter gibt.
Ja, vielleicht dauert das auch deshalb mit dem 10.8.3 so lange. Ist ja auch alles nur geraten.
Also, wo ist denn nun dein...
Komm, wenn du jetzt schon Vögelchen hast, die mit dir oder auch nicht über Features diskutieren, was ist denn dein Guess so?
Bezüglich was?
Naja, that coming out von 10.0. Wann oder was?
Na, bezüglich des Wanns gehe ich jetzt davon aus, dass es jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauert, bis sie da mal rauskommen. Und ehrlich gesagt...
Also, sie kommt noch vor 10.8.3.
Na, ich würde es jetzt nicht wundern, wenn das relativ zeitgleich wäre. Aber das muss auch nicht so sein. Das ist jetzt einfach geraten. Da habe ich einfach überhaupt keine Daten, keine Anhaltspunkte, nichts. Aber es ist halt auch überhaupt erschreckend still gerade. Also, es schreit geradezu nach Breaking News.
Du meinst, wir sollten jetzt Sendepause machen, wenn es nur ein paar Wochen oder so.
Oder noch schlimmer, wir reden mal nicht über Macs. Wir schweigen jetzt einfach so lange, bis jetzt den neuen angekündigt wird. Das macht sie total fertig. Einfach so ein teutonisches Schweigen.
Das fängt Druck auf.
Das Einzige, was hier gerade teutonisch schweigt, ist dein Internet-Himm.
Ja, ja, aber wir sollen nicht über abgebrochene Streams reden.
Verstehe, na dann reden wir einfach weiter. Wenn wir jetzt schon mal bei den Vögelchen sind, hast du denn noch...
Das ist wieder los, ey, das ist doch echt scheiße.
Ich dachte nicht vor allem.
Jetzt kannst du mal analysis machen, bitte. Machen Sie mal, Herr Schrümpfe, bitte zur Analyse. Interessanterweise ist hier auch die Verbindung zu meinen iPads abgebrochen. Ist das hier vielleicht ein...
Lokales Problem? Gibt es dann News zum QDAM-Store?
Keine neuen.
Das heißt, alles liegt im Zeitplan. Jetzt geht's wieder.
Das letzte war Mai, ne?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, Mai war die letzte Aussage, wann das Ding irgendwie rauskommen soll.
Also ich hab wieder ein Netz, das geht wieder alles.
Ich auch. Aber Tim, du müsstest mir jetzt noch mal kurz Zugriff geben auf die Klasse Fritze Boxer.
Ja, ja, ich weiß das gerade nicht so auswendig. Das sind alles so komisch generierte Passwörter, weißt du? Verstehe.
Was ist denn gerade noch so Thema dann?
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz hier den Herrn Dingsbums ein Passwort geben.
Ich seh es.
Das wollte ich ja nebenbei noch mal erwähnen. Ich hab's vorhin schon im Chat gepostet. Es gibt von der Firma, die diesen Unigine-Grafik-Engine macht, gibt's einen neuen Benchmark. Vorher hieß der ja Heaven. War so ein OpenGL-Benchmark, der ist eigentlich ganz schick. Da gibt's auch eine neue Version. Jetzt gibt's einen, der heißt Hell? Nee, jetzt haben sie einen rausgebracht, der Valley heißt. Der ist ein bisschen langweilig, weil er so ein bisschen Alpenoptik hat, so mit Bergen und Wiesen und Bäumchen und so. Aber du hast eine ziemlich weite Sicht und die ist trotzdem alles gerendert. Wenn jemand einen Mac Pro hat, zum Beispiel, mit einer ordentlichen Grafikkarte, hint, hint, dann kann man sich den mal angucken, der sieht eigentlich ganz schick aus. Oder auf dem PC kann man da ein dickeres Equipment haben, kann man da mal gucken. Wie heißt das Ding?
Unigine?
Unigine heißt die Engine, die die machen und die bewerben sich selbst, indem sie auch immer so einen Benchmark haben. Und der heißt halt Valley, der neue. Und den kann man sich mal angucken. Für Leute, die gerne, es gibt ja auch so Fans von Benchmarks, die gerne Benchmarken.
Die gerne Benchmarks gucken.
Ja, wirklich, es gibt ganze Benchmarking-Clans, die gegeneinander antreten, wer den schnelleren Benchmarkwert hat. Ja, so ungefähr. Und die dann, weiß ich nicht, mit Overclocking und Flüssigkühlung und was weiß ich nicht, alles.
Ja, aus der Abteilung Verstörene Hardware gab es ja auch noch diese lustige Geschichte mit diesem Lightning HDMI-Adapter. Also das, was Apple verkauft, als dass man es doch an sein iPad ran bammle mit Lightning-Ausgang, damit es HDMI macht.
Gibt es eigentlich mal ein Bild, ich habe den immer nur zerrupft gesehen.
Ja, unten zerrupft sieht er halt aus, wie alle anderen Adapter auch. Groß, relativ groß und die Bude dabei Panic, die haben den mal auseinander geschraubt und damit so eine kleine Diskussion in ihrem Blog losgetreten, da sie festgestellt haben, dass da halt ein ARM-Stein drin ist und das hat sie irgendwie völlig verstört. Und man merkt auch, dass das voll die Software-Typen sind bei Panic, weil was sie da so hardware-mäßig irgendwie an Einschätzung von sich gegeben haben war teilweise ganz lustig. Wie auch immer, erst mal haben sie halt festgestellt, als sie mit diesem Adapter rumgespielt haben, dass der eben kein Full HD als Auflösung liefert, sondern maximal 1600 x 900 Pixel, also kein Full HD, während das bei dem alten Adapter so gewesen ist, den noch für Nicht-Lightning-Stecker. Und naja, dann sind sie da halt mal beigegangen und haben sich das genauer angeschaut und haben auch festgestellt, dass eben so, wenn sie eben mit Full HD oder wenn sie überhaupt da mit der höchsten Auflösung rausgehen, dass sie eben auch noch MPEG-Artefakte auf dem Bildschirm hatten. Also schließt dein iPad da an, lieferst irgendwie ein schönes, crispes Bild und kriegst aber kein crispes Bild, weil du halt diese typischen Artefakt-Pixel da irgendwie hast. Dann haben sie das Ding mal irgendwie auseinandergenommen, um mal rauszukriegen, was es damit so auf sich hat. Und sehe da, da ist halt so ein kleiner Armstein drauf. Sie mutmaßen, dass das Ding 2 GB RAM hat, das stimmt nicht. Das sind 2 GB, also 256 MB RAM, was heutzutage...
Was für ein Adapter schon ganz gut ist, oder?
Ja, gut, aber das... ja klar, aber das...
Ich glaube, ich habe keinen Adapter, der so viel RAM hat.
Sehr gut, da ist halt so ein richtiger SoC draußen, so ein System-on-a-Chip. Und wenn man sich halt mal überlegt, was der macht, wird das eigentlich auch relativ klar. Es gibt dann irgendwie 1000 Kommentare dazu. Und einer dieser Kommentare las ich so, als ob da irgendjemand, der da dran mitentwickelt hat, da mal kommentiert hat. Also klingt irgendwie so ein Kommentar, den ein normaler Apple-Mitarbeiter eigentlich nicht überleben dürfte. Ich weiß nicht, ob er nun wirklich einer ist, aber es klingt so.
Und er erzählt mal so ein bisschen, was da geht. Das ist, dass da halt ein XNU-Könnel, sprich das, was im Mac und im iPhone drin ist, bootet, der aber extrem gestrippt ist und deswegen nur irgendwie den Prozess startet, der halt Daten seriell über Lightning entgegennimmt und auf der anderen Seite als HDMI wieder rausbläst.
Genau. Im Prinzip ist das nämlich nichts anderes als so ein Konverter. Das heißt, die iPads mit Lightning schieben ihren Bildschirm schon MPEG-encoded raus. Das heißt, sie benutzen ihr normales H.264-Encoding, um den Bildschirm-Inhalt rüber zu streamen. Und der ARM-Stein auf diesem Adapter nimmt diesen seriellen Strom entgegen und setzt den dann eben auf HDMI um.
Das heißt, der Typ hat erzählt, dass das Lightning nichts weiter ist als eine Hochgeschwindigkeitsserielle. Und am Ende können sie das auspacken und in alle möglichen Formate irgendwie tun. Also HDMI, DisplayPort, sonst was.
Und sie können neue HDMI-Standards damit unterstützen.
Interessant fand ich das Detail, dass der Stein scheinbar kein Flash oder so drauf hat. Oder nur wenig. Aber die Software selber nur im RAM ist. Das heißt, wenn du den anstöpselst, scheint er als allererstes die Firmware runterzuladen, die er dann spielt. Da frag ich mich, wie lange es dauert, bis die Leute irgendwas Unsinniges drauf portieren. Linux. Wie Ping-Green-Betriebssysteme.
Ja, könnte spannend werden. Da fällt mir irgendwie ein, wenn so ein iPad auch USB kann. Kann man da auch so einen USB-Ethernet-Adapter anschließen? Bei Ethernet, das ist irgendwie so das, was man bei diesem iPad irgendwie...
Wenn die da HDMI aus dem Stecker raus holen können, dann können die da auch alles andere rausholen.
Könnten ist mir eigentlich schon klar, aber irgendwie... einen USB-Ethernet-Adapter unterstützt der nicht. Hab ich jetzt auch noch nicht gesehen, dass das schon mal jemand ausprobiert hätte.
Du meinst, du willst ein iPhone mit Ethernet haben?
Ein iPad.
Ja, ist doch das Gleiche.
Also beim alten iPad geht das. Da kannst du ja diesen Kameraadapter anstecken.
Ja, aber hast du da mal wirklich Ethernet angeschlossen?
Ach so, Ethernet noch nicht. Nein, USB kannst du halt anschließen.
Ja, wenn du so einen USB nachdenkst, dann hier diesen Stöpsel hier. Der hier liegt. Wenn du so was dann da rein steckst.
Ja, versuch's halt mal. Ich fürchte ja eher nicht.
Es kann wieder sein, dass er wieder sagt, da kommt nicht genug Power raus. Deswegen werden halt viele Dinge dort von diesem USB-Stöpsel verweigert. Immer mit der Ansage, ja, was du da gerade reinsteckt hast, wird der zu viel Strom haben.
Lieber Apple, die Scheiße haben ja nicht mal mein Radio, was ich mir mal für meinen alten iPod gekauft habe, auf dem iPhone unterstützt.
Warum sollte ein iPad kein Internet unterstützen?
Weil Onkel Steve das nicht will.
Du, keine Ahnung, die unterstützen ja auch MIDI-Interfaces und Audio-Interfaces. Wenn du das Richtige anstöpselst, hast du ein Audio-Interface, was funktioniert. Du nimmst uns jetzt das iPad weg.
Wir brauchen das gar nicht. Wir können das gar nicht mit umnehmen.
Wir machen schon mal die Kamera an, falls der weiße Rauch gleich rauskommt.
Haben wir sonst noch ein Thema? Soll ich kurz über das Bier sprechen, was ich hier trinke?
Das kannst du machen. Das war ein Geschenk eines Hörers.
Das ist ein Reckendorfer Henrique Bock.
Das angeschlossene USB-Gerät wird nicht unterstützt.
Das hat ein sehr lustiges Label mit so einem König drauf. Ja, schmeckt sehr malzig.
Stimmt.
Ist sehr süffig. Ja, sehr lecker. Könnte man mehr von trinken. Ja gut, ist ein Bock. Sollte man vielleicht nicht allzu viel von trinken. Sonst tut der Kopf am nächsten Tag ein bisschen weh.
Der ein bisschen bockig.
Aber lieber Hörer, der du das geschickt hast, ist ein lecker Bier. Kannst du mehr von schicken.
Ich würde mir mal Ethernet fürs iPad wünschen. Das fände ich mal richtig geil. Weil WLAN ist einfach, manchmal einfach nicht das Richtige.
Ja, dann musst du ja mal was ordentliches kaufen, nicht so ein Fritzbox-Scheiß.
Was?
Es gibt doch ordentliches WLAN.
Das Problem liegt nicht an der Fritzbox. Das Problem liegt daran, was du für Geräte hast und in welchen Frequenzbandern du rumspielst. Die Fritzbox ist ja immerhin schon so fair, jedenfalls die, die Tim hier hat, dass sie eben sogar noch einen 5 Gigahertz-Carrier gibt. Das ist schon mal der erste Step. Gerade wenn man hier in so einer hipster Gegend wohnt, wie Tim und Meta eben, wirst du ja zugekackt.
Bei mir gibt es auch 100.000 Netzwerke und ich kriege über 30 Megabyte über meinen WLAN drüber.
Über einen 5 Gigahertz WLAN. Im 2,4er glaube ich dir das nicht. Jedenfalls nicht im Innenstadtbereich.
Kann sein, ja. Und das iPad kann keine 5 Gigahertz, oder was?
Das 1er nicht. Doch, doch, das 1er kann das auch schon.
Das 1er kann das auch schon.
Das 1er kann das auch schon. Das iPad kann 5 Gigahertz. Ja, aber die alten iPhones nicht.
Genau, das neue.
Aber ein iPhone 5 kann auch 5 Gigahertz. Und das brauchst du wirklich echt. Ich habe beim Freund, da saß ich gerade gestern in Potsdam, ganz verzweifelt, sein neuer totaler, super schöner MacBook Air und alles und alle VDSL-Anschluss. Und er sagte, er kann nicht mal irgendwelche doofen Autoscout-24-Seiten anklicken, weil er mitten beim Bilderladen hängen bleibt. Dann bin ich mal hingefahren, habe mir das mal angeguckt. Er und seine Nachbarn, seine 50 Nachbarn, sitzen alle auf Kanal 11 im 2,4 Gigahertz Band. Auto heißt bei denen auch nur random Zufall, dass sie sich in die Stationen nehmen, oder? Da gibt es ein paar Sachen, die man dazu wissen muss. Wenn wir jetzt schon damit gerade anfangen, die ask for it. Diese Autogeschichte funktioniert nur, wenn du so ein Ding startest. Die buchen sich, die sind nicht so schlau, dass wenn sie jetzt schon 2 Jahre am Stück am Strom sind und auch nicht gebotet wurden, und inzwischen deine Nachbarn den selben Funkkanal vollkacken, dass sie dann sagen, dann ziehe ich jetzt mal um. Das machen die nicht. Sondern die gucken nur einmal beim Booten, wo sieht es hier gut aus. Das kann natürlich auch zu einer Tageszeit sein.
Aber immerhin machen sie das.
Also eine Fritzbox macht das, das machen auch nicht alle. Aber eine Fritzbox macht das und einen Cisco-Router kann man auch dazu bringen. Und was die anderen so machen, die netten Gäste dieser Welt, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich denke, die horchen auch zumindest mal rein, was es da gibt. Dann gibt es noch folgenden beliebten Fehler. Die Leute sehen, ah, ich habe ja 13 Kanäle, zumindest wir haben hier 13 Kanäle. Das ist auch noch so ein Special. Die Amis haben nämlich nur 11 Kanäle. Das ist, wenn man dann Freunde aus Amerika zum Suche hat, die ihr Gerät aufklappen und dann sagen, ich finde deinen WLAN gar nicht. Dann solltest du mal gucken, ob dein lokales WLAN auf 12 oder 13 läuft, weil das sehen die nämlich gar nicht. Unter Umständen. Aber trotzdem, diese Kanäle überlappen sich alle, gerade mit den Geschwindigkeiten, die wir benutzen, also mit diesem Endstandard und so. Also kannst du in dem 2,4 GHz Band eigentlich nur 3 Kanäle benutzen, nämlich 1, 6 und 11. Weil alles andere überlappt sich wie so. Das wissen aber Leute nicht und sagen sich, oh, hm, meine Nachbarn sitzen ja alle auf 1, gegen auf 2. Und das ist schädlicher, als wenn du dich auch noch auf die 1 setzt. Das liegt nämlich daran, dass wenn du sozusagen, wenn alle in dem gleichen Kanal sind, dann erkennen die sich auch alle gegenseitig. Dann passiert richtig dieses schöne CSMA-CD-Verfahren, wenn du auf dem Nachbarkanal bist, dann störst du zwar sozusagen die Frequenz, aber du wirst nicht mehr gehört. Das ist sozusagen der Unterschied, wenn wir jetzt hier in einem Raum sitzen, machen wir CSMA-CD, weil wir uns verstehen. Aber wenn jetzt jemand in der Wohnung über uns, sozusagen auf Kanal 2 seine Bohrmaschine anmacht, dann stört die einfach nur. Oder wenn der bullt, weil wir verstehen die nicht und der versteht uns auch nicht. Das heißt, man kann sich mit denen auch nicht koordinieren, aber sie stören sich halt trotzdem. Deswegen ist es in einer solchen Situation schlauer, wenn man nicht anders kann, als im 2,4 GHz-Band überhaupt zu spielen, dann wenigstens denselben Kanal zu benutzen. Also wenn du jetzt nicht einen hast, der 5 weiter weg ist, also wie gesagt 1, 6 und 11 sind die einzigen, die man benutzen kann normalerweise, ohne Überlappung. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann setze dich lieber noch auf allen drauf, als gerade so daneben, weil gerade so daneben ist schlimmer.
Ja, aber gerade, also wo, welchen Kanal der da aus ist, ist ja egal, weil die alle anderen ja sowieso auch trotzdem 2, 3, 4 und 5 und 7 und so benutzen. Also du hast sowieso immer welche auch neben dir.
Du hast eigentlich heutzutage gerade in den vielbevölkerten, in den Gegenden der Stadtwirteln, hast du ein 2,4 Gigahertz Band. Je nach Tageszeit hast du einfach auch verloren. Das ist einfach Quatsch. Deswegen finde ich es auch gut, dass Apple jetzt mit allen neuen Geräten, inklusive iPhone, jetzt auch diese 5 Gigahertz Nummer auch macht. Und ich empfehle jedem das zu machen, weil da kannst du nämlich die Kanäle alle benutzen, ohne dass die sich auf den Fuß treten. Jedenfalls mit den normalen Standards, die wir jetzt haben.
Und vor allem strahlt das 5 Gigahertz halt nicht so weit und dann stört man die anderen noch weniger.
Ja, das ist ohnehin so ein Punkt. Viele Leute glauben ja, dass wenn sie ihre Sendestärke auf 100% drehen oder noch irgendwo eine fettere Antenne dran machen, so nach dem Motto, viel hilft viel.
Viel stört die anderen noch mehr.
Genau. Und vor allen Dingen, auch wenn du eine große Antenne dran machst, gerade bei diesen einzelnen Dingen, die nur eine Antenne haben, das ist nämlich auch die Empfangsantenne von dem Ding. Und wenn du eine große Empfangsantenne dran machst, dann empfängt die auch viel mehr Nachbarn. Was du ja nicht willst. Also eigentlich möchtest du deine Zelle so klein wie möglich halten. Also so groß wie nötig, aber so klein wie möglich. Und zwar in Empfang und Sendung. Dann hast du noch eine Chance. Diese Vielhilf, Vielnummer ist böse. Das geht nicht. So, das war der kurze Gastbeitrag zum Netzwerker.
Seitdem du mir eine SMS geschickt hast, empfange ich auch wieder SMS.
Hatst du da so einen Pfeil-Doppelpunkt-Slash-Slash-Bug noch und so?
Über SMS?
Ist der jetzt eigentlich schon gefixt gewesen?
Haben wir vorhin über das noch nicht vorhandene 10.8.3 geredet? Nee, aber auf dem iPhone gab's den nie.
Aber hat die doch auch irgendwas gefixt?
Auf dem iPhone gab's genug andere Probleme.
Da gab's nur so Exchange-Probleme.
Irgendwie mit dem Log-Screen, den man umgehen kann.
Den gibt's noch, genau. Der soll ja mit 6.1.3 irgendwie gefixt werden, aber gibt's ja auch noch nicht.
Apropos Kommunikationsprobleme. Twitter schaltet gerade seine alte API ab. Ich wollte das nochmal anprangern. Ja, der Niedergang des Netzwerks nimmt seinen Lauf. Twitter, Twitter?
Dieser Dienst, wo nur noch Max ist.
Genau.
Ich bin da auch noch.
Wer noch?
Und deine 50.000 Follower sind da bestimmt auch noch.
Ich hab keine 50.000 Follower.
Sondern mehr?
Nee, weniger.
Was, echt?
Weiß ich nicht. Demnächst vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Twitteren tust du doch trotzdem noch, gibst du.
Ja, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, jetzt so...
Das ist ein Abfallprodukt.
Mit Twitteren ist für mich jetzt mehr so ein Pflichtprogramm geworden.
Peak Twitter.
Also ich schick da das hin, was da zu sein hat, irgendwie. Aber ich schick da nicht mehr gern was. Weil das jetzt einfach in zunehmendem Maße einfach lebensfeindlich ist. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt schon das Tumbleweed irgendwie von links nach rechts durchlaufen sehe, aber macht halt einfach nicht mehr so einen Spaß.
Aber viel Zeug, was ähnlich ist. Ähnlich wie Tumbleweed.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings auch. Naja, aber jetzt mal zum technischen Hintergrund hat vielleicht auch nicht jeder mitbekommen. Es war schon vor einem halben Jahr angekündigt worden. Die neue API von Twitter, die ganz toll ist. Für Twitter, sonst aber allerdings für kaum irgendjemanden. Insbesondere nicht für Developer, denn viele haben sich mit dieser Ankündigung von der 11API schon ausgebotet gesehen. Und teilweise wurde ja dann auch die Entwicklung schon eingestellt. Warum? Weil halt unter anderem damit verbunden ist, also nicht direkt jetzt mit der API, sondern überhaupt mit den neuen Regeln, die sie verkündet haben, wo die API auch dazu gehörte. Dass, wenn man jetzt einen Client hat auf Twitter, dass der eben nach so und so viele User-Tokens, die verbraucht wurden, irgendwie dann nicht mehr weiter mitspielen darf. Ich glaube, was war das, 100.000 oder so? 100.000 User-Token?
Ja, zumindest meinten sie, dass man dann erst mal mit Twitter selber reden muss, damit man dann vielleicht auf mehr Tokens abgegradet wurde.
Das hat aber bisher nicht stattgefunden, sondern es ist jetzt vor ein paar Wochen so ein Android-Client irgendwie ins User-Token-Limit reingelaufen. Und seitdem haben sie irgendwie das Problem, dass sie jetzt irgendwie auf einem Playstore noch irgendwie sein müssen, damit sie irgendwie da noch ihre existierenden User gegebenenfalls noch mit Updates versorgen können, aber eigentlich nicht mehr gekauft werden wollen. Und deswegen erhöhen sie jetzt den Preis, um nicht mehr gekauft zu werden. Last time I checked war dann der Preis bei 134 Dollar und so für ein Twitter-Client für Android. Das kauft dann sozusagen kaum einer. Naja, so.
Ne, mal ganz ehrlich, hat denn der Android-Store das gleiche Problem wie eigentlich der Apple-App-Store, dass man da irgendwie nur mit großen Klimmzügen zwar Software reintun kann, aber dann irgendwie verhindern muss, dass die Leute es auch kaufen?
Ich kann mich da nicht kompetent so äußern. Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gibt es ja up.net und up.net ist sowieso viel toller, weil es einfach toller ist. Das muss man ja mal jetzt hier auch mal so sagen. Deswegen, ich habe mich schon lange überlegt. Also mir fällt jetzt überhaupt gar kein Feature ein, was Twitter hat, was bei up.net nicht schon längst drin wäre und auch gleich viel besser umgesetzt wurde.
Aber up.net hat keinen Justin Bieber.
Siehst du einen weiteren Vorteil von up.net? Das ist ja egal. Für mich ist das jetzt nicht so interessant, ob das Mainstream-Netzwerk überhaupt ist. Die Frage ist, ist es für mich nützlich? Kann ich da eine interessante Community erreichen? Und habe ich vor allem auch die Werkzeuge, die mir diese Kommunikation mit dieser Community auch leicht machen?
Aber noch ist die Community ja nicht bei ADN komplett, oder?
Fragt sich, was die Community ist. Tatsache ist, ich verwende vor allem auf dem Mac ein Echo-Phone. Für den Mac-Echo-Phone wurde im Rahmen der Ankündigung dieses User-Token-Limitierungen das Development eingestellt, schon vor Monaten. Das heißt, diese Software hat schon lange kein Update mehr erfahren, wird kein Update mehr erfahren. Das heißt, es hängt auf Twitter API 1.0 fest, wird nicht für Twitter API 1.1 angepasst. Eigentlich hatte ich jetzt damit gerechnet, dass zum Zeitpunkt dieser Sendung der Klein schon nicht mehr funktioniert. Bei mir funktioniert er komischerweise. Ich habe von anderen aber auch schon gehört, dass es nicht mehr so ist. Also es scheint irgendwie so ein regionale...
Chat sagte auch gerade jemand, das ginge alles noch.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen unklar. Aber ich habe auch schon gehört, dass es irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert. Es widerspricht sich gerade so ein bisschen. Aber eigentlich war die Ansage, 5. März schalten sie halt die API ab. Und damit wäre es halt dann das Ende für den Client.
Vielleicht gibt es noch keine neuen Tokens mehr oder so. Für Leute, die jetzt gerne einen Token hätten.
Nein, nein, sie redeten ja wirklich von Abschalten. Und nicht nur von nicht weiter zulassen oder kein Wachstum mehr ermöglichen.
Jaja gut, irgendjemand muss aufgefallen sein.
Die Grey Spirit war halt jetzt schon die letzten Monate.
Irgendjemand muss aufgefallen sein. Das ist nicht so ein guter strategischer Schachzug, wenn plötzlich alle Leute anfangen zu heulen, wie gemeint Twitter wäre. Und dass ADN doch viel besser ist.
Ich glaube, dass Twitter sich wegen ADN nicht groß am Arsch kratzt. Das geht bei denen total links rein, rechts raus.
Das ist eh alles old and busted.
Aber für ADN ist die Diskussion um Twitter natürlich Gold. Und ich glaube, dass dieser Zeitpunkt, den sie gewählt haben, um ihre freemium-Initiative zu starten, vielleicht auch etwas mit diesem 5. März-Termin zu tun hatte. Vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Habe ich nichts Konkretes zu gehört. Kurze Erläuterung, also Abdotnet, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, ist eine Social-Media-Plattform, nicht ein Social-Media-Network. Es ist eine Social-Media-Plattform, auf der man beliebige Networks implementieren kann, die eine common-User-Base hat und verschiedene APIs bereitstellt. Unter anderem eben so eine Twitter-like Public Timeline-API, aber eben auch eine sehr umfangreiche Private-Messaging-API. Vor ein paar Wochen haben sie dann auch noch eine File-API dazugelegt. Man kriegt mit seinem Account, den man sich bisher hat, für 3 Dollar im Monat kaufen müssen, auch noch 10 GB Storage in der app.net Cloud dazu. Das heißt, man hat da so ein bisschen Amazon-Style. So ein Bucket kann da irgendwie seine Files irgendwie hochladen. Und dann liegen die da und man kann sie halt per HTTP oder HTTPS erreichen.
Moment, wenn du jetzt so ein Fanboy-Asian bist, du bist ja auch mit denen so ein bisschen in Kontakt, die das da so machen. Haben die eigentlich überhaupt welche Infrastruktur in Europa? Oder ist das wieder alles Cloud, was auf irgendwelchen Amisurvern liegt?
Im Wesentlichen ist das so Cloud-Front und Amazon-Kram, was die benutzen.
Ja, aber Amazon kannst du ja hier und dort mieten. Weißt du, ob sie was in Irland gelaufen haben? Oder ist das alles schön billig in den US gehostet?
Ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung, wo sie sich da verteilen. Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, eh alles old and pastet.
Trotzdem, nochmal, das ist ja eine Plattform, auf der jetzt 1.000-3.000 Sachen Leute entwickeln sollen. Und File-ARP, sie heißt ja nicht Picture-ARP, sie heißt ja File-ARP. Da kannst du darauf warten, dass einem Leuten da mal einfällt, dass wir was anderes hinlegen als ein Picture. Und dann wäre es schon mal ganz gut, zumindest zu wissen oder mal, sie wollen ja alles mal richtig machen. Das ist ja der Anspruch von ADN, dass sie mal hingehen und sagen, wir machen jetzt nicht einfach nur Mushe-Bugu, irgendwie mal schnell was, sondern wir wollen es ja mal richtig machen. Und wenn man das richtig macht, dann gehört für Europäer, außer Schweden, das Stichwort Datenschutz. Und da würde ich zum Beispiel als Benutzer schon gerne wissen, wo meine Daten liegen. Also das ist ja auch nicht schwer.
Im Prinzip hast du natürlich recht. Aber so wie ich das sehe, sehe das vielleicht anders, ist es halt so, dass das app.net jetzt zumindest der, ich sag mal, der Twitter-ähnliche Teil des Dienstes ist halt ein öffentlicher Dienst. Und wenn ich jetzt meinen App.net-Client benutze und da ein Foto hochlade, weil ich ein Foto halt in meinem Stream haben will, dann liegt er natürlich in dem File Storage von der Cloud. Aber das ist ja ein öffentliches File in dem Sinne, weil ich habe es da ja hingeladen, damit die Leute das sehen können. Da ist mir der Datenschutz...
Es gibt aber noch mehr Daten. Du erinnerst dich daran, als jetzt gerade erst vor ein paar Wochen irgendwie die Regierung ja Twitter in Grund und Boden geklagt hat, ihnen die Zugangsdaten oder die Zugriffsdaten von irgendeinem dieser Aktivisten da, die hier zu Wikileaks zum Beispiel gehörten, rauszutun. Und da möchte ich gerne auch mal eine Ansage zu haben.
Das ist ja auf jeden Fall auch ein richtiger Wunsch.
Also es ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig dringend, aber jetzt einfach totzuschweigen, weil nach dem motiviert ja eh keinen. Aber das wäre mal eine Frage.
Aber auch nicht die bei Twitter, die, die halt eben genau die Daten nicht rausgerückt haben.
Sie haben lange nicht... Sie haben sich lange dagegen gestreckt. Das muss man ihnen noch zugutehalten. Aber am Ende des Tages ist natürlich immer eine Frage, wo liegt das, welcher Juristikation unterliegt das. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht irgendwie in Frage stellen. Ich möchte aber einfach mal wissen.
Ja, es wäre sehr interessant, mal dieses Thema aufzubringen. Das fällt übrigens derzeit noch relativ leicht. Also der Dalton Coldwell macht ja regelmäßig so einen Podcast, den UPDOTMAT-Podcast. Im Blog wird der rausgelassen und sammelt auch vorher mal Fragen ein. Und soweit ich bisher den Eindruck hatte...
Das kann man dem mal zuschmeißen....
beantwortet der auch das, wenn das sozusagen halbwegs sinnvolle Fragestellung ist.
Also sie könnten ja auch einfach nach Nordkorea gehen. Ja, das hat zwischendurch leider elementiert worden. Aber das wäre mal wirklich ein cooler Hack gewesen. So wie damals, ich weiß noch, bei der Wahl Obama gegen... was war das, Bush noch, deine Erste, als dann irgendwie wieder mit der Wahlauszählung das ein bisschen hibbelig war und so. Und wie war das, ich glaube, Kuba hat dann angeboten, schicken Wahlbeobachter und der Iran oder so. Also das ist so eine schöne Tollnummer jetzt. Aber okay, gut, lassen wir das. Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe jetzt schon zum dritten Mal gesagt, es ist eh alles old and busted, weil jetzt gibt es ja JOIN. ADN war gestern.
Nee, Moment, jetzt müssen wir erstmal diese ADN-Geschichte hier fertig diskutieren.
Aber das ist doch alt.
Ich bitte dich, ich komme jetzt nicht mit deinem Telekom-Kram. Nicht jetzt schon. Also, für die Leute, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, das sind sicherlich einige. Also Abdotnet hat angekündigt, dass sie jetzt auch Accounts ermöglichen, die kein Geld kosten bisher. Gab es nur, du kaufst dir ein Jahr, dann kostet dich der Monat drei Dollar. Du kaufst dir einen Monat, der kostet dich dann fünf Dollar. Oder du wirst über einen Invite-Code eingeladen, dann hast du einen Monat komplett frei mit All Features on. Und du läufst dann nach vier Wochen in die Bezahlwelt oder nicht. Das haben sie jetzt dahingehend geändert, dass die Invite-Codes jetzt auch für einen kostenlosen Account sorgen, aber eben jetzt für einen dauerhaft kostenlosen Account, der dafür aber wiederum Beschränkungen hat. Und das ist im Wesentlichen wohl auch Ihr Modell, mit der Sie Ihren Dienst jetzt weiterentwickeln wollen. Der kostenlose Account ist im Prinzip kann eigentlich alles, was auch der normale Account kann, mit der Einschränkung A, dass man maximal 40 anderen folgen kann. B, du nicht 10 GB Storage bekommst, sondern ich glaube nur ein halbes. Und die dritte Einschränkung war, glaube ich, dass die maximale Dateigröße auch noch irgendwie kleiner ist. Und das war's. Also relativ geringe und einfach zu verstehende Einschränkungen, die dir quasi die Funktionalität vollständig geben, bloß eben mit anderen Grenzen. Und was ich ganz interessant finde in dem Zusammenhang ist, also er meinte ja auch jetzt bei der Ankündigung, das hätten Sie von Anfang an vorgehabt. Das haben Sie nicht von Anfang an so kommuniziert, weil da wollten Sie sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt in die Karten schauen lassen. Allerdings hätte man schon selber drauf kommen können, da er schon immer so ein paar andere Dienste als Vorbild genannt hat, die ja eigentlich demselben Modell folgen. Vor allem natürlich GitHub und Dropbox. Dropbox ist im Prinzip auch kostenlos. GitHub eben auch unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Wenn du mehr haben willst, dann muss halt Geld fließen. Und Dropbox, wenn du mehr als zwei Gigabyte haben willst.
Ja, bzw. zehn, die du dir durch diverse Invitecodes und andere Maßnahmen zusammensammeln kannst.
Genau, also wenn du einfach viel mehr haben willst.
Was mich bei Dropbox ein bisschen nervt, ist, der kleinste Bezahltarif sind gleich 100 Gig, und das brauche ich einfach nicht. Aber mir sind dann irgendwie 10 Dollar im Monat doch auch ein bisschen zu viel. Also wenn es da irgendwie die Hälfte für die Hälfte gäbe, das fände ich irgendwie ganz schick, aber gibt es halt nicht.
Ja, da kann man natürlich jetzt lange darüber diskutieren. Die werden sich sicherlich schon ein paar Gedanken darüber gemacht haben. Das mag auch was damit zu tun haben, was so die average Usage ist. Und da liegen dann vielleicht viele noch, weiß ich nicht, in einem Bereich, keine Ahnung.
Die haben ihre Gründe und ich habe dann meine Gründe, es nicht zu klicken.
Ja, ich stimme dir zu. Ich muss aber auch sagen, ich bin mit kaum einem Dienst so glücklich wie mit Dropbox.
Ich finde das auch super. Ich brauche nur keine 100 Gig.
Nur mal ganz kurz, der Chat kotzt sich gerade wieder aus, weil der Stream zusammenbricht. Ich messe jetzt seit dem Hickup vorhin, messe ich die ganze Zeit. Wir haben keinerlei Probleme mit der Außenanbindung. Du könntest mir vielleicht mal privat über den Sound schmeißen, wo du hin-streamst. Oder wo dein Nice-Cast-Ziel ist, dass ich das mal trässe oder so. Weil unsere Außenanbindung ist topfit und nicht loaded. Die Schlaumeier, die da draußen glauben, wir lassen hier Torrens laufen, ist klar.
Ach so, Scheiße, soll ich mal ausmachen?
Jut, wollte ich zwischendurch noch mal sagen.
Ja, noch mal zu up.net. Also jetzt gibt es halt dieses Premium-Model, da kommt man aber nur rein, wenn man Invitecodes hat und Leute, die halt einen normalen Account haben, die kriegen halt welche. Ich habe auch noch ganz viele. Ihr seid ja schon alle bedient. Ne, denn es braucht noch einen, ne?
Ne, braucht nicht.
Doch, doch, du musst doch zu uns kommen.
Up.neten.
Ich habe noch Zeit. Also, erstmal muss ich das durchsetzen, ne? Dann gucken wir nochmal.
Das hat sich hier schon total durchgesetzt.
Das erinnert mich an die Frau, die den Gag nicht schon mal erzählt. Irgendwie auf meinem Dorf da oben, wo ich meinen Landsitz habe, die irgendwie Anfang des Jahres 2002 oder war auch schon im April oder sowas, wie im Supermarkt mit der Kassiererin redete und meinte ja, das mit dem Euro oder so, ne, sie macht das nicht, sie tauscht das nicht um, das setzt sich nicht durch.
Ja, ich habe schon einige Sachen ausgesetzt, die sich nicht durchgesetzt haben. Ich hätte auch Google Wave ausgesetzt, aber ich wurde ja genötigt hier. Daher bin ich mal herabgelassen, was ist? Fail.
Ja, das ist halt einfach der interessanteste Dienst jetzt.
Hast du denn wenigstens Ping ausgesetzt?
Klar.
Das war auch nicht so schwierig, das auszusetzen.
Ich habe sogar Siri ausgesetzt.
Den einen Nachmittag, wo Ping... Na egal.
Ich habe auch Facebook ausgesetzt, ich habe noch nie Facebook benutzt.
Facebook setzt sich auch aus, relativ erfolgreich bis jetzt.
Die setzt ganz schön viel aus, aber ich bin ja auch ein alter Sack, ich dachte es.
Gut, um jetzt nochmal hier den Sermon komplett gebracht zu haben, was bei Abdeutnet alles Interessantes Neues passiert ist. Diese freien Accounts haben natürlich auch noch Auswirkungen auf diese Sache mit dem Developer Incentive Program, weil ja da Developer bezahlt werden aus einem Fonds, der absolut...
Das heißt, da kommt jetzt gar keine Kohle rein, wenn alle für umsonst reinkommen, richtig?
In diesen Fonds.
Das heißt, die Developer haben wahrscheinlich das gar nicht so cool, oder doch?
Doch, die haben jetzt mehr im Pool. Die haben jetzt noch 10.000 Dollar mehr im Pool.
Ja, die haben jetzt sogar mehr Geld.
Sie haben den Pool vergrößert, aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dürfen die Free-Anwender zwar sagen, was sie gerne benutzen, aber nach den Free-Anwendern wird nicht der Pool aufgeteilt, sondern nur nach dem Bezahlten.
Ja, das ist ja auch richtig so, weil sonst hättest du das Problem, dass die Leute mit ihren Inventcodes sich Fake-Accounts machen, die dann irgendwie die eigene Software räten und all solche Geschichten. Und das finde ich auch völlig in Ordnung. Also das haben sie so auch klar kommuniziert, das wird so nicht stattfinden, aber sie befragen trotzdem alle, um einfach auch so die Zufriedenheit einfach mal zu monitoren. Um ein Gefühl dafür zu haben, was die Leute mögen, was die Leute nicht mögen und was sie nutzen und nicht. Außerdem haben sie so ein bisschen die Rahmenbedingungen geändert. Also diese Gewichtung, die dort vorgenommen wird, die ist eben jetzt auch danach ausgerichtet, inwieweit die Clients auch alle APIs nutzen. Also so ein Client, der nur einen API-Teil nutzt, also der jetzt nur so Public Timeline macht, steht erst mal nicht so gut da wie einer, der eben auch File-AP-Aktivität und Private-Message-Kram macht. Dieses Private-Messaging, das muss man uns noch mal darlegen, weil viele Leute nehmen ja uptitle.net wahr, als ja, ist ja ein Twitter-Klon. Das kann man insofern sagen, als dass natürlich diese Idee der Diskussionstimeline im Prinzip identisch ist. Und dass sie sich eben ein paar Stellen eigentlich nur geringfügig unterscheidet. Du hast halt 256 Zeichen statt 140. Wobei ich sagen muss, könnt ihr irgendwie noch richtig twitten?
Ich benutze mal diese Doppelsende-Funktion jetzt, wo du sozusagen in deinem Uptitle.net-Klient sagst, twittert das mal auch noch, und wenn das dann länger ist, dann macht er in den Tweet einen Link rein auf...
Den Uptitle-Post, so wie twitlonger sozusagen. Ja, naja, gut, ich bin ja da eher für Netzwerke gehen, aber das soll mal jeder so machen, wie er will. Die andere interessante Eigenschaft ist, dass dieses Private-Messaging halt jetzt auch da voll da ist, und das muss man sagen, das ist jetzt wirklich viel, viel toller als bei Twitter. Aber bei Twitter, das Einzige, was du halt machen kannst, ist, du kannst einer anderen Person eine private Nachricht schicken, wenn sie dir folgt.
Das ist bei ADN anders?
Ja, das ist bei ADN anders. Bei ADN kann jeder in seinem eigenen Setup, kann euch das hier gerne auch mal zeigen, wenn man da auf seine Profilseite geht, kann man das nämlich alles einstellen. Da kannst du für die Message-Geschichte auswählen, wer darf mir Nachrichten schicken. Und bei Default ist es halt Everyone. Also ich kann derzeit, das ist bei mir auch so eingestellt, also mir kann jeder App.NET-User Nachrichten schicken. Ich lasse das jetzt erstmal so, um einfach mal zu gucken, was Sache ist.
Wann der erste Spam reinrauscht.
Aber wenn das jetzt irgendwie überhandnimmt und ich da keinen Bock drauf habe, dann könnte ich das eben auf Users I Follow and Users Following Me reduzieren. Also mir darf dann keiner was schicken, der mir nicht auch folgt und dem ich auch folge. Oder man kann es ein bisschen lockerer machen mit Users I Follow, also genauso wie bei Twitter. Also es gibt sozusagen zusätzlich zu Twitter der Art und Weise wie Twitter, das macht noch drei andere Einstellungen, nämlich alle, keiner oder bidirektionale Beziehungen.
Okay, das ist aber jetzt nicht das Feature, wobei ich jetzt zwei Stunden diskutieren möchte.
Nein, ich sage ja nur, was anders ist.
Kann ich denn jetzt mal Direct-Messages... Ah, das wäre meine Frage gewesen.
Ja, natürlich, du kannst mit mehreren Leuten kommunizieren. Und damit hast du...
Group-Chat.
Group-Chat permanent. Das ist sozusagen auch eine Information, die der Client so einfach aufnehmen kann. Also der sieht, dass da so eine Gruppenkommunikation vorliegt und zeigt sie dir dann einfach an. Du wechselst deinen Client. Und der Client ist in der Lage festzustellen, dass du da gerade eine Kommunikation mit ein Leuten hast. Und die ist halt eröffnet. Und solange du die nicht komplett dicht machst, bleibt die dann eben auch da und ist unter allen Clients verfügbar. Und natürlich hast du für die Nachrichten auch ein Red-Unread-Status. Also anders als bei Twitter, wo du einen neuen Client aufmachst und dann erstmal alle deine Nachrichten wieder als da ist was Neues markiert bekommen hast, hast du hier serverseitig eben so richtig dieses hast du gelesen, hast du nicht gelesen. Also es ist sehr viel näher dran an E-Mail, Instant Messaging etc. als das jetzt bei Twitter der Fall wäre. Also es wird dann schon auch so ein bisschen eher so wie Skype auch, so von den Fähigkeiten her. Das finde ich zum Beispiel eine sehr schöne Sache. Dazu kommt ja noch, dass es dann dieses Petter gibt. Das ist so von einem Developer, Jonathan Dürig, auf up.net entworfenes Prinzip des Chats. Das ist quasi Irg für up.net. Also funktioniert nicht jetzt genauso wie Irg, aber es ist halt einfach Chat-Räume, die du definieren kannst. Und es gibt unter petterup.net dann entsprechendes Web-Interface dazu, was auch gleich mit deinen privaten Nachrichten auch noch migriert, weil das ja quasi alles auf derselben API basiert. Und da kannst du dann halt so offene Räume aufrufen und denen joinen oder eben auch deine eigenen aufmachen. Und es gibt auch jetzt schon so Clients wie zum Beispiel Happy auf dem iPhone, auf iOS, die eben diese Petaräume auch gleich erkennen. Und dann hast du sozusagen auch noch deine Chat-Kanäle auch noch gleich mit da drin. Das ist irgendwie alles erst noch der Anfang, aber da passiert irgendwie jetzt schon eine ganze Menge. So, ich bin gerade so schnell gewesen hier gerade alles, aber so, und da gibt es irgendwie alles Mögliche, wo du darüber irgendwie diskutieren kannst. Und es ist halt immer dieselben Usernamen, alles dieselben Einstellungen, alles ist irgendwie retrievable. Das ist schon wirklich nett. Ja, man könnte jetzt noch viel mehr erzählen. Will ich aber jetzt gar nicht nur noch eine einzige Sache, was sie jetzt schon angekündigt haben, und das ist die erste API, die sie jetzt angekündigt haben, bevor sie sie releasen, und sie releasen eigentlich am laufenden Meter irgendwas, ist eine Billing-API. Das heißt, es wird auch noch kaufen und verkaufen irgendwie Teil werden, wie das aussieht, keine Ahnung. Aber da wird es dann halt schon spannend, weil sie ja im Prinzip hier auch die Chance haben, einerseits so ähnlich wie beim Upstore mit so In-Up-Purchases und so was zu kommen, Subscription-Payment etc. Das könnte natürlich bestimmter Software auch nochmal ganz andere Bezahlmodelle ermöglichen. Und wo ich so ein bisschen drauf hoffe, ist halt ein cooles Micropayment-Modell.
Vielleicht mit und zusammen gegen Flatter?
Ja, inwieweit Flatter da irgendwie eine Chance hat, hier überhaupt mitzumischen, ist mir noch nicht so klar. Also so richtig einfach ist es nicht für die, weil die eigentlich, jeder der irgendwie erkennt, dass Flatter eine tolle Idee ist, und eine Plattform, die für Geld ist, will das eigentlich irgendwie selber machen. Und das ist auch immer noch so ein bisschen meine Vermutung, dass das ja bei Apple vielleicht auch eine Rolle spielen könnte. Irgendwann wird dieses Micropayment seinen Durchbruch kriegen. Aber ich weiß noch nicht, durch wen. So, das war mein Update zu up.net. Wer hier im Chat noch Accounts haben will, kann ja gleich mal ein paar Invites fallen lassen.
Ja.
Wollen wir mal hier die Zukunft ins Auge fassen? Oder wollen wir uns über die Fritzbox unterhalten?
Fritzbox unterhalten?
Zukunft.
Wenn du schon mal Fritzbox sagst, dann habe ich meine Frage. Gibt es so eine Kiste, die man bei einem Kabelprovider anstöpseln kann, wo hinten ein S0-Bus rauskommt, wo ich alte ESDN-Telefone anschließen kann?
Eine Fritzbox. Eine Fritzbox, die hat einen Voice-over-IP-Tralala drin, was du für die Kabel-Meteile brauchst, weil es ja kein analoges oder ESDN-Signal auf deinem Coax da drauf. Die rückt das nach hinten raus entweder als zwei analoge Anschlüsse, die du dann irgendwie je nach Rufnummer und so überlegen kannst, oder halt als S0 oder dann wieder dein...
Und gemischt kann ich das auch machen?
Kannst du der S0-Anschluss, wie gesagt, auch bloß einer von N internen Anschlüssen. Diese Fritz-Boxen haben ja teilweise auch eine Deck-Basis-Station gleich mit drin.
Was ist denn das für eine Fritz-Box? Wie heißt denn die dann?
Das ist 68er-Serie. Für Kabelanschlüsse gibt es ja auch 6840, diese LTE. Also 6830 und so was heißen die. Du musst aber dazu sagen, du kannst nicht immer, das ist anders als bei dem DSL, du kannst nicht notwendigerweise das Gerät, das dir dein Kabelanbieter hintut, wo das Internet rauspurzelt, kannst du nicht nach Belieben einfach austauschen. Jedenfalls nicht der Teil, der am Coax-Kabel dransteckt. Das ginge zwar technisch, weil es technisch standardisiert ist, aber da gibt es eine Authentication und la-la Pipapo und Provisionsdaten, die gerade die Kabelprovider in der Regel nie rausrücken. Jedenfalls habe ich noch nicht davon gehört, dass das einer in Deutschland tut. Aber was du machen kannst, ist, so eine Fritzbox kannst du auch auf eBay schießen, dann kannst du auch eine Nicht-Kabel-Fritzbox nehmen, weil der kannst du auch sagen, pass mal auf, das mit dem Internet, das habe ich schon gelöst. Wie hast du ein Internet, da kommt Internet raus. Mach mal bitte deinen ganzen Voice-over-IP-Voodoo oder was du sonst so machst, so als Fritzbox, was du ganz gut kannst, oder VPN oder einen anderen, tralala. Aber das mit dem Internet, das machst du diesmal nicht. Also schalte deinen DSL-Modem aus, oder was auch immer du da drin hast, und nimm mal bitte jetzt das Internet, was ich dir per LAN in die erste Buchse reinstecke. Und dann kannst du sie sozusagen wieder konfigurieren, als wenn sie selber das Internet als Router machen würde, und dann kannst du die ganzen Voice-Spielchen damit machen.
Und du kannst dir dann auch konfigurieren, dass sie das Voice so macht, wie sie es machen soll, mit dem Voice, was der Anbieter dann anbietet?
Theoretisch ja. Praktisch scheitert das daran sehr häufig, dass der Anbieter die Zugangsdaten nicht sagt. Die kannst du dir natürlich wieder raushacken. Es gibt sehr viele Leute, es gibt noch diverse...
Wozu haben wir gleich noch diese RECTP?
Ja, damit sie dir... Nee, pass auf, die hat folgende Aufgabe. Normalerweise würdest du dich jetzt als Kunde bei deinem Provider beschweren und den ganz fürchterlich beschimpfen. Und da die das nicht möchten, haben sie das jetzt an die RECTP ausgelagert. Das heißt, die RECTP schickt dir jetzt mit einem Bundesadler auf dem Briefpapier, dass das alles so richtig so ist. Also das war ja normalerweise von den Hotlines, von den Telekom-Hotlines, dass das alles schon so richtig so ist und du sollst dich ja nicht anfassen. Das nervt die Leute jetzt, deswegen rufen sie bei der RECTP an, deswegen schreibt die RECTP das jetzt. Und sagt, das ist schon alles ganz richtig so. Wir können da leider nichts machen. Es gibt natürlich da Möglichkeiten. Es gibt sehr viele Leute, die haben diese Kabelmodems aufgehackt oder diese CPEs und da die Konfigurationsdaten rausgenuckelt. Das kannst du dann natürlich machen. Also rein technisch gesehen, wenn du die ganzen Daten hast, kannst du das bauen. Aber die Problematik besteht daran, dass du diese Daten nicht immer kriegst oder du sie erst erhacken musst.
Oder mitsniffen.
Oder mitsniffen, was gerade auf dem Kabelanschluss besonders knifflig wird, aber nicht unmöglich. Apropos miffen, nur so nebenbei, wo wir gerade über Fritzboxen reden. Kurze Ansage, ich habe jetzt hier gerade keinen Chat. Aber wer das wissen will, kann es ja trotzdem in die Kommentare schreiben. Man kann auf Fritzboxen sehr schön den Verkehr mitschneiden, was wirklich mal sehr lustig ist. Man möchte gerne den internen Verkehr oder gerade eben alles, was ins Internet geht, mitschneiden. Und da kommt dann ein Feilchen dabei raus, das ist ein PCAP-File, das kannst du in einen Wireshark reinladen und dann kannst du mal gucken, was eigentlich nach draußen alles gesprochen wird. Da kannst du auch gucken, wie das NAT funktioniert oder ob es nicht funktioniert. Oder wer sonst auf deinem Netzwerk alles rumsurft. Also wer jetzt gerne mal den Internetverkehr seiner Freundin gerne mitschneiden möchte, was er nicht darf, aber möchte, kann mal gucken, wie gesagt, das gibt auf der Fritzbox eine mehr oder weniger versteckte Funktion, wo man diese PCAP-Files erzeugen kann mit dem ganzen Verkehr, der da rein und raus geht. Wo man dann teilweise auch gucken kann, mit was sich denn so für eine Software Wo anmeldet, mit Watfell-Username und Passwörter.
Diese Kabelmodemvarianten heißen nur 6330 und 6340. Das sind komischerweise aber so bei den Versendern nicht so zu kriegen.
Ja, weil du sie eh nicht selber provisionieren kannst.
Das heißt, die sind sozusagen nur Modelle, die du dann vom Provider gestellt bekommst. Aber da musst du dann Glück haben, dass du eine kriegst.
Ja, manche Provider sind nett. Da kann man das ansagen. Ich hätte gern was ordentliches. Schicken sie mir nicht so einen Ching-Chang-Chong-Modem, sondern eine Fritz-Box. Ja klar, wenn sie einen 240-Monats-Vertrag unterschreiben, schicken wir ihnen eine Fritz-Box oder so. Da gibt es dann solche Deals. Aber gerade weil du diese Dinge in der Regel nicht selber provisionieren kannst, weil du die Zugangsdaten nicht hast, die du noch brauchst, werden gerade diese Dinge nur über die Provider vertickt.
Ja, das heißt, Kabel will man sowieso nicht haben.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, ein Kollege von mir, der ist jetzt umgezogen und in dem Haus, wo er jetzt wohnt, gibt es halt irgendwie keine Telefonanschlüsse mehr.
Ja, bitte?
Ja, das wurde neu gebaut, es gibt keine DSL-Kapazität, Telefonanschlüsse ist nicht, alles, was wir machen können, ist halt Kabel. Kabel Deutschland und die anderen Tele-Columbus, die verkaufen auch ganz fröhlich ihre Anschlüsse, aber Telefone-Provider...
Also da würde ich jetzt mal, ich lehne mich jetzt mal aus dem Fenster und sag mal, da ist ein finsterer Deal am Gehen, zwischen den Kabel-Fuzzis und dem Hausbesitzer und der Hausverwaltung. Weil das ist, das halte ich für ein unglaublich unrealistisches Szenario. Und da wird wieder mal das gespielt, wir erzählen das mal den Leuten und 99% der Leute glauben das einfach oder beißen in ihren Apfel. Weil übrigens bei mir auch so, in der letzten Wohnung, die ich damals hatte, kam auch der Hausvermeter gleich an und sagte, wir haben hier toll Kabel Deutschland im Haus, nehmen Sie Kabel Deutschland. Ich sag, nee Kabel stinkt aus, dem hab ich keinen Fernseher, brauch ich nicht. Ja, nehmen Sie doch viel besseres Internet. Da hab ich schon den Neuen gemerkt, meine, du hast damit gar keine Ahnung. Du bist ein büseliger Hausbesitzer, ein alter Banker oder sonst irgendwas. Und der will mir was erzählen, was hier gut das Internet ist. Der ist echt gut bearbeitet worden. Der hat irgendwie mal eine schöne Einladung gekriegt für eine Veranstaltung von Kabel Deutschland, den haben sie richtig gut zugetextet. Und nochmal, ich lehne mich da jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Fenster, aber ich würde jetzt wirklich ernsthaft mal sagen, ich halte das für sehr, sehr gewagt. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es hier Leute gibt, die heutzutage noch in Deutschland ein Haus bauen oder überhaupt ein Haus bauen dürfen, wo keine normalen Kupferdoppeladern drin geht in die Wohnung. Das kann mir keiner erzählen.
Mit den Details bin ich nicht so ganz vertraut, aber es ist wohl so, dass er...
Nee, das erzählen Sie ihm. Ich glaube echt nicht, dass das so ist, aber das erzählen Sie ihm.
Er hat es bei O2 versucht.
Hast du mal bei O2 geklickt, ob DSL für dich zur Verfügung steht?
Also kannst du doch locker klicken, oder?
Hat er irgendwie gemacht und da ging nichts. Wie ich.
Du kannst doch die Adresse da eintippen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo der wohnt.
Und dann klickst du bitte zuerst bei der Telekom. Weil es ist durchaus so, dass viele Provider, die gerade die letzte Meile von der Telekom einsammeln, die machen die selbe Anfrage und die Telekom sagt ihnen, pff, nee, geht nicht, und wenn du die selbe Anfrage bei der Telekom machst, dann kriegst du einen, na klar, können Sie hier einen Anschluss haben. Und wenn selbst die Telekom sagt, hier können wir Ihnen keinen Privatkunden-DSL legen, dann machst du die selbe Anfrage nochmal als Businesskunde und dann kriegst du eine Zusage. Aber holla. Also, wie gesagt, ich halte das für sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass jemand heutzutage ein Haus baut, der sowas macht. Da sind wir uns bei dem Thema der Fusion mal kurz angeschnitten hatten. Hat ja hier auch noch ein Thema, nämlich mit zwei Dosen in der Wohnung. Ein Kollege von mir hat auch einen VDSL-Anschluss. Ihr habt einen VDSL 50, aus dem nur knapp so 24 Megabit rauskullerten. Der hat den rausgefunden, weil es nämlich auch ein Neubau war, dass jemand sich dachte, aber wir sind besonders schlau. Wir ziehen, wir legen in jede Zimmer von so einer Wohnung, legen wir eine Telefondose rein. Und damit später der Telekom man nicht nochmal extra kommen muss, und man knüppern muss, knüppern wir die alle zusammen. Das heißt, er hat sozusagen in allen vier Zimmern, plus Bad und Flur und Tralala, hat er sich eine DSL-Antenne gebaut. Hat er sich nicht gebaut, sondern hat der Vermieter im gebaut. Und dann ist er hingegangen. Er hat nicht darauf gewartet, dass ein Telekom man kam, sondern hat sich selber die Zange gegriffen und hat sozusagen die ganzen Dinge alle abgeknipst, außer die Dose, die er wirklich im Betrieb hat, und wupp, hat er 48 Megabit. Also er hat sozusagen, oder 46 oder so, also fast seine Bandbreite nochmal dadurch verdoppelt, dadurch, dass er diese VDSL-Antenne, wie du so gerade sagtest, mal mit einem Nagelknips zurecht gestutzt hat. Also wer in Neubauwohnungen wohnt, wo mehrere Telefondosen sind und da ein DSL betreibt und damit vielleicht Sorgen hat oder Bandbreiten sorgen oder sowas, kann da mal nachgucken. Notfalls hier nochmal in den Kommentaren nochmal nachfragen oder mich nochmal ansprechen per Mail, dann kann man dazu vielleicht noch mal mehrmals sagen. Ja, haben wir jetzt auch erwähnt. Sollen wir gerade dabei bleiben, bei mehreren DSL-Leitungen?
Ja, das wollte ich auch gerade mal anregen, weil das war ja auch noch so eine Anfrage, die reinkam. Landproblematik, Netz ist langsam, warum nicht einfach gleich mehrere DSL-Leitungen bestellen? Wenn man sich mehrere 16er oder 3er, 4er oder was man gerade so runtergekratzt bekommt.
Ein 16er Gebe wäre ja schon fast ok.
Ja, für manche ist das sicherlich eine Option, eher mal 200 Euro im Monat zu bezahlen, als da kein Netz zu haben. Wenn du da irgendwie selbstständig bist und so ein bisschen von der Pampa aus arbeitest, dann kannst du dir das einfach nicht erlauben, bei bestimmten Dingen nicht dran zu bleiben. Die Frage ist, wie gut performt sowas, da über mehrere DSL-Anschlüsse hinweg Netz zu machen?
Wie kann man es machen? Wie kann man es überhaupt machen?
Tunneln muss man dann, oder?
Ja, nein, ja, ja. Du machst jetzt leider eine größere Kiste auf, die möchte ich jetzt auch nicht allzu sehr ausdehnen. Wir haben ja noch ein paar Sendungen dieses Jahr. Aber ich will mal kurz die Themen anschneiden, vielleicht greifen wir die dann mal einzeln auf. Also es gibt einerseits Möglichkeiten, wie der Anbieter selber diese Thema sich annehmen kann. Die sind zwar schön, die kann ich auch mal kurz erwähnen. Da ist allerdings angesichts der Investitionsdämlichkeit und der Dummheit der hiesigen Provider hier in diesem Land denke ich mal zunächst nicht mitzurechnen. Außer mit einer Technik vielleicht, da hat jetzt die Telekom gerade vor ein paar Wochen so ein bisschen Brimborium gemacht in der Presse auch, nämlich dieses sogenannte Vectoring. Das war deswegen in der Presse, weil die Vectoring-Technik, da kann ich gleich mal kurz drauf eingehen, was das macht, bedingt, dass kein anderer Provider mehr drauf sitzt. Und zwar nicht auf deinem Anschluss, sondern auf dem ganzen Kabelbündel. Das heißt, was sie jetzt mühsam politisch erstritten haben, dass jetzt auch andere Provider an den KV gehen können und mal Kupferdoppeladern belegen können mit ihrem eigenen DSL-Signal oder auch im HVT, also in der Vermittlungsstelle, das stellt die Telekom gerade wieder in Frage, weil sie sagt, ja, wenn wir jetzt den Standort Deutschland hier ordentlich mal mit DSL versorgen wollen, dann müssen wir Vectoring benutzen und wenn wir Vectoring benutzen, dann können leider keine anderen Leute mehr in weit und breit das Kabel benutzen. Vectoring funktioniert vom Prinzip so und die Idee ist an sich genial, dass man damit eins der größten Probleme, was man im DSL-Bereich hat, nämlich das sogenannte Übersprechen, das heißt, also wenn auf der Straße in dem fetten Kabel, wo halt mal so 100, 200 Doppeladern drin sind, da ist natürlich mehr als ein DSL-Signal drauf. Und dass sozusagen das ein DSL-Signal, das andere stört, was da drauf ist. Das ist vornehmlich auch eine Einschränkung der Reichweite. Bei DSL-Geschwindigkeit ist ja immer eine Frage von Technik, Dämpfung, Reichweite und so aus einem Dreieck, was sich daraus bildet. Und bei Wegbringen macht man einfach folgendes, wenn man sagt, alle Kupferadern, die da an der Straße liegen, gehören nur einem Anbieter und die stecken nur auf einem DSLAM von dem einen Anbieter. Denn weiß er ja, was er auf dem A dann ein paar A sendet und was er auf dem paar B senden will. Und er kann sozusagen, kann man sich vorstellen, wie so ein Noise-Cancellation-Kopfhörer, den man so kennt, so für Flugzeugzeugs hören. Oder ein Büro. Ich sage es jetzt mal ganz in layman's terms, wie sagt man so schön, so vereinfacht dargestellt. Wenn ich jetzt auf A ein Signal sende und ich weiß, das B-Kabel liegt daneben, dann kann ich gleich sozusagen auf das A-Signal minus B drauf geben. Also ein Gegensignal, was sozusagen das, was ich gleichzeitig auf B-Auslände wieder rausrechnet. Und damit schafft man es halt eben auch wieder, höhere Reichweiten hinzukriegen, bzw. bei kürzeren Reichweiten wieder höhere Bandbreiten. Aber dazu muss ich halt eben wissen, ich muss wissen, was ist alles auf dem Kabel drauf. Dazu muss sozusagen alles, was auf dem Kabel drauf ist, mir gehören. Mir als Provider. Das ist Vectoring.
Und du wirst es ja nicht nur mit Kanal B machen, sondern C, D, E, F. Also alle andere Kanäle werden irgendwie von deinem Sendendings irgendwie...
Du kriegst ja Kompensationssignal dafür.
Was denkst du, wie das jetzt politisch ausgeht? Der Anspruch, wir müssen jetzt die Meister über die Kabel sein versus wir haben hier eine offene Landschaft, wo auch andere Leute die Kabel benutzen dürfen.
Das klingt nach einem Versuch, die anderen wieder vom Kabel zu kriegen.
Ja, ich meine, ganz doof sind sie nicht. Sie sagen dann natürlich auch, die anderen dürfen dann natürlich auch unseren Dienst mitkaufen. Das heißt, der Telekom sagt natürlich...
Die weckt dann für alle und...
Ne, ne, ne, die weckt dann nicht. Sie betreiben die ganze Technik und sagen, aber ja, natürlich darf der LSO2, Acor, Vodafone sich jetzt wieder die Leitung bieten zum Kunden. Allerdings eben nicht das nackte Kupfer, sondern unseren Bitstream-Access oder sonst was. Aber sie wollen halt die Hoheit über das Kabel dadurch wieder erlangen.
In gewisser Hinsicht würde ich das sogar auch für wünschenswert halten, wenn es vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Telekom wäre, sondern der deutsche Datennetz. Wie heißt das denn bei der Bahn?
Wie eine Bundesautobahn. Aber dann sind wir wieder dabei, dass wir sagen, es wäre sinnvoll, solche Infrastruktur wie auch Gas, Wasser, Strom wieder in die öffentliche Hand zu geben.
Ja, das ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Essenzielle Infrastruktur.
Muss einfach der Gemeinschaft gehören. Und das wäre in gewisser Hinsicht fordern wir jetzt die Kommunalisierung der Telekom.
Du hast übrigens recht, was so angeht. Telekom, die haben auch Vor- und Nachteile. Aber ich habe vorhin gerade noch losgetweetet, als ich auf dem Weg hierher war, bin ich aus der Tür gegangen. Ich habe direkt vor der Tür so einen KV zu stehen, mit Outdoor-D-Slam drin. Der war offen, da saß ein Telekom-Maker vor, der das Ding gerade voll fluchte. Den habe ich dann mal so juvial angemacht, was er dann gerade tun würde. Und er begann seinen Satz oder seine Plauderei, und dann mit mir, er macht das ja sonst nicht. Da war mir schon klar, also jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob inzwischen meine Leitung zu Hause wieder geht. Na ja, er hat ja sonst mit diesen Dingen nichts zu tun. Das heißt, sie haben da wieder hingeschickt an einen Outdoor-D-Slam, dem sie gesagt haben, ja, da ziehst du mal an den Kabel, und da steckst du mal, das passt schon. Du musst ja nicht wissen, was da drin passiert. Das hat mir echt wieder Vertrauen gegeben.
Die fährt man noch?
Weiß ich nicht, ich war ja nicht da. Ich müsste jetzt mal pingen, oder mal gucken ins Lokfall, ob da zwischendurch ein Ausfall war. Ja, also das ist Vectoring. Der zweite ist Bonding. Wobei es dazu wieder gewagte Aussagen gibt von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Bist du noch am Monitoren? Ich bin noch am Monitoren.
Wir haben keinerlei API-Störungen. Sowohl V4 als V6 laufen die ganze Zeit los ohne Packet Loss. Auch bis zu deinem Stream-Server. Also wir haben jedenfalls kein IP-Problem dorthin. Wir haben vielleicht ein Higher-Level-Problem oder zu viele User auf dem Server oder frag mich was. Aber ich gucke, wie gesagt, ich monitor, wir haben seitdem ich das monitor. Ne, warte mal, ich kann ja mal gucken, wie viel Prozent Packet Loss haben wir. 0,1 Prozent Packet Loss auf dem V6. Das sind vier Pakete gewesen in der letzten Stunde.
Ja, man kriegt hier irgendwie, das gar nicht resolvt. 0 Prozent Packet Loss.
Ah, die Frage ist, warum macht ihr überhaupt Verbindungen offen, oder welche hast du? Ja, kann den aber resolven, kann den noch pingen. Hat aber länger gedauert als sonst. Aber das ist mal ein guter Hinweis. Also wir hatten kein IP-Konnektivitätsproblem, wir hatten vielleicht zwischendurch ein DNS-Problem. Muss ich jetzt mal mit dem Erwachungsskript gleich mal umschreiben, dass ich sozusagen immer wieder neue DNS-Abfragen mache, periodisch, und gucken, wann uns der Name wegfällt.
Ja, aber die Frage ist, warum...
Warum bricht der überhaupt ab, ja. Wie gesagt, aber auf IP-Ebene sind wir hergrün.
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich zu der Frage, wie man mehrere DSL-Bündelkarten noch gar nicht gekauft hat?
Nee, da waren wir noch nicht. Weil wir sind erst mal bei weiter und schneller und höher.
Genau, das ist ja diese ganze Vektor-Geschichte. Das ist aber noch Zukunftsmusik.
Nee, das gibt es schon. Ja, aber das gibt es halt noch nicht in Deutschland, weil das macht jemand nur, wenn die ganzen Kabel gehören. Und da sind die Einzelnen, die nach vorne gegangen sind, und haben gesagt, wir wollen das gerne mal machen. Lieber Rektepie, erlaubt uns das mal. Das ist halt eben noch so ein bisschen... Du kannst damit noch mal schneller... Du kannst auf jeden Fall schon mal weitergehen. Und wenn du weitergehen kannst, kannst du mehr Leute erreichen. Und für die Leute, die dich da dran sind, hast du auch eine bessere Störgeschichte. Sie sagen immer, dass man damit doch 100 Megabit fahren kann. Die kannst du auch so fahren. Du bist ja auch dran ziemlich dicht bei dir. Der Ziel wäre dann sozusagen 100 Megabit für jedermann über eine Kupferdoppelader. Und nicht nur für die Leute, die direkt neben dem KV wohnen. Für die anderen Leute, die überhaupt ein Problem haben, überhaupt was zu kriegen, es gibt jetzt diese Möglichkeit des sogenannten Bondings. Und da muss man jetzt unterscheiden. Bonding heißt, man benutzt einfach mehr als eine Leitung. Oder, ja, sag ich jetzt mal, Leitung. Nicht Kabel oder Ader, sondern Leitung. Da ist jetzt die Frage, was kann man tun? Es gibt technische Standards, die es dir erlauben, als DSL-Provider mehr als ein Adernpaar zu benutzen. Die gibt es auch schon länger. Da gibt es dann auch noch so lustige Techniken, die sogenannten Phantom-Mode. Sie legen dir zwei Leitungen, aber sie bilden damit drei Kanäle ab. Wenn du eine Leitung als einen Übertragungskanal siehst, hast du bei zwei Leitungen logischerweise erst mal zwei Übertragungskanäle. Um diesen Phantom-Mode erzeugen sie ein Differenzsignal zwischen der Leitung 1 und der Leitung 2 und bilden sich damit sogar noch einen dritten Übertragungskanal. Das heißt, du kriegst mit zwei Leitungen nicht die doppelte Kapazität hin, sondern die zweieinhalbfache oder vielleicht sogar die dreifache Kapazität. Manchmal bräuchte ich ja wirklich wieder. Ich starre jetzt gerade so in Tims Augen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob er gerade Core-dumpt oder ob er jetzt abmiss.
Das kriege ich schon nachvollzogen, aber das war jetzt nicht die eigentliche Frage. Die eigentliche Frage war ja, kann ich mir einfach zwei DSL-Verträge klicken, wenn die da alle bockig und nicht kooperativ sind?
Moment, ich weiß jetzt bei den Technikstandards.
Zu diesem Phantom nochmal. Eine Leitung ist für dich eine gedrillte Doppelader, zwei Leitungen sind zwei gedrillte Doppelader. Aber dann müsstest du doch eigentlich... Na ja, okay, du machst ein Differenzsignal zwischen den beiden Adern haben.
Genau. Da machen sie sozusagen den Phantom, das ist der Phantom Mode, da machen sie sozusagen nochmal den dritten Kanal hin. Gut, das ist das, was der Standard hergibt. Diese ganzen Techniken basieren aber alle darauf, dass sozusagen Endgerät bei dir und DSLAM alle aus einer Hand kommen, irgendwie kooperieren, miteinander zusammengehören. Auch da wüsste ich jetzt keinen, der das anbietet, weil du brauchst einen DSLAM, der das kann. Und mir wäre nicht bekannt, dass jemand in Deutschland auf der Straße schon solche DSLAMs hat, wo man sowas machen könnte. Was bleibt dem Benutzer? Dem Benutzer bleibt selber sozusagen ein Multilink-Geschichte zu machen. Das heißt also, sich selber, wie du gerade eben sagtest, zwei DSL-Anschlüsse zu klicken. Im Idealfall vielleicht sogar zwei DSL-Anschlüsse von unterschiedlichen Anbietern. Also, dass du dir einen O2-VDSL klickst und einen Telekom-VDSL, in der Hoffnung, dass in Friedenszeiten beide laufen. Du also dann sozusagen 100 Megabit hast und in Störungszeiten halt eben dir einer wegfällt und du ihn immer noch die 50 hast. Das ist sozusagen die Ideallösung.
Ja, aber das geht natürlich davon aus, dass sie nicht beide über den gleichen DSLAM laufen.
Klar, wenn das eine bloß gemietet ist von dem anderen, logisch.
Wenn der Laster zurücksetzt und den DSLAM plattmacht, dann ist egal.
Also es gibt doch nicht nur Ausfallsicherheit, sondern auch um doppelte Bandbreite, oder?
Ja klar, aber ich sag mal, im Idealfall möchtest du gerne beide haben. Du möchtest mehr Performance haben oder möchtest die Rede und Tanz haben? So etwas kannst du dir wirklich nur selber bauen, weil es gibt ja keinerlei Kooperation auf den höheren Bit-Ebenen zwischen diesen ganzen Providern. Was man noch machen kann, ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwelche unter euch Hörern gibt, die vielleicht wirklich zwei DSL-Anschlüsse haben, oder zwei Telekom DSL-Anschlüsse. Ich betreibe ja so einen eigenen BRAS, also so ein Gegenstück im Telekom Netz, am TDSL. Was theoretisch geht, was ich auch konfigurieren kann, was ich aber wie gesagt nicht ausprobieren kann, da ich nicht zwei DSL-Anschlüsse nebeneinander habe, ist ein gutes, altes Multilink-PPP. Also sozusagen das, was man früher schon bei ISDN für die B-Kanal-Bündelung benutzt hat, das kannst du auch noch auf DSL spielen. Das geht.
Aber dann brauchen wir eine Gegenstelle, wo aber auch zweimal DSL irgendwie einschlägt.
Ja, genau, auf beiden Seiten müssen die am selben Netz hängen. So, da das natürlich auch wieder ein höherer Unsicherheitsfaktor ist, gab es eben ein paar Leute, die sich das mal angeguckt haben. Und zwar hatte ich das ja schon mal vor zwei Szenen erwähnt. Es gibt diesen Lisp-Standard. RFC... vergesse. Die haben gerade erst kürzlich ihre RFC-Nummer gekriegt dafür. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, wo sich Leute mal gedacht haben, wir machen uns jetzt mal mit der Internetversorgung für eine Site mal ein bisschen unabhängig von diesen ganzen Medien, die da so rumliegen. Und der Anzahl der Anschlüsse und so. Also das heißt, wir machen jetzt mal was, wo jemand einen beliebigen Zoo von Anschlößen haben kann. Mobil, DSL, Kabel, und auch mehrere davon. Und die sozusagen sich zusammenbündeln kann. Auch dafür brauchst du natürlich wieder eine Gegenstelle, die dir im Netz sozusagen wieder zusammenknotet. Aber die muss jetzt nicht bei irgendeinem Provider sein. Die kannst du dir selber in einem Hosting-Center zusammenklicken. Oder vielleicht gibt es auch mittelfristig welche Anbieter dafür, die das machen. Und das Interessante ist, dass es da Leute gibt, die das schon mal aufgegriffen haben. Zum Beispiel die Firma AVM, die die Fritzboxen herstellt, hat ein Beta-Programm, wo sie mal ein Lisp-Client implementiert haben in ihre Fritzboxen. Das habe ich neulich mal gekriegt, so vor ein paar Wochen. Und siehe da, das funktioniert sogar. Ich habe eine Lisp-Gegenstelle bei mir in meinem Hosting-Center. Mit meiner Cisco kann ich es nämlich auch konfigurieren. Und derzeit wird es natürlich, da man in der Regel nicht zwei VDSL-Anschlüsse oder DSL-Anschlüsse zu Hause hat, habe ich das natürlich nur so simuliert. Aber man kann es zum Beispiel auch dafür benutzen, dafür V6 nochmal nach Hause zu kriegen. Weil diese Lisp transportiert alles über alles. D.h. du kannst ihm vom nassen Schnürsenkel über DSL hinlegen, kannst sagen, auf dem ist nur V6 drauf, auf dem ist nur V4 drauf. Und dann kriegst du sozusagen über diese zur Verfügung stehenden Medien mit wie auch immer gearteten Adressen, kriegst du denn deinen eigenen Adressraum V4 und V6 oder nur V6 oder nur V4 oder wie du willst. Man bildet nochmal ein, das klingt eigentlich ein bisschen... Ja, das ist keine Verschlüsselung und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das ist eingepackt, das ist so eine Art Tunnel.
Das ist ein Tunnel, das ist ein Tunnel, der da...
Du hast ja auch das fremde Netz zu deinem Hause. Du hast da nicht mehr dein VDSL-Netz von der Telekom, also die Adressen, sondern du holst dir die von dem Lisp Endpunkt irgendwie her, oder?
Ja, du hast diese Adressen, weil das sind nämlich die Endpunkte für diese Tunnel. Aber die werden dann selber sozusagen nicht mehr benutzt. Es gibt den sogenannten EID-Space, sozusagen deine eigenen internen IP-Adressen, und die werden dann über die Gesamtheit aller möglichen Tunnel verbreitet, mit Gewichtungen und Steuerung und Redundanz und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt also, wenn man sich das so mal vorstellen will, du hast halt zwei DSL-Anschlüsse, du kriegst von denen jeweils von deinem Provider, der jetzt wie gesagt nicht derselbe sein muss, jeweils eine IP-Adresse zugewiesen. Nebenan hast du jetzt einen AKO und einen TDSL-Anschluss, du kriegst von beiden eine IP-Adresse zugewiesen.
Um noch oben zu seinem Lesb-Endpunkt zu kommen, sonst nutzt man die eigentlich nicht.
Das sind dann sozusagen deine beiden Airlocks, deine Location-IDs. Das sind nämlich sozusagen gerade deine beiden Tunnel-Endpunkte auf deiner Seite. Und dann hast du eben wie gesagt eine Gegenstelle dazu. Und die muss jetzt nicht privat betrieben werden, sondern man kann auch größere Netze mitmachen, das ist nämlich das Schöne daran. Und die kann man auch zum Beispiel schön hosten zentral. Das heißt, es ist vorstellbar, dass eben Provider sich hinsetzen, fett einen Cisco-Router oder einen anderen Router da am D6 anknoten, der halt sozusagen Lisp-Endpunkt ist. Und dann kannst du da rüberjagen. Das heißt, auch da hast du wieder den Effekt, dass du Performance hast, wenn in Friedenszeiten, wenn alles geht, werden sozusagen alle Leitungen alle benutzt. Und wenn in Störungszeiten hast, hast du halt eben dein Redundanz-Thema. Und deine IP-Adressen ändern sich dahinter nicht notwendigerweise. Und du kannst eben alles darüber transportieren. Das heißt, wenn du erstmal ein Lisp-Tunnel hast, geht da V4 und V6 drüber. Und auch dann, wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwann in ferner Zukunft mal vielleicht von deinem Provider nur noch eine V6-Adresse kriegst, aber du willst jetzt noch V4 zu Hause haben, kannst du dir natürlich auch darüber abwickeln. Also es ist so alles über alles, kreuz und quer. Und da könnte man sich noch ein paar Stunden über das Konzept unterhalten. Warum wir das jetzt nicht machen? Ich wollte es dir mal vorstellen. Das Interessante, wie gesagt, daran ist, dass es halt eben kommt aus einer ITF Working Group. Cisco ist ja stark involviert da drin. Und wie gesagt, ich habe selber auch eine Cisco Implementation im Rechenzentrum. Und eben jetzt auch so Plastikrouter-Hersteller wie AFA-Media Fritzbox fangen halt eben auch damit an. Zumindest gibt es ein funktionierendes Beta-Programm.
Also wir haben in der Firma, weil wir eben so Probleme hatten mit DSL, irgendwann halt Kabel-Internet noch dazu gebucht. Und haben jetzt halt eine Leitung über DSL und eine Leitung über Kabel.
Gerade für Firmen wäre ideal.
Und eigentlich funktioniert immer eine von beiden. Also DSL häufiger als Kabel, aber irgendeine von beiden funktioniert immer.
Und wenn du das, wie gesagt, mit Lisp baust, anst du das so machen, dass du das hin und her schaltet, hoch und runterfährt, macht und tut, ohne dass du deine Konnektivität verlierst oder dauernd immer neue IP-Adressen kriegst?
Na ja, momentan machen wir das so. Also ich zumindest so, dass an dem einen hängt halt das WLAN und auf dem anderen hängt halt das Kabel-LAN. Und dann stöpselt man beides in den Rechner ein und was halt geht, da geht halt die Daten rüber. Also das ist irgendwie so.
Na gut, aber das merkt er ja nicht. Ob die Daten halfway irgendwo dann verrecken, dann hast du das Problem, dass du dann die Faultroute immer noch in die gleiche Richtung zeigt, wo es nicht weitergeht.
Ich will noch eine Sache zu sagen. Es gibt ja schon von irgendwelchen Netgehr-Router oder sonst irgendwas, wo du zwei DSL-Anschlüsse reinkündigst. Die werden dann nicht gebündelt. Du kannst auch immer dir was basteln mit einem intelligenten Router, wo du sagst, ich stecke einfach mal zwei DSL-Anschlüsse rein oder einen Kabel und einen DSL-Anschluss und mach das mal klar. Aber dann hast du selbst in Friedenszeiten nicht den Performance-Gewinn. Das heißt, du hast in Summe mehr, aber du kriegst deinen einzelnen Download. Wenn du jetzt einen einzelnen Download machst mit FTP oder HTTP-Download, der kann immer nur so stark sein, wie einer dieser beiden oder drei N-Anschlüsse. Der kann nie die Dinger zusammennehmen, weil die nicht zusammengebündelt sind. Durch diese Naterei kann man nicht sagen, ich schmeiße mal ein Paket links, eins rechts, eins fallen lassen. Der Router sucht sich für jeden Stream, also für jede HTTP-Verbindung oder für jeden UDP-Stream, sucht sich einen der beiden Kanäle aus. Dann bleibst du auch für diese Connection auf diesem Ding. Du kannst nur die Bandbreite des jeweils ausgewählten Kanals nutzen und nicht mehr. Der Vorteil ist, gerade in so einer Firmenumgebung, aber meinetwegen zu Hause, wenn du jetzt eben noch mehrere Leute hast, kann es sein, dass der Kollege neben dir noch mal denselben Download machen kann, derselben Geschwindigkeit, weil der reinzulich über den anderen Anschluss läuft. Das heißt, du hast in Summe mehr Bandbreite, aber jede einzelne Transaktion kann nur das eine von beiden oder n Dingern haben. Bei Lisp ist das nicht so. Bei Lisp verteilst du deinen gesamten Verkehr über alle Anschlüsse. Das heißt, wenn du Lisp benutzt, hast du wirklich Load Balancing, oder nicht nur Load Balancing, sondern auch eine Load Distribution über die Kanäle, die du hast, als auch Redundanz.
Der zerschnipselt dann auch die IP-Pakete?
Nee, das macht er nicht. Aber er macht einen links, einen recht einfallen lassen.
Ich habe letztens schon einem gehört, ich komme gleich zum Thema zurück, ja, kleine Kurve. Der hat sich die LSDSL-Boxen angeguckt, wie dort das Default-Passwort berechnet wird. Da gab es ja das für Easybox schon mal, dass sie das irgendwie gemacht haben. Der hat sich das letztens für die LS-Box angeguckt und hat auch entdeckt, dass es die Mac-Adresse vom Ethernet, die siehst du ja per WLAN nicht, aber die WLAN-Adresse ist genau plus eins. Also hat er das da auch genommen. Dann machen sie einen MD5 drüber, machen ein bisschen Base64 und schon hast du das Standard-Passwort. LSDSL-Router ist jetzt auch gehackt. Ich glaube, er hat es hoffentlich schon veröffentlicht, wenn nicht, habe ich zu früh erzählt. Ich bin schon mal gedacht, wo nicht in der Mitte, tausende Nachbarn, irgendwer hat immer so eine Dinge. Easybox ja auch. Theoretisch könnte man sich ja schon noch 3, 4, 5 DSL-Dosen aufmachen, um ein bisschen Netz zu kriegen. Aber wie bündelst du die Scheiße zusammen, dass ich meine Downloads schneller kriege? Genau, jetzt habe ich es. Aber ich meine, das ist es doch. Und der sieht gar nichts aus. Ist bei Lisp vielleicht doch noch so ein Crypto-Feature dabei? Oder ist das wirklich alles offensichtlich?
Du kannst darüber wieder Crypto fahren. Aber Lisp-Protokoll selber ist eigentlich eher ein öffentliches Thema.
Ist aber schade, dass man nicht auch gleich verschlüsseln kann. Weil wenn man schon über viele verschiedene Leitungen geht...
Kannst ja in Ipsac-Tunnel drüber fahren über deinen ERD-Space. Hindert dich ja keiner dran.
Innerhalb des Lisps oder außerhalb? Nein, obendrauf.
Du kannst unten drunter gehen auch. Das heißt, du kannst deine einzelnen Tunnel verschlüsseln, was vielleicht bei deinem Ich hacke meine Nachbarn sogar gar nicht doof wäre. Aber du kannst doch einfach sagen, ich bündle erstmal alle zusammen. Und was daraus kommt auf diese Bündel, mache ich jetzt nochmal in Ipsac-Tunnel drauf. Aber das ist eigentlich nicht dafür vorgesehen. Das Spannende ist nämlich diese Lisp-Geschichte. Das ist nicht so eine Punkt-zu-Punkt-Geschichte. Nach dem Motto, jeder soll sich jetzt seine Lisp-Gegenstelle unbedingt dafür einen Router und einen Hosting-Center stellen. Das machst du in so einem privaten Bereich. Aber der Standard ist so offen, dass da sozusagen so eine Wolke gebildet wird. Diese Lisp-Dinger können sich alle gegenseitig erkennen. Um dir mal ein Beispiel zu geben, nimm mal an, du hast jetzt eine Lisp-Installation und Roddy hat eine. Und ihr fangt jetzt plötzlich an, direkt miteinander Daten auszutauschen. Dann fängt dein Lisp-Teilchen an, das direkt an Roddy's Teilchen zu schicken. Die vermitteln sich. Diese Lisp-Cloud hat einen Mapping-Server drin, wo jeder sich anmeldet. Ich bin der Roddy mit folgendem IP-Adress-Space. Und ich bin der Dennis mit folgendem IP-Adress-Space. Und wenn der eine auf den anderen zugreift, dann wird dieser Map-Server gefragt, wo sind jetzt die Tunnel-Endpunkte, um folgende Ziele zu erreichen? Und dann würdet ihr direkt miteinander Daten austauschen.
Also ich würde dann direkt zu ihm tunneln, ohne über die Endpoints zu gehen?
Richtig. Also du gehst schon über den Endpunkt, über seinen.
Jaja, aber...
Das macht die Sache nochmal wieder komplex auf der einen Seite.
Also warte, das heißt, das geht nicht von seinem Zuhause zu seinem Endpunkt zu meinem Endpunkt zu meinem Zuhause. Das geht direkt von seinem Zuhause zu meinem Endpunkt zu mir nach Hause.
Nein, von seinem Zuhause zu deinem Zuhause. Direkt von seinem Zuhause nach Hause. Wenn die beiden Lisp-Wolken, an denen ihr teilnimmt, wenn die kooperieren. Jede Lisp-Wolke hat diesen Mapserver, der immer verwaltet, welche IP-Adressen oder welche eID-Space, also welcher innere IP-Adress-Space V4 und V6 liegt hinter welchen Tunnel-Endpunkten. Da gibt es so eine schöne Mapping-Database. Und das ist so konstruiert, dass diese Mapping-Databases sich auch von unterschiedlichen Lisp-Wolken miteinander verbinden und austauschen können. Oder ihr nutzt beide eh denselben NAP-Server. Dann ist es eh banal. Aber am Ende des Tages würdet ihr dann direkt miteinander Daten austauschen.
Okay, also das heißt, wenn ich Lisp über meine Nachbarn fahre, dann will ich schon die Dinger direkt in IPsec einpacken, sonst können die in einer Wolke nachfragen, wer ich denn bin.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Ich finde den schön. Ich habe mir immer überlegt, so BitTorrent wäre eigentlich genau das Richtige, um auch so das Netz deiner Nachbarn mit zu benutzen. Weil du hast ja bei BitTorrent schöne, richtig geile verschiedene Connections.
Dafür braucht es aber eben keinen Lisp. Gerade bei solchen Protokollen, die E5000-Verbindungen aufmachen, oder bei Protokollen, die E5000-Verbindungen aufmachen, kannst du auch 5000 einzelne Anschlüsse benutzen. Da kommt es nicht darauf an, dass du nicht eine Summe hast. Es wird einfacher, klar, wenn du einen Lisp benutzt. Weil dann hast du am Ende des Tages eine und dieselbe IP-Adresse. Aber wie gesagt, da könnte man sich noch ein paar Stunden drüber unterhalten. Aber das ist noch... Was ist denn jetzt die praktische Empfehlung? Ich sehe die Leute, die mich ansprechen im Chat. Da ich aber meinen Chat gerade nicht aufhabe, gibt es davon eigentlich noch einen Transkript? Kann man das hinterher nach der Sendung noch mal nachlesen? Oder ist das jetzt, wenn das oben rausgescrollt ist, vorbei? Oder ich sage jetzt einfach mal, alle liebe Hörer, die mich hier fragen wollen über Chat, ich bin nicht im Chat gerade, es gibt technische Probleme, schickt mir eine Mail, schreibt einen Kommentar und die gehe dann in den Kommentaren drauf ein.
Ja, Kommentare sind richtig.
Kommentare ist die gute.
Genau, Kommentare, wieso? Wir haben alle was davon. Also so Mail schicken.
Ja, nee, Kommentare ist schon okay.
An den Mobile-Max-Kontakt nur, wenn es wirklich irgendwas total geheim ist. Oder wichtig ist, oder lukrativ ist, oder was auch immer. Okay, ich habe jetzt die ganze List-Problematik nur so begrenzt verstanden, aber an sich ist das irgendwie was ganz Tolles, was man auf jeden Fall haben will. Aber das ist jetzt schon noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, oder?
Also, Lisp ist auch nicht der einzige...
Die eigentliche Kernfrage war ja, ich bin jetzt auf dem Land, ich will so schnell Netz haben wie möglich, Geld spielt keine Rolex, sondern es ist sozusagen nur noch die Frage, wie viele DSL-Anschlüsse kann ich jetzt hier irgendwie bestellen und geliefert bekommen? Und wenn ich dann so vier, ich hab mir jetzt so vier 3-Mega-Beteile geklickt?
Ja, das ist doch die Situation da draußen.
Was macht man praktisch, um da jetzt Netz so schnell wie möglich zu kriegen, dass sich das möglichst wie ein...
Was du derzeit dafür brauchst, ist, du brauchst zur Zeit noch einen Gegenspieler mit dicker Leitung im Netz. Den kannst du dir notfalls auch selber hosten. Das heißt, du klickst irgendeine virtuelle Maschine zusammen bei irgendeinem Hoster und lässt da sozusagen eine Lisp-Gegenstelle laufen. Es gibt verschiedene Open-Source-Implementationen für Lisp. Es gibt nicht nur das für die Hardcore-Router von Cisco oder die Plastik-Router von AVM, sondern es gibt auch ein Linux- und ein BSD-Teilchen dafür. Das haben die Leute bestimmt schon längst rausgeklickt. Das findet man so über die üblichen Wiki-Einträge und so. So ein Ding kompilierst du dir, schmeißt es auf irgendeine gehostete Maschine.
Die möglichst nicht so weit weg ist.
Die möglichst nicht so weit weg ist, die also eine gute Verbindung hat. Wenn du auf dem Land bist, kriegst du eh bloß DSL von der Telekom. Das heißt, du guckst erst mal an, welcher Hoster ist ganz gut am Telekom wegbauen, wo habe ich da geringe Pinkzeiten usw. Da schmeißt du das ab, da kompilierst du das Ding, machst du das erst mal hin. Da es noch keinen fertigen Release gibt, noch keinen fertigen Plastikrouter, die so etwas kann, also entweder, wenn du sagst, Geld spielt keine Rolex-Kurve, sondern eine kleine Cisco, kann man schon kriegen für einen dreistelligen Betrag mit mehreren DSL-Modulen drin. Dann hast du sozusagen gleich einen Router mit mehreren DSL-Anschlüssen dran, was ja auch einen gewissen Sex hat. Nimmst da den Lisp-Client, der da drin ist, sondern hast du auch einen ordentlichen Router, dann hast du den Drops auch gleich geludgt. Wenn du sagst, du willst das nicht investieren, sondern es ist schlimm genug, dass du Geld an die Telekom rausschmeißt, du willst das andere noch machen, dann machst du das selber, was du in deinem Hosting-Center gemacht hast, nämlich da den Dynix-Demon oder doch immer den FreeBSD-Demon da, zu kompilieren, machst du zu Hause auch nochmal. Und nimmst da einen PC, der mehrere Ethernet-Karten hat, steckst dem einfach da deine DSL-Modems drauf, deine vier DSL-Modems, die du dir zusammengeklickt hast, die du von dem Provider gekriegt hast, machst viermal PPP-OE-Session auf, dann hast du sozusagen vier IP-Adressen, vier Tunnel-Endpunkte, und dann schmeißt du das alles an.
Dann klingt die Cisco schon wie die sinnvollere Lösung, letztlich genauso teuer.
Ja, und der kann man auch besser lecken, um in deiner Terminologie zu bleiben. Ja, wie gesagt, so eine kleinere Cisco kann ich zum Beispiel mal sagen, wer sich das mal angucken will, wer so eine Cisco, die so was kann, zum Beispiel, so eine kleine 29er-Serie, so eine 2901 zum Beispiel.
Gibt es da auch dieses Produktmanager-Video dazu?
Kannst du da machen, die hat irgendwie noch so vier Löcher hinten drin, da kannst du jetzt entweder, wenn dir dein Provider schon die Modems zwangsweise mitliefert, was die meisten ja manchmal tun, dann steckst du die Modems, steckst du die Ethernetz, die aus diesen vier Modems rauskommen, da in vier Ethernet-Ports rein. Oder du klickst ja gleich, zum Beispiel auf eBay oder wo auch immer, oder meine Fingern auch als Original von Cisco, gleich DSL oder VDSL Modems zusammen, die du in diese Slots hinten reinsteckst.
Also muss schon noch, also das Gerät allein hilft nicht, sondern du brauchst dann auch noch die DSL-Module.
Das ist ein Router, der hat von Hause zwei Gigabit Ethernetz. Und je nachdem, was du jetzt noch hinten dranstecken willst, da kannst du in diese vier Löcher, die du da gerade siehst, kannst du alle Möche reinstecken. Da kannst du DSL-Modems, UMTS-Modems reinstecken. Da kannst du Serial-Schnittstellen reinstecken, Gigabit Ethernetz. Entweder vier DSL-Module oder, weil die Dinger teuer sind, du kaufst ja ein Modul mit vier Ethernet-Schnittstellen und nimmst einfach irgendwelche durseligen DSL-Dinger, weil wenn du auf dem Land bist, du sagst, du kriegst bloß 3 Megabit DSL, da gibt es keine Performance-Fragen, da kannst du auch einen Xing-Chang-Chong DSL-Modem für nehmen. Oder alte Fritzbox SL gibt es auf Ebay massenhaft. Ich habe einen Keller voll davon.
Da kriegst du ja eh mitgeliefert.
Bei manchen, ja, aber bei der Telekom zum Beispiel nicht auf dem Land kriegst du ja bloß Telekom, bei der Telekom kannst du dir zwar ein Modem mitklicken, aber das ist albern. Dann nimmst du diesen Cisco-Router und steckst ein 4-faches Ethernet-Modul rein und machst sozusagen auf 4 Ethernet-Sites PPPoE, machst sozusagen 4x Verbindungen auf, durch den Telekom Backbone hast du damit 4 IP-Adressen und die bündelst du mit Lisp zusammen und dann hast du deine 12 Mbps-Strecke. So eine 9901 kostet irgendwie keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, neu, irgendwie auch 900 Euro, aber es gibt auch Versender dafür.
Zum Teil kriegst du später hier sozusagen auch so 4x VDSL.
Wenn du dir ein Gegenstück dafür und dann irgendwo zusammenklickst, kannst du das machen, ja?
Das werde ich nicht tun, aber der Gedanke...
Nochmal, der Sex dabei ist der Lisp. Lisp erlaubt dir, das Zeug zusammenzubündeln, was kreuz und quer ist. Du kannst also auch, wie gesagt, zwei VDSL-Anschlüsse nehmen oder einen VDSL und einen ADSL von einem anderen Provider. Wenn du dem Lisp ordentlich sagst, wie die Dinger physikalisch ausgestattet sind, dass also eine nur 16 Megabit hat und der andere 50, dann balanciert er das auch ein bisschen aus. Also, was heißt ein bisschen? Der macht das dann richtig.
Also, bei eBay geht es bei 900 Euro los.
So, und dann schiebst du doch nichts. Aber es gibt Gebrauchtversendern. Sie kaufen mal ein Zeug von einer österreichischen Firma, weil das ist halt innerhalb von EU-Land. Und die sammeln weltweit Zeugsein- und reförbische Nöte. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob die nicht vielleicht auch Sachen nehmen, die in China vom Laster fallen. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich bin damit immer sehr zufrieden gewesen. Die haben sehr gute Preise. Willst du sagen? Nein. Nur Firmenkunden sowieso. Sagen sie extra, weil sie haben keinen Bock auf EU-Privatkundenrecht, Versandrecht. Und schreiben sie extra auf ihre Webseite und sagen, Privatkunde, bleib mir weg. Geh in deinen Saturn oder wo auch immer. Aber wie gesagt, sowas kann man bauen inzwischen. Es ist noch ein bisschen Bleeding Edge, aber es ist nicht mehr so Bleeding Edge. Diese Lisp-Geschichte ist auch schon länger am Gehen. Das Spannende ist, dass die ewig lange herum diskutiert haben, erst in den ITF Working Groups und erst vor kurzem sozusagen ihre echte RfC-Nummer gekriegt haben. Aber The Choice ist schon seit ein paar Jahren unterwegs. Sie sind auch nicht die Einzigen, die das machen. Aber die sind halt so weit, dass sie jetzt schon aus ihrem Internet-Draft-Status raus sind, eine RfC-Nummer haben und eben Leute verschiedener Hersteller das mal implementiert haben. Und das gibt auch so ein bisschen Interoperabilitätstests. Also die Fritz-Leute, die AVM-Leute testen auch gegen den Cisco-Backbone. Es gibt ein Beta-Programm bei Cisco selber. Da hänge ich auch dran mit meiner Cisco unter anderem. Da haben sich die AVM-Leute auch angemeldet und ihre Implementation dagegen getestet und so. Das ist ja aber schon mal was. Das finde ich schon mal besser, als wenn jetzt nur ein Hersteller mit einer proprietären Lösung kommt. Also sowas gibt es ja schon. Es gibt ja schon so VPN-Router von Netgearer wie auch immer, die aber nur was ganz proprietary machen, um diese Zeugster zusammenzutunneln. Und es gibt halt eben auch Open-Source-Implementationen für Linux und BSD oder sowas von dem Zeug. So.
Super.
Das war jetzt eine der Möglichkeiten dort weiteres in den nächsten Folgen.
Genau. Jetzt müssen wir mal ein Thema nehmen, wo sich Clemens ein bisschen ausruhen kann.
Ja.
Was schlägst du denn vor?
Alles solche Telekom-Themen, die wir ja noch auf der Liste haben.
Ich könnte mal ein kurzes Programmierer-Thema dazwischen werfen. Und zwar ist mir neulich eine Webseite aufgefallen. Die heißt yommel.me.
Yet another mailing list?
Yet another UML, weiß ich nicht, schlag mich tot. Auf der Webseite kann man UML-Diagramme machen, indem man die so mit ASCII-Zeichen zusammen tippt und dann schmeißt er einem die als PDF raus oder so. Und das Lustige ist, man kann diese UML-Diagramme tatsächlich auch komplett gleich in die URL zu der Webseite rein coden. Und dann zeigt er einem das halt direkt live an. Also wenn man mal so schnell zwischendurch ein niedliches UML-Diagramm braucht, kann man diese Webseite verwenden. Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht benutzt. Das sagt es vielleicht, aber ich fand das irgendwie ganz cool. Neulich war nämlich bei den Popcorn-Piraten so ein Artikel, wer gerade wen bei den Piraten verklagt. Und die hatten da so ein nettes Diagramm gemacht mit ganz vielen Pfeilen und Kisten. Und dann stand da drunter erzeugt mit Jummel, also mit dieser Webseite. Da dachte ich mir, das ist ja spannend, klickst du mal drauf. Und dann ist das aber eigentlich ein UML-Diagrammgenerator. Aber um so Beziehungen aller Art mit Kisten und Pfeilen zu machen, ist das ganz cool. Nur so als kleiner Tipp nebenbei.
Wer verklagt wen? Oh Mann.
Naja, Popcorn-Piraten halt, ne?
Das ist überhaupt, finde ich, so die Medien-News-Seite des Jahres. Vom Nachrichten- und Unterhaltungswert gleichermaßen.
Na, so oft gucke ich da nicht drauf, aber...
Das ist immer wieder erstaunlich. Ja, wo wir gerade noch beim Programmieren sind, auch wenn das vielleicht hier manchen, der hier zuhört, schon überhaupt keine Neuigkeit mehr darstellt, aber da möchte ich noch mal in eigener Sache auf eine Crowdfunding-Aktion hinweisen, die wir gestartet haben. Und zwar geht es da natürlich um das Projekt PodLove. PodLove ist ja eine Initiative, die sich bemüht, bessere Standards und auch Software für Podcasting hervorzubringen. Vor allem, also vor allem im Fokus ist derzeit natürlich der PodLove Publisher, was so eine Plug-in-Lösung ist für WordPress und der dazugehörige Webplayer. Und um da mal in etwas größeren Schritten voranzukommen, sammeln wir gerade so ein bisschen Geld ein, um einfach mal die Programmierer irgendwie aus ihren Jobs rauszukaufen und die Möglichkeit zu geben, an Verspaßigen zu arbeiten, und nicht nur an irgendwelchen Foo. Da gibt es dann auf Metaebene ME den entsprechenden Blog-Eintrag beziehungsweise auch die entsprechende Spenden-Informationsseite. Und ja, das ist schon sehr gut angenommen worden, muss ich auch dazu sagen. Also das Ganze läuft jetzt seit einer Woche und es sind jetzt schon 3000 Euro zusammengekommen. Das ist natürlich total großartig. Kann aber gerne auch noch ein bisschen weitergehen, weil das schafft dann einfach nochmal deutlich mehr Möglichkeiten. Das ist jetzt so das Minimum, was ich mir so erhofft hatte, ist quasi da. Und ab jetzt wird es halt wirklich richtig spaßig. Und ich bin auch relativ sicher, dass wir da zügig vorankommen und mal sehen. Also bei dem Zuspruch und den Unterstützungsleistungen, die sich da gerade abzeichnet, kann man dann vielleicht auch noch ein paar etwas mutigere Projekte folgen lassen. Ja, über die ich jetzt noch gar nicht so viel sagen kann. Aber das ist schon toll. Vielen Dank an alle, die jetzt bisher schon gespendet haben. Und ja, ich werde es nicht bereuen. Wir könnten hier nochmal ein bisschen in die Glaskugel gucken, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Alle reden die ganze Zeit von diesem Google-Glas. Und von einer iWatch. Und irgendwie scheint nicht so ganz klar zu sein, ob die Zukunft der Welt sich jetzt mehr in einer Armbanduhr oder in einer Brille widerschlägt.
Ehrlich gesagt, wo du Google Glass und Apples iWatch in einem Atemzug nennst, fällt mir überhaupt erst auf, wie diese beiden Produkte eigentlich den Unterschied zwischen Apple und Google charakterisieren.
Google hat den Durchblick?
Das ist so das, was ich theoretisch unter dem Ärmel von meiner Jacke habe, was ich nur hervorhole, wenn ich da mal draufschauen will. Und Google Glass ist so dieses Ding, was ich immer aufhabe, was immer die ganze Zeit die Umgebung filmt und lauscht. Das finde ich eine großartige Allegorie irgendwie.
Ob da auch so ein 650.02-Code von oben nach unten durchläuft wie beim Terminator?
Gibt es da bestimmt.
Das wäre ja wiederum ganz cool. Da musste ich ja sehr grinsen, als ich Terminator gesehen habe. Mein bevorzugter Maschinensprachecode lief auf einmal über den Bildschirm.
Das ist zu lange her. Ich glaube, ich würde den nicht wieder erkennen.
Ach klar, LDA, STA.
Stimmt, LDA, STA, BSR und PPL.
Ich weiß sogar noch, was LDA immediate ist. A9. A9 2A heißt, lade mal 42 in das A-Register. Damals war es, als wir noch cutgroßerdriver.o geschrieben haben.
Was soll man zu diesem Google Glass schon sagen?
Es gibt ja auch interessante Phantom-Debatten. Wir unterhalten uns über ein Produkt, von dem noch nicht mal klar ist, ob es jemals das Licht des Tages sieht. Google bemüht sich zwar redlich, den Eindruck entstehen zu lassen, aber sie haben auch schon ganz andere Sachen angekündigt, die, wenn sie dann zumindest gekommen sind, auch nicht unbedingt so lange gehalten haben. Was ich aber grundsätzlich interessant finde und worüber wir hier auch noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist Googles unglaublicher Drang derzeit an die Hardware-Front. Zeitgleich auch mit Microsoft, wenn auch auf noch ganz anderen Wegen. Ja, das kommt ja da sozusagen auch noch mit rein. Ich meine, diese Chromebooks sind ja in dem Sinne noch nichts Neues, nur dass sie jetzt in zunehmendem Maße auch eigenes Branding verfolgen. Also sozusagen so Google-Computer machen, der Nutzen...
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, ich meine, auch mit Android sind sie doch noch nirgendwo hingekommen bis zu dem Punkt, wo sie dann ihr eigenes Handy mal gemacht haben. Und dann ging es irgendwie los. Und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch so eine Lektion, aus der sie gelernt haben, wenn ich will, dass ein bestimmtes Betriebssystem, Software, was irgendwie auch von Drittherstellern verwendet wird, dann muss ich mit eigener Hardware vorlegen, die den Use-Case auch zeigt.
Ja gut, aber ob nun diese Nexus-Telefone da wirklich entscheidend waren für den Markterfolg von Android, das wage ich stark zu bezweifeln. Ich meine, der Erfolg von Android ist der Erfolg von Samsung derzeit und nicht der Erfolg von Google.
Ja, stimmt natürlich. Trotzdem kann ich mir vorstellen, dass wir so ein Google Glass eher von HTC als von Google selber sehen. Oder von einem Samsung oder von einem You-Name-It. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Google Glass als Hardware ankündigt und vielleicht auch irgendwann in irgendwelche Läden tut. Das hat, glaube ich, nichts damit zu tun, dass sie wirklich Hardware anbieten wollen. Sondern nur, dass sie quasi einen Demonstrator auf die Straße bringen wollen. Wir haben hier das neue System und so funktioniert das, liebe Hersteller. Und seid doch jetzt mal begeistert, weil die Leute kaufen.
Aber was ist denn die Vision hier eigentlich? Glauben die jetzt ernsthaft, dass sich Millionen Leute in so einen Cyborg-Modus versetzen werden? Und dann vielleicht auch noch zusätzlich zu ihrer Brille, die sie sowieso schon haben, noch irgendwie dieses, wie ist das überhaupt gedacht, dass man das da drunter trägt oder da drüber oder was? Oder ist das nur für Leute ohne Brillen? Also das verstehe ich schon mal überhaupt nicht. Und auch ansonsten, jeder wird wissen, dass das das Ding ist mit der Kamera. Und du kriegst doch einfach nur auf die Fresse mit dem Tag.
Der Backlash wird sicherlich groß sein.
Aber so richtig krass.
Ihr wisst schon, dass irgendwie 95% aller Leute bei Facebook sind und sich da ein Scheiß drum kümmern.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich warte noch darauf, dass in Deutschland wieder losgeht, dass die Leute selber sich mit ihrem Foto bei Google registrieren, um sich denn verpixeln zu lassen. Das heißt, wenn du dann mit deinem Google Glass durch die Straße rennst, gingen dir plötzlich Leute, deren Gesichter verpixelt sind.
Also grundsätzlich finde ich die Idee von so einem Google Glass und so einem Head-Up-Display ja nicht verkehrt. Also ich finde das schon ganz cool.
Was heißt nicht verkehrt? Was ist der Use-Case? Wozu braucht man das?
Das haben sich die Leute vor 50 Jahren auch gefragt.
Wozu brauche ich ein Telefon?
Info, navigieren. Was machst du auf deinem iPhone? Da guckst du immer aufs Display und willst irgendwas wissen? Das könnte eine Menge davon in deiner Brille kommen. Also man muss ja schon auch mal ein bisschen ausprobieren. Die wissen ja vielleicht selber noch nicht, was so cool ist. Und wir wissen es ja auch noch nicht. Aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass da auch ganz...
Ich bin doch nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie so ein Teil in die Fresse, nur damit ich irgendwie ab und zu mal drauschauen kann.
Nur wenn du es halt wissen willst. Sonst ist natürlich da freie Sicht.
Ja, aber wenn ich es wissen will, kann ich doch draufgucken.
Aufs Telefon? Musst du ja erst rausholen.
Dann hole ich es ja aber auch erst raus. Also ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Vorteil.
Früher hat es ja kein Telefon. Da hast du ja deinen Rechner rausgeholt. Jetzt bist du halt ein Stück schneller, indem du dein Telefon schnell aus der Tasche ziehen kannst. Demnächst bist du halt noch schneller, weil du es auf deiner Brille trägst. Also ich finde, man muss auch ein bisschen mal offener in die Sachen rangehen.
Glaubst du ernsthaft, dass irgendwann alle Leute mit so einer scheiß Brille rumrennen?
Tim, haben vor 70 Jahren Leute ernsthaft dran geglaubt, dass du mit einem Telefon in der Tasche rumrennst? Wofür braucht man ein Telefon? Ich muss nicht da unten im Führerhauptkarteal anrufen.
Ich habe das geglaubt.
Vor 70 Jahren?
Ach, vor 70 Jahren. Vor 70 Jahren war ich noch nicht auf der Welt, was weiß ich.
Aber diese Frage stellt sich doch jede Generation.
Ich rede aber nicht von in 70 Jahren, sondern dieses Produkt kommt jetzt auf den Markt.
Es kommt überhaupt gar nicht auf den Markt.
Du bist aber auch schon über 30.
Momentan ist es halt ein Early Adopter Spielzeug. Das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn sie jetzt nicht allzu große Stückzahlen davon fertigen, dass sie sie auch loswerden. Und dann wird sich natürlich die Frage, was soll das, auf die Dauer erst mal stellen und erst mal zu klären sein. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ein Brillenträger sich so ein Teil holt und dann geschliffene Gläser da reinmachen lässt. Und dann ist es seine eigene Brille. Weil wenn er nach zwei Wochen merkt, dass es irgendwie doch scheiße ist, dann braucht er wieder eine neue Brille oder so. Keine Ahnung. Also, ich kann da auch nur spekulieren. Vor allen Dingen würde mich dann doch auch mal interessieren, wie gut ist denn das Display, was da drin ist? Weißt du, wenn ich da irgendwie riesige Pixel vor der Fresse habe, dann, weißt du, das muss dann schon Retina-Auflösung haben.
Ja, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, dass es irgendwas bringt. Also, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt lass doch mal die technischen Feinheiten weg, ob da nun das Display gut genug ist, aber meint er nicht, dass es irgendwie cool ist, auch Sachen direkt so Head-up-Display-mäßig da eingeblendet zu bekommen?
Das mag zwar cool sein, aber wenn wir jetzt schon wieder über nicht-technische Themen reden, dann komme ich wieder und sage, ich lebe in einem Land, wo es garantiert irgendeine Behörde gibt, der dir das ohnehin wieder verbietet. Zumindest ist damit draußen rumzurennen.
Das ist ja jetzt doch mal eine ganz andere Frage.
Ich meine jetzt mal so grundsätzlich, ob das Google Glass dann irgendwie überhaupt erfüllen wird oder nicht, aber wenn du so ein Ding auf der Nase hast, und ich weiß nicht, wie man es bedienen soll, über Sprache angeblich, oder man muss OK Glass sagen, oder was muss man sagen?
Ach, reden muss ich dann auch noch damit?
Auf der Straße rumstehen, da komme ich ja schon nicht von meinem Telefon.
Jetzt soll ich auch noch mit meiner Brille reden.
Das sehe ich auch noch so ein bisschen als Problem.
Das Play ist natürlich auch schlecht, oder?
So Touch, also entweder ist das Ding irgendwie mental gekoppelt, oder es hat so zwei, drei Druckknöpfe am Ohr. Weil ich meine, wenn schon Geheimagent, dann richtig. Also, auch noch mit meiner Brille reden. Mehr zum Volltrottel auf der Straße kannst du dich ja nun wirklich nicht machen.
Das haben aber die ersten Leute, die vor 20 Jahren das erste Handy in der Hand hatten, auch. Die wurden auch für beglaubt gehalten.
Das Glas ist nicht das Äquivalent zum Handy. Das ist das Äquivalent zur Handy-Tasche. Na ja, das ist so eine Extension, die irgendwie Zukunftsschlupfen...
Oder stell dir vor, Bluetooth ist das bessere.
Das haben sie aber von den ersten Leuten gedacht, die mit Kopfhörern in der Straße rumgelaufen sind.
Ja, dann sind die Leute auch immer mit diesem scheiß Bluetooth-Headset durch die Gegend gerannt, obwohl sie es gerade gar nicht benutzt haben.
Weil man könnte ja angerufen werden.
Man könnte ja angerufen werden oder man könnte ja angerufen... Oder man könnte mal nicht mehr wissen, wie man zum scheiß Döner kommt. Und dann muss ich sagen, Hallo, Glas, liebe Brille, blende mir einen Scheiß ein.
Shortest way to the Döner.
OSPF-Döner.
Wo geht's zum Döner? Und dann sagt er, meinten Sie Dirne?
Ich verstehe irgendeinen Scheiß nicht.
Ich meine vielleicht, um so ein Straßenstrichscanning zu betreiben, ist das vielleicht geil, aber du kriegst einfach auf die Fresse. Vor allem, wenn du in so etwas sensitiven Bereichen unterwegs bist, wo die Leute einfach überhaupt gar keinen Bock haben, auch nur das Gefühl zu haben, du könntest sie die ganze Zeit filmen. Du kriegst einfach auf die Fresse.
So ein Chaos-Congress zum Beispiel.
Auf jeden Fall kriegst du da richtig auf die Fresse.
Die Frage ist übrigens auch nochmal kurz, weil die Technik funktioniert ja nur, solange du da Bits dran hast an der Brille. Und diese Bits hast du ja nur unterwegs über ein Mobilfunknetz. Diese Brille hat selber kein Modem drin. Die wird wahrscheinlich über Bluetooth mit deinem Android-Phone oder mit deinem iPhone reden. Wo kriegt die ihre Bits her? Weißt du das schon jemand? Weil das ist ja wie gesagt auch nochmal dein Powerproblem. Das ist super toll, wenn du eine super geile, schicke Brille hast, aber hinten mit einem 10 Kilo Rucksack durch die Gegend rennen musst, weil das Ding Strom verbraucht, bis der Arzt kommt.
Ich werde übrigens gerade im Chat zurecht gerügt, weil ich sozusagen gegen meine eigene Regel verstoßen habe.
Die da wäre?
Ich kritisiere das immer gerne, dass Leute bei neuer Technologie dann immer fragen, wozu brauche ich das? Und jetzt habe ich das sozusagen auch mal gemacht.
Du hast ja den Max gemacht, ja?
Nee, mit Max hat das nichts zu tun. Das ist eher so eine grunddeutsche Eigenschaft und vielleicht setzt das auch irgendwann ein mit 45. Ist schon so weit, ja? Gehen wir das mal ganz nerdig an. Sagen wir mal, was kann man damit machen? Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir nicht irgendwie auf die Fresse kriegen.
Navigation aller Art?
Ich habe jetzt das scheiß Teil auf und gehe irgendwie durch die Straßen. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn das Ding da ist, dann muss es mir auch mehr oder weniger permanent einen Mehrwert bieten, der instantan da sein muss.
Also er könnte dir deinen App.net-Stream immer draufhalten.
Ja, und dann renne ich gegen die Laterne.
Du hast es ja nur auf dem einen Auge. Wenn ich das recht verstanden habe, hast du ja das Display nur auf dem einen Auge und auf dem anderen Auge nicht. Das ist etwas, was ich mir eigentlich auch nicht so rechtlich vorstellen kann. Dass das nicht Kopfweh macht.
Mit dem zweiten siehst du besser.
Ja, mit dem zweiten sehe ich dann die Laterne.
Okay, mir fällt gerade eine Anwendung ein. Sport. Und zwar Inlineskating konkret.
Also wenn du selber skatest oder wenn du dir eine Sportübertragung von Inlineskatern angriffst?
Nein, wenn ich selber skate.
Und wozu denn? Weil du so schnell bist, dass du Kilometer anzeigest.
Geschwindigkeit, Position, Restweg.
Ja gut, kannst du auch joggen oder Fahrrad fahren oder so.
Ja genau, Fahrrad fahren genauso. Vor allem, wo man sozusagen die Hände nicht frei hat und wo es schon immer irgendwie ein Scheiß ist.
Motorrad fahren, im Helm, da will man halt...
Auto ist egal.
Aber es sind Situationen, wo man isoliert ist.
Da gucke ich auch Leute an und so weiter.
Nee, aber du bist... Niemand fühlt sich unmittelbar... Wenn du mit der Motorradstraße entlang fährst, dann wählen sich die Leute nicht in ihrem sozialen Raum.
Wenn ich da fahre, schon. Nee, aber das Recht ist nicht so direkt.
Genau, wenn ich inline skate oder wenn man im Fahrrad fährt, dann ist man irgendwie raus. Aber ich würde sie danach irgendwie abnehmen. Ich glaube, dieses Bild, was alle so verwirrt und mich auch ist, man setzt es auf und läuft normal durch die Straße.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Aber für Touris zum Beispiel, wo dann auch immer gleich hier da ist das und gleich so ein Dings Texte. Ich meine, jetzt rennen die ja mit dem iPhone rum und müssen da mal hingucken und latschen wahrscheinlich irgendwie andauernd überall gegen.
Es gibt doch schon diese Dinge, wo du diese Augmented Reality-Geschichte machen, wo du durch dein iPhone die Kamera durchguckst, das Bild siehst, und sie da noch irgendwelche Sachen draufmalen. Gibt es ja schon in der Einzelweite. Was mir jetzt einfällt, wo sich ein paar Leute aus der Hand reißen, gibt ja jetzt schon genügend Spacken, die Ingress spielen. Diese Google-Statt-Spiel auf den Google-Phones. Wo denn virtuelle Dinger rumstehen, frage mich, wie die heißen, ein Freund, ein Kollege von mir spielt das. Das ist mir neulich aufgefallen, den habe ich mitgenommen, sozusagen mal ins Büro oder sowas. Und der war die ganze Zeit... Der saß da mal auf dem Beifahrersitz und konnte sozusagen selber mal gucken. Hier ist ja jetzt ein neuer so und so mit Energie aufgeladen. Und was, das sieht nicht alles. Du guckst mich gerade so an, schon gehört von diesem ingeres Zeug.
Ich hab das Wort schon mal irgendwo gelesen, aber bei...
Das war früher eine Datenbank. Ja, eben.
Und da führe ich das nämlich auch immer noch.
Es ist jetzt, wie gesagt, so ein Spiel, was wie gesagt, was Google betreibt, was du dann auf deinen Android-Phones und so was machen kannst. Was sich aber in deiner realen Stadt rumtreibt. In deiner sozusagen... Im Meet-Space befinden sich virtuelle Dinger noch. Andere Spieler und andere...
Sowas wie Shadow City?
Dinger, keine Ahnung, was Shadow City ist, da bin ich jetzt wieder raus.
Das ist das gleiche Spiel auf dem iPhone. Da musstest du auch irgendwie... Da hab ich doch mal eine Weile gezockt. Da bin ich immer zum Nordbahnhof gefahren, um meinen Gegner platt zu machen. Kurz vor Feierabend immer noch schnell zum Nordbahnhof, ausgestiegen, also abgestiegen vom Moped irgendwie, iPhone raus, irgendwie seine Portale platt gemacht und wieder nach Hause gefahren. Und nächsten Morgen war die Gruppe gestanden mit, weil ich stehe erst um 10 Uhr auf, der war schon irgendwie um 8 Uhr wach und dann hat er mir am Nordbahnhof meine Dinger wieder weggekloppt, weil er vor mir aufgestanden ist. Du musst halt physikalisch da sein oder dich irgendwie so hin hüpfen können. Aber hinfahren geht manchmal schneller als sich da hinzuhangeln. Deswegen zum Feierabend nach Hause fahren, erst mal noch schnell irgendwo hinfahren und Sachen platt machen. Ingress ist irgendwie ein bisschen so. Nur ein bisschen advanced, glaube ich. Die haben die Idee noch ein bisschen weiter vorgeführt und noch eine Story drumherum gemacht und haben einfach noch ein bisschen mehr Geld draufgesteckt.
Und die Leute, die das jetzt machen, die werden so eine Brille lieben.
Ich glaube, da gibt es Tausend Sachen, wo wir uns noch gar nicht vorstellen können, wo es cool sein könnte. Aber ich denke mir natürlich schon auch, dass viele Leute sich irgendwie, die wollen nicht gefilmt werden und was soll der Scheiß und du willst natürlich auch irgendwie nicht quatschen mit deiner Brille. Also ich meine, bei Star Trek sah das immer toll aus, wenn die mit dem Communicator reden. Aber die haben auch immer nur einen gezeigt, der das gerade macht und um den ging es auch gerade. Wenn die mal so einen Star Trek zeigen würden, so eine große Halle, wo sie alle irgendwie die ganze Zeit gerade in den Communicator reinquatschen würden, das würde nicht mehr schick aussehen. Also es war...
Ich glaube, wenn man das in so einer Hipster...
Ich meine mal ehrlich, die Zukunft wird sein, dass du so eine Brille hast und du wirst gar nicht mehr erkennen, ob da überhaupt noch eine Kamera dran ist oder nicht, weil das so eine kleine Linse ist, die irgendwie so toll ist.
Du meinst, alle sind einfach nur noch Brillenträger?
Na irgendwann sowieso. Also wenn da deine Bionic Enhancements da irgendwie drin sind und du wirst auch, so wie Microsoft schon mal irgendwann sagte, du wirst ja irgendwann alle deine Daten irgendwie speichern und ich glaube, es wird als erstes losgehen mit Audio. Du wirst einfach rund um 24-7 dein eigenes Audio um dich herum aufnehmen, weil dann vielleicht deine Versicherungsprämie billiger ist oder irgendwie so. Und in Autos wird es ja vielleicht auch kommen. Da geht es ja auch schon los, habe ich heute irgendwas gelesen, ein Spiegel oder was, dass es wohl kommen soll, dass wenn ein Auto die ganze Zeit irgendwie sich so ein Lockbook führt, so elektronisches, kriegst du den.
Die Russen.
Also es werden sowas von durchdigitalisiert werden und wir werden es nicht verändern können. Da können wir so viel zappeln, wie wir wollen. Ich fände das auch nicht gut und ich bin jetzt auch kein Spackrier-Typ. Aber es ist schwer dagegen anzugehen.
Und meinst du, Google hat Erfolg mit dem Scheiß?
Ja, das sind die ersten. Und dann kommt da vielleicht irgendwer, der es besser macht. Aber was ich mir gut vorstellen könnte, ist, dass sie eine Menge an Patenten jetzt schon mal abstecken. Die machen das ja nicht einfach. Oder bereits verletzen. Oder so. Oder gucken, wer welche hat, um die frühstmöglich einzukaufen. In der Uhr bin ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen skeptisch. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man mit der Uhr...
Max meint, das ist ja das große nächste Ding.
Ja, aber das hat er vor zwei Jahren auch gemacht.
Vor ADN oder wie?
Ja, das wäre doch mal visionär gewesen.
Ja, jetzt machen wir gerade mal kurz einen Reality-Check. Trägst du eine Uhr?
Nein.
Trägst du eine Uhr?
Ich hab ein iPhone.
Trägst du eine Uhr? Ich auch nicht.
Ich hab ein iPhone. Seitdem ich überhaupt ein Mobiltelefon hab, brauch ich irgendwie keine Uhr mehr.
Sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, wenn Apple eine Uhr bauen würde.
Wenn die so im hässlichen Beiß ist, dann nicht.
Wenn die gebürstet ist, Aluminium, dann brauchen wir darüber reden.
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, dass man sagt, du trägst aber keine Uhr, sondern du trägst Apple-Schmuck, der versehentlich auch die Uhrzeit anzeigt.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, die Uhren, die ich bisher getragen habe, waren fast alle eher auf der, sie zeigen vor allen Dingen die Uhr an und sind nicht so auf der Warnschmuck-Seite.
Ja, aber das Thema Uhr ist ja nicht neu. Es gibt durchaus Uhren, und ich hatte auch sehr schöne Uhren, aber ich brauche sie echt nicht mehr. Und zwar seit vielen, vielen Jahren nicht mehr. Und deswegen trage ich keine, weil diese Funktion, ich will dieses Ding nicht am Handgelenk haben, auch nicht meine schönen Uhren.
Geh mal einen Schritt zurück und stell dir einfach vor, du hast eine Status-Anzeige am Handgelenk.
Ja, deswegen sag ich ja.
Früher war ja Status-Anzeige, weil eine Uhrzeit zu wissen war ja schon mal ein guter Status. Da ging es dann auch nicht auf die Minute genau. Aber man konnte schon so sein Leben mit einer Armbanduhr relativ gut strukturieren.
Aber du kommst genau auf meinen Punkt zurück, dass ich sage, wir sollten hier nicht darüber diskutieren über eine Apple-Uhr, sondern wir sollten über ein Stück Appelschmuck, was man am Handgelenk tragen kann, diskutieren. Was versehentlich auch als eine von 500 Funktionen, die auch die Uhrzeit mit anzeigen kann.
Ich denke, die Uhr ist dafür da, dass man halt sein iPhone öfter in der Tasche lassen kann, um so schon bestimmte Sachen zu gucken.
Das sehe ich anders. Ich sehe es halt mehr als eine zusätzliche Anzeige. Aber nicht als Uhr? Nein, jetzt nicht direkt als Uhr, aber schon als etwas, was am Handgelenk trägt. Nicht, damit man einen Armreif am Handgelenk hat.
Das ist die iPhone-Display-Extension.
Sondern eher so als Display und Minimalinteraktion. Wie auch immer du es nennen willst. Als Minimalinteraktion mit dem Gerät, das du nicht aus der Tasche nehmen willst, wenn, wie oder was.
Ich habe das schon verstanden. Aber es ist keine Uhr, die dir noch Daten mit anzeigt. Das ist ein Datending, das dir unter anderem als eine von 500 Funktionen auch versehentlich die Uhrzeit mit anzeigen kann.
Was ist der Punkt, dass es nicht um die Uhrzeit geht?
Ja, aber das ist eben auch eine Frage der Betrachtungsweise.
Lassen wir das mit der Uhr mal weg. Es ist klar, man kann seine Uhrzeit mittlerweile auch vom Telefon beziehen. Das wissen wir alle. Die Frage ist, wenn es ein solches Gerät gibt, und ich bin noch überhaupt nicht davon überzeugt, dass das jetzt irgendwie irgendwas ist, was Apple demnächst ankündigt. Aber einfach mal so als Gedankenexperiment, um sich vielleicht auch mal was vorstellen zu können. Was könnte es denn sein? Gibt es denn überhaupt etwas, was absolut wünschenswert sinnvoll wäre? Und wenn Apple ins Spiel kommt, müsste es ja auch wirklich eine unfassbare Dimension haben. Also es müsste sozusagen so attraktiv sein, dass echt viele Leute das haben wollen. Viele, viele, viele Millionen Leute, potentiell. Weil sonst würden sie sowas nicht bauen.
Das ist ja auch ein Pose-Item.
Ja gut, aber Apple verkauft jetzt nicht nur Geräte, weil man damit posen kann.
Aber deswegen verkaufen sie viel Geräte.
Nein, die verkaufen deshalb viele Geräte, weil es gute Geräte sind, die was Sinnvolles tun, was Leute wirklich brauchen und haben wollen.
Mit denen man posen kann.
Dass man damit noch posen kann, mag dazu beitragen, dass es sich besser verkauft. Aber das ist nicht so, dass man das deswegen kauft, auch wenn das gerne Apple unterstellt wird.
Viele Leute, die posen wollen, sind längst bei den 4,8 Zoll Display Samsung-Fonts.
Mit dem Stullenbrett am Ohr, ja?
Fat-Fonts, wie ich sie immer nenne.
Ja gut, aber ok, was glauben wir? Glaskugel jetzt mal aufmachen.
Aber mir ist ehrlich gesagt jetzt noch nicht so eine gute Anwendung eingefallen, was man denn da sehen wollte. Ich meine, was will ich denn sehen? Ich will meine Nachrichten sehen. Oder meine Push-Notifications. Das heißt, der Bildschirm, der sich dann hier in Retina-Style vor mir abspielt, muss in der Lage sein, zumindest solche Notifications irgendwie ausreichend anzuzeigen. Dann muss man sich schon mal fragen, ob der Bildschirm vielleicht genauso breit sein müsste wie ein iPhone 5. Das macht das Teil schon recht breit. Nicht vielleicht komplett ausgeschlossen. Vielleicht ein Viertel von dem Bildschirm von einem iPhone 5. Also der Länge nach ein Viertel. Vielleicht 20 Prozent.
Also ganz ehrlich, um Notifications anzuzeigen, würde auch die halbe Breite reichen. Du kannst sie ja anders umbrechen.
Am Ende holst du ja eh dein iPhone aus der Tasche.
Ja, aber irgendwie...
Also diese ganzen Notifications, zumindest so wie Apple sie macht, ist ja was, wo ich eher sagen würde, die Uhr kommt nicht, weil sie haben es ja beim iOS noch nicht im Griff. Also das ist ja alles irgendwie nur so eine halbe Lösung mit den Notifications. Meiner Meinung nach. Das ist irgendwie so...
Deswegen glaube ich, dass es ja nur eine iPhone Display Extension ist, um zu sagen, dass man jetzt mal sein iPhone aus der Tasche holen müsste, weil da irgendwas ist.
Das weiß man ja auch, wenn es brummt.
Ja, ich verpasse voll viel.
Üben Sie nur so nebenbei. Auch das kann man dann durchaus wieder machen. Das ist durchaus eine dezentere Art und Weise, Notifications zu machen. Weil Brummen am Handgelenk ist noch unauffälliger als Brummen von einem Telefon, das auf dem Tisch liegt.
Ja, aber dann reicht es aber, wenn ich am Handgelenk einfach nur eine Brummfunktion habe. Also einfach nur den Vibrator...
Das wäre aber wahrscheinlich nicht hip genug für Apple, um das zu produzieren. Das ist wieder was für irgendwelche Dritthersteller.
So lange es den Brettchen da brummt, ist es voll schön warm. Also was ich cool fände, wenn es dabei wäre, ist, wenn das Teil tatsächlich einen Kopfhörer bzw. einen richtigen Headset-Anschluss hätte. Weil du dann nicht mehr in die Tasche kabeln musst.
Das geht inzwischen ohne Schnur. Ganz ehrlich, da bindet mir nicht eine Strippe ans Handgelenk. Hallo, wie sieht denn das aus?
Du bist ja richtig Opfer.
Solche Leute tragen auch Google Glass.
Ich bin eigentlich auch ein bisschen skeptisch, was das Killer-Feature von dieser Eyewatch sein sollte. Mir fällt auch nicht so richtig was ein.
Ich habe vor Jahren schon mal im Geiste ein Ei-Produkt kreiert, was mal wirklich mal anders wäre. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe dann Steve einfach gestorben. Und ich hätte keine Ahnung, wer ich sonst hätte einreden sollen. Oder den Eyeball. Das passt auch, glaube ich, ganz gut. Und zwar eine Kugel, wo die komplette Oberfläche ein Display ist. Damit kannst du nämlich durchaus mal interessante andere Sachen darstellen. Ja, du kannst all möglichen Daten darauf darstellen. Du kannst damit auch anders umgehen. Du kannst ja diesen Ball mal rumdrehen zum Beispiel. Oder ihn anders rumflippen. Also das würde ganz neue Bewegungs- oder Bedienungskonzepte ermöglichen. Du kannst Daten anders visualisieren und so weiter und so fort. Ja, klar. Aber das fand ich mal irgendwie sehr witzig. Ich hab das mal Spaßes, aber mit einem Kollegen auf so einer Weihnachtsfeier oder so was, weiß ich noch, ein paar Stunden mal zusammengesessen, einfach mal zusammensponnen, wie so was aussehen könnte, was machen würde. Was ja auch mal interessant ist, weil du hast ja dann vom Prinzip eine endlose Display-Oberfläche. Die gibt dir dann keine Render mehr auf einer Kugel-Oberfläche.
Jetzt kannst du ohne Ende scrollen.
Du kannst, ja, oder...
Aber was soll denn das für eine Anwendung haben?
Das ist immer die Frage, was du darauf visualisieren willst.
Ja, aber trotzdem musst du ja mindestens mal eine Anwendung nennen können, wo ich sage, ah ja, deswegen brauch ich das.
Dann machst du eine Weltkugel drauf und guckst ja darauf an, wie das Wetter ist, oder deinen Börsenkurs in Tokio, in dem du einfach die Kugel rumdrehst. Oder die, die andere Seite der Kugel anguckst. Wenn es ein Killer-Feature wäre, wäre ich jetzt schon Milliardär. Aber ich fand die Idee damals mal interessant. Vor allen Dingen ist es mal was anderes.
Du weißt, dass du jetzt ungefähr gefühlt 10.000 Kilowatt Energie für das Apple Headquarter erzeugt hast. Weil jetzt Steve sich mindestens fünf Mal im Graben umgedreht hat. Und da ist einfach so viel Energie drin.
Er hätte tolle Funden, ganz ehrlich.
Der dreht sich, ich sag's dir, das flattert richtig.
Nein, nein, nein, Eyeball, das gibt's auf Eyeball. Das ist eine tolle Idee.
Überleg dir erstmal, da kann man auch mal von der Software denken.
Mal abgehen von diesem komischen, rechteckigen Bildschirm, dem man wieder wie drauf rumgelangt sind soll.
Es gibt sowas natürlich unter dem Stichwort virtuelle Globen.
Aber die haben dann so 6 Meter Durchmesser.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was so der Range ist.
Ich würde mal sowas in die Hand nehmen wollen.
Ja, also als Globus, jetzt sagen wir mal dediziert als...
Ich weiß, ich hab mir das damals angeguckt.
Gibt Firmen, die sowas herstellen, kosten Geld, steht in irgendwelchen Museen rum oder sowas, wo die Leute dann sozusagen von innen auch gegenprojizieren und so.
Genau, die halt auch wirklich 360 Grad Projektion machen. Ja, wenn man jetzt natürlich hier sucht, gibt es nur Bilder. Vielleicht haben wir mal was so gesehen in der Richtung. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau. So, soviel zur Glaskugel.
Ja, naja, was soll man zu der Uhr schon sagen?
Wir können jetzt hier mit etwas handfesteren Dingen beschäftigen.
Ich habe selber noch kein Zeug, aber ich weiß, was das ist.
Sag mal.
Das ist eine Fritz-Ausrufezeichen. Das ist eine Kombination, die ich nicht verstanden habe.
Deckt 200. Einrichten und bedienen.
Das ist eine Steckdose, die Deckt spricht. Eine Deckdose. Genau.
Was das heißt? Ein Stromschalter, der sich per Deckdose... Steuern und Auslesen lesen lässt.
Ja, der biste nämlich nebenbei noch den Stromverbrauch.
Genau, also es agiert auch als Stromverbrauchssensor.
Eben. Das wäre meine Frage, die ich mir gerade an dieser Stelle. Weil es genügend Standards gibt, die übrigens von anderen Fritz Produkten schon implementiert werden. Das ist der Punkt, den ich da dran nicht verstehe, die zum Beispiel eben Power, Ethernet over Powerlines machen. Also diese Strom über Steckdosen-Nummer. Da gibt es da schon reichlich Produkte. Warum nehmen sie nicht da ihr selber ein Produkt, das sie schon haben, das in ihre Produktfamilie passt? Nein, sie benutzen jetzt ihren komischen Deckmodul von den Fritz-Boxen, die in der Deckbasisstation drin haben, um mit der Steckdose zu sprechen. Statt über Strom mit der Steckdose zu sprechen. Oder mit WLAN.
Da könnte ich direkt mit meinem iPhone absetzen.
Oder mit WLAN.
Dass es sich dabei um dasselbe Stromnetz handelt?
Nein.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel zwei komplett disjunkte Stromnetze in meiner Wohnung.
Wie du willst über Strom mit einer Steckdose sprechen? Was ist denn das für eine absurde Idee?
Ja, das saftet den Leuten die Internet-Ethernet-Powerlein. Oder mach WLAN.
Bevor du dich jetzt hier weiter entröstest.
Ich will mich nicht entrösten, aber ich habe es nicht verstanden, was das soll, jetzt gerade mit Deck zu machen. Ich vermute mal, dass das kein Produkt ist, was sie jetzt hier in Berlin konstruiert haben, weil vor allem, sondern das haben sie irgendwo wieder eingekauft. Oder OEM.
Das verstehe ich jetzt echt nicht. Weil alles, was dieses Gerät hier können muss, nämlich irgendwie digitale Kommunikation zu betreiben und ein definiertes Pairing durchzuführen und relativ stabil über größere Strecken in der Wohnung Funkkommunikation aufrechtzuerhalten, da ist jetzt Deck durchaus Proven Technology. Außerdem haben sie es sowieso schon in ihrem Kram drin.
Ich bin nicht gerade sicher, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Doch mittlerweile ist ja der Deckstandard dann nach dieser ganzen Deck-Hackerei auch enhanced worden. Das hatte ja wirklich Folgen.
Von diesem, wie hieß er, Carsten Noll oder so?
Nein, nein, das hat mit Carsten Noll nichts zu tun. Aber ich kann dich da gerne an eine CLE-Ausgabe...
Aber wer ist denn nun die Gegenstelle bei so einem Deck? Weil mein Rechner kann kein Deck, mein Telefon auch nicht.
Die Fritzbox, die Fritzboxen mit Deck drin.
Man braucht also zu diesem Gerät zusätzlich auch noch die Fritzbox.
Das ist eine Erweiterung der Fritzbox. Genau.
Okay, was kostet denn das Ding als Erweiterung?
Das weiß ich nicht, genau.
Aha, du hast es also per Post bekommen.
Ich habe es per Post bekommen, genau. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Preis schon irgendwie fest steht. Ich schaue gerade mal. Das kommt ja jetzt auch gerade erst in den Handel, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also hier 49 Euro.
Also die selbst hat die kein Display, zeigt gar nichts an. Sondern du brauchst wirklich die Fritzbox, um zu gucken, ja?
Ja, du buchst das eine in der Fritzbox.
Vermutlich. Ich kann dir das nicht hundertprozentig sagen. Es kann auch sein, dass vielleicht man mit diesem Fritz-Phone schon auch irgendwie Informationen...
Es gibt keine Peer-to-Peer-Kommunikation im Deck.
Deckdose, was ist denn dein Verbrauch gerade?
Es gibt keine Peer-to-Peer-Kommunikation im Deck. Das heißt, du musst das ohnehin auf der Zentrale einbuchen und dann kann vielleicht auf deinem Fritz-Phone eine Anzeige dafür da sein, aber ja.
Und diese roten Dinger, da sind LEDs da an dem Teil, oder was sehe ich hier auf der Verpackung?
Die roten Dinger sind aufgeklebt und dann gibt es hier noch zwei Schalter, die grün leuchten.
Ach, die sind nur Optik? Ich verstehe.
Steck sie doch mal in die Wand. Das ist ja eine Steckdose. Kann ich noch mal kurz gucken? Bitte, hier.
Hinter dir ist eine Steckdose in der Wand.
Zum Beispiel.
Du meinst, das ist echt nur Farbe?
Sie können elektrische Geräte manuell oder automatisch ein- und ausschalten. Die automatische Schaltung lässt sich individuell einrichten, zum Beispiel nach einem Wochenplan. Sie können den Energieverbrauch elektrischer Geräte messen und aufzeichnen.
Steck doch mal rein hinter dir da am Boden.
Auf Wunsch halten Sie die Daten regelmäßig per E-Mail. Ich habe zum Beispiel seit vier Jahren ein Messgerät bei mir laufen. Und glaubst du, ich bin einmal zurückgekommen, weil es geht abzulesen?
Du brauchst doch nur draufgucken.
Ja, aber das muss man halt machen. Das muss man halt machen und dann muss man sich da auch mal einen Plan machen. Wie lange läuft denn das jetzt eigentlich schon?
Mich ist das jetzt immer nur der aktuelle Verbrauch. Den Rest kann man sich ja hochrechnen. Außer beim Kühlschrank, da geht es halt nicht so gut.
Gas blinkt grün.
Es ist auch der Kühlschrank, um den es geht.
Meiner hat 14 Watt Durchschnitt.
Also wenn wir jetzt in diese Thema einsteigen, ich habe ja noch einen anderen Nerd-Hobby neben der Netzwerkerei. Ich habe ja in meinem kleinen Landsitz draußen, den habe ich ja komplett mit Haustechnik zugenagelt. Unter anderem lese ich auch da drüber die Stromzähler ab. Also wenn dich das interessiert, deine Stromzähler auf die Daten auf deinen Rechner drauf zu kriegen, könnte ich dir da auch noch was dazu erzählen.
Ich habe ja zu Hause theoretisch von so einer Firma, die auch so eine Treppenhaus-Schalter macht, dass das Licht nach einer Weile von alleine ausgeht. Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht mehr wie die El Taco. Ich habe so einen El Taco-Standardeinsatz hier, diese Hochkantlinge für diese modernen Sicherungsanlagen.
So wie die noch in Gutschienen.
Und da habe ich ja so einen kleinen El Taco mit einem Display drin. Also dieses ganz schmale Ding. Nicht extra, sondern wirklich dieses ganz schmale Ding. Und der kann auch den aktuellen Verbrauch anzeigen. Das Problem ist bloß, dass ich keine Hauptsicherung bei mir habe, was eigentlich auch nicht so okay ist. Und ich kann dieses Ding nicht ausbauen ohne da so eine 32 Ampere Zentimeter breite Kupferader, die ich nicht entsichern kann, irgendwie mal zur Seite zu machen. Und man sagte mir, das funkt nicht nur kurz, sondern da fliegt dir das flüssige Kupfer um die Ohren, wenn du dann kurzen machst. Und das ist halt nicht so meins, da rumzubasteln. Sonst hätte ich das Ding schon eingebaut.
Mach doch einfach kein kurzen Ohr. Lass einfach die Finger davon.
Also, absoluter gewissen Größe sollte man Finger von bestimmten Sachen lassen.
Und da lasse ich lieber die Finger von. Ich habe mich damit sehr intensiv befasst, weil ich in meinem Land sitze, dort gerne ein paar Sachen fernsteuer. Der ist nämlich ein bisschen weg von hier. Und da macht es halt Sinn, zum Beispiel die Heizung vorher anzumachen, bevor man hinfährt oder im Sommer mal das Gartenwasser draußen an, für den Rasensprenger und so Zeugs. Und in dem Rahmen habe ich auch gleich Stromzähler, die ich von hier aus ablesen kann und auch Wasserzähler. Also wenn das mal ein interessantes Thema ist, will ich jetzt nicht näher einsteigen, aber dann können wir uns damit durch erstmal befassen. Das ist nämlich ganz lustig.
Das ist ein Thema, das Fass machen wir heute nicht mehr auf, glaube ich.
Da gibt es ja auch einen S0-Bus, ne?
Da gibt es witzigerweise einen S0-Bus.
Aber das ist kein ESCN, sondern ein Tastgeber.
Nein, das ist ein Open-Collector-Ding. Also einfach nur ein Kontakt. Oder denn der Zähler sagt, benutze ich ihn auch für die Wasserzähler. Da kriegt pro Liter Durchfluss einen Impuls.
Haben wir noch Themen?
Bevor wir jetzt hier zu schnell Feierabend machen, ich wollte nochmal Bitcoin haben. Was hat man bei Bitcoin noch? Weil sonst ist auf jeden Fall morgen der erste Donnerstag im Monat und im Room 77 ist morgen ein Bitcoin-Treffen. Und da noch habe ich erfahren, habe ich gestern besucht...
Wann denn?
Als Bitcoin-Milliardär?
Die liegen alle in der Bank, da komme ich gar nicht ran. Morgen ist, glaube ich auch, es gibt irgendwie so eine Art ein Ruby-Talk-Treffen morgen irgendwo. Den Ort weiß ich nicht, aber die Leute, die da hingehen oder die Ruby machen, die wissen es irgendwie. Und dort wird morgen auch ein bisschen über Bitcoin und Ruby erzählt. Weil gestern hat mich da einer ausgefragt und brauchte noch ein bisschen Bitcoin-Feedback. Also morgen sind sozusagen zwei Sachen gleichzeitig.
Bitrubies.
Ja, irgendwie so. Ich weiß leider nicht, wo es ist und wie sie heißt, aber ja. Ansonsten rum-serv-n-e-serv-n, Grefe-Straße 77, da gibt es morgen Bitcoin-Treffen. Also da ist nichts Spezielles, sondern einfach nur Leute, die halt ein bisschen mit Bitcoins machen, was auch immer. Zum Beispiel der Programmierer der Bitcoin-Android-App ist da. Und da kann man auch seine Burger mit Bitcoins bezahlen. Und inzwischen müsste man ziemlich wenig Bitcoins bezahlen für seinen Burger.
Weil der Kurs nämlich extrem nach oben gegangen ist.
Ja, aber er ist doch schon wieder runtergegangen. Er ist schon wieder bei 34 jetzt.
Aber er hat ja nicht immer so feste Preise. Kostet das nicht immer das Gleiche?
Tagesaktuell wird da berechnet, was dein Burger gerade wert ist. Und in dem Augenblick, wo du bezahlst, wird sozusagen geguckt. Also wenn ein Burger 10 Euro kostet, dann zahlst du morgen den Drittel Bitcoin so, oder sogar ein bisschen weniger, für deinen Burger. Das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Siehst du, da schreibt schon jemand im Chat, Join von Telekom fehlt noch.
Stimmt, das hast du vorhin eingebracht.
Ja, weil das alle diese komische ADN und lalala, das alles all den Bastel.
Aber mal ehrlich, dieses Join von der Telekom ist doch bestimmt eine Totgeburt, oder nicht?
Das Spannende ist, wenn du jemals wissen wolltest, ob Totgeburten noch Kinder kriegen können, dann hast du damit den Beweis. Weil Join ist die Totgeburt, der Totgeburt, MMS.
Nee, es funktioniert.
Ja, war trotzdem eine Totgeburt, weil keiner irgendwie interessiert...
Hast du jene MMS versendet?
Und das Spannende ist...
iPhone ist schuld.
Ja, das Spannende ist...
Noch bevor iMessage rauskam, weil da kannst du also prima Bilder mit versenden und das geht einfach.
Deswegen war es jetzt auch total sinnvoll, jetzt noch mit Join auf den Markt zu kommen, weil man mit iMessage, WhatsApp, Skype, ADN, Twitter, keine Nachrichten, keine Fotostreams, keine Fotos versenden kann. Deswegen war es jetzt total wichtig, dass man Join noch mal rausbringt, weil die Kunden dürsten nun danach, dass sie jetzt endlich Nachrichten für 19 oder 39 Cent wieder versenden können. Weil diese WhatsApp und iMessage ist einfach zu billig. Das will keiner. Das hat keinen Premiumwert. Und der Premiumwert liegt halt daran, dass man jetzt mit Join endlich wieder für die Nachrichten was bezahlen kann.
Das heißt, sie haben wieder Wert. Ich mache die Telekom mit Ruhe, damit sie sagen können, dass sie da ein Alternativangebot haben, dass sie irgendwie iMessage versuchen können zu sperren. War da nicht mal irgendwas, dass sie sperren wollten oder andere Chatsysteme wollten sie sperren? Sie können natürlich die nur sperren lassen, wenn sie auch was Eigenes anbieten können, oder?
Nee. Ich könnte das gar nicht sperren lassen.
Das hat mal jemand.
Suchst du einfach mal nach JOIN mit Y. Telekom hat es jetzt gerade mit großem Symbolium gestartet und haben auch schon die Preise dafür angesagt. Natürlich, wenn du eine Internet-Flatrate hast, die ja nicht flat ist, wie wir ja schon wissen, dann kostet das nichts.
Wir müssen das mal eine Cliffrate nennen.
Für alle Leute, die ein bisschen Smartphone haben, damit sie die auch noch abkassieren können, die sich die voll billigen Telefonen holen.
Du brauchst aber ein Smartphone, weil das alles IP-basiert ist. Wenn du den Scheiß, den du joinen kannst, hast du eh ein Telefon, das Kamera, Trailer und Pipa Pro drin hat, mit IP-Stack, dann liefert der natürlich auch einen Browser mit. Welcher Telefonhersteller baut noch ein Telefon mit IP-Stack und Trailer und Pipa Pro, das nicht noch einen Browser drin hat? Wenn es einen Browser drin hat, ist es nach Quardefinition schon wieder ein Smartphone. Ich weiß echt nicht, was sie sich dabei ausgedacht haben.
Na gut, dann ist es ja auch ein Nicht-Thema, dann ist das ja alles gar nicht so spannend.
Aber ich fand es toll, dass du dich jetzt noch traust, mit was jetzt auf den Markt zu kommen wird, wie gesagt, WhatsApp, iMessage, Skype und Trailerland, was es schon seit Jahren gibt, etabliert. Und jetzt mit was rauszukommen und stolz noch zu verkünden, ja, du kannst eine Textnachricht für 19 Cent verschicken, 19 Cent. Und wenn du da jetzt noch ein Bild dran tackert, dann kostet es nur 39 Cent. Das ist doch toll, oder? Aber der zeigt mal wieder, in welcher Denke diese Telekom-Fuzis da noch irgendwie verhaftet sind. Oder in welcher Realitätsbubble die stecken. Das ist irgendwie, ja.
Ja, hier steht in Wikipedia so schön, Join soll insbesondere mit mobilen Instant-Messenger-Diensten wie WhatsApp, Apple, iMessage und Facebook Messenger konkurrieren, die für die Mobilfunkanbieter unlukrativ sind.
Ja, schön ausgedrückt. So, was hast du jetzt rausgefunden mit deiner Deckdose?
Ich kriege die nicht gepaart hier. Man muss da eine Taste drücken, sagen sie. An die Fritzbox.
Nicht auf dem Ding selbst?
Nee, musst du nicht. Da kannst du doch über Software machen.
Und wo ist die Fritzbox?
Ja, aber wie denn? Mit neues Gerät einrichten.
Muss ich dir das jetzt während der Live-Sendezeit einrichten? Ja, zum Beispiel.
Also keine neue Farbe aufspielen, während wir noch senden, ja?
Jetzt hat das Blinken aufgehört. Und jetzt blinkt es anders. Jetzt blinkt es kürzer, in kürzeren Abständen. Was haben wir denn noch so auf der Liste?
Na, wenn wir schon bei der Telekom sind und ihren vergeblichen Versuchen irgendwie ihre Märkte zu halten.
Bei der Telekom gibt es jetzt auch das iPhone Unlocked.
Jetzt gibt es ja vor allem dieses skurrile Announcement, dass sie jetzt tatsächlich mit Phon zusammen Internetzugang anbieten wollen.
Diese sparen ja mit diesen Phoneras.
Ich bin ja da weg bei der Telekom.
Angeblich 2,5 Millionen Hotspots. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr in den letzten Jahren irgendwann mal irgendwo einen gesehen habt.
Ja, bei mir zuhause.
Bei dir selbst?
Ja, die hatten mal eine Weile dieses Angebot, dass man sich das Ding umsonst schicken kann. Lassen konnte. Da habe ich mir so einen Teil kommen lassen.
Aber hast du den auch in Betrieb?
Nö, den wollte ich doch nur zuhause haben.
Allerdings habe ich ihn gleich als erstes Mal geroutet und einen OpenWrt draufgespielt. Und damit ist es kein Phonero oder Phonera mehr, sondern ein ganz normaler Access-Point. Wenn ich im Innenhof sitze, reicht das W-Laden nicht. Dann packe ich dieses Teil aus und schließe es mit einem langen Kabel an den normalen Router und lege es aufs Fensterbrett. Dann habe ich im Innenhof W-Laden.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Telekom konkret plant. Aber wenn das letztlich bedeutet, dass diese ganzen Fohn-Hotspots sich mir gegenüber genauso verhalten wie ein Telekom-W-Laden-Hotspot.
Also scheiße oder wie?
Ja, scheiße. Dann weiß ich nicht so richtig, wo der Gewinn ist. Davon abgesehen, meine Erfahrung auf der Straße, wenn ich so unterwegs bin und nach Netzen suche, dass ich mal einen Fohn-Spot sehe, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr selten. Bis nie. Also ich glaube, ich habe mal einen irgendwann mal tatsächlich gesehen, wo ich jetzt nicht unbedingt erwartet hätte, einen zu sehen. Ja, your mileage may vary.
Sie haben Millionen davon, laut Ihrer Pressemitteilung? Ja, du musstest einfach mal nicht immer alles in Frage stellen. Du musstest auch einfach mal glauben.
Nein, ich weiß, es ist natürlich dumm von mir, dass ich jetzt hier irgendwelche realen Zahlen haben möchte, wo ich ja auch einfach glauben kann, was in der Pressemitteilung steht. Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Es gab auch neulich wieder eine Diskussion, die irgendwie in den Kommentaren oder auch im Flatter geführt wurde, wofür jetzt diese Zwangstrennung beim DSL da ist. Die Antwort ist ganz klar, das dient dem Datenschutz. Das sagt die Telekom. So, da muss man auch dankbar dafür sein.
Das ist gut, wir sollten mehr für den Datenschutz tun.
Sollen wir jetzt noch einen kurzen praktischen Lebenstipp einschmeißen?
Wenn du einen hast.
Aus aktuellem Anlass bin nämlich gerade gestern gefragt worden, was mache ich eigentlich, wenn ich im Urlaub beim Wandern einen Unfall habe oder jemand, der mit mir unterwegs ist, einen Unfall hat? Oder zum Beispiel in diesem konkreten Fall war es ein Schlaganfall? Und meine Antwort war, nimmst dein GSM-Phone, was hoffentlich noch Batterie hat und wählst 112. Ja, aber ich bin noch im Ausland. Du wählst immer 112 auf deinem GSM-Telefon. Selbst wenn du zum Beispiel in den USA bist oder sowas. Oder in Japan oder sonst wo. Selbst wenn dein Roaming gerade ausgeknipst ist. Du wählst 112. Ja, aber wenn das Telefon gesperrt ist, dann wählst du 112. Nein, das ist Pflicht. Sonst kriegst du keine Zulassung für dein Telefon.
Genau das wollten sie ändern.
Ist aber nicht so. Was wir vor ein paar Jahren mal geändert haben, ist allerdings anfangs der GSM-Phase war es interessanterweise so, dass ein sogenanntes Emergency-Call hat notfalls auch andere Leute aus dem Netz geschmissen. Und das haben dann ein paar Leute benutzt, zum Beispiel hier in Deutschland. Wenn man mal wieder so Remy Demi war, was weiß ich, so Love Parade oder sonst irgendwas, und du hast keinen freien Funkkanal gekriegt auf der Straße am 17. Juni, dann hast du mal ganz kurz 112 gewählt, kurz wieder aufgelegt, weil dann hat dein Telefon ja einen Kanal freigeschossen, und dann hast du sozusagen gewählt. So haben sie es damals korportiert. Deswegen hat man das jetzt mal, diese Funktionalität hat man dann mal so ein bisschen eingeschränkt. Aber wichtig, also wie gesagt praktisches Lebensding, egal in welchem Land ihr seid, ob ihr Roaming an oder aus seid, oder auch in Deutschland, selbst wenn ihr jetzt mit eurem E-Plus-Telefon auf dem Land rumeyert und keinen Empfang habt, wenn ihr 112 wählt, bucht sich das Telefon aufrecht bei der Telekom ein und macht den Notruf. Das Interessante dabei ist, dass es, wie gesagt, so komplett durchdesigned ist, dass 112 immer geht, auch in Ländern, wo 112 nicht die Notrufnummer ist. So ist es zum Beispiel auch so, dass wenn ein Ami herkommt, mit seinem Ami-Telefon oder mit seiner Ami-SIM-Karte, und selbst wenn er seine Ami-SIM-Karte in ein deutsches iPhone steckt, der kann 911 eintippen und kriegt hier einen Notruf-Operator.
Weil auf der SIM-Karte steht, welches die Notrufnummer ist.
Also 112 ist eh der GSM-Standard. Auf der SIM-Karte können noch weitere Notrufnummer stehen, die vermutlich der Anwender dieser SIM-Karte für Notrufnummer hält. Die werden dann sozusagen umgesetzt, weil im Netz wird ja nämlich wirklich 112 gewählt, sondern im Netz wird signalisiert, dies ist ein Notruf.
Ja guck, jetzt hat einer im Chat herausgefunden, dass sie wollen ändern, dass man ohne SIM-Karte 112 und 110 wählen kann, weil der Missbrauch so groß war, dass die Stellen, wo angerufen wird, waren durch irgendwie Prank-Calls irgendwie überlassen, deswegen wollen wir das jetzt einstellen.
Ja, hast du immer, aber derzeit ist es noch so, du hast recht, du kannst auch ein Telefon einfach nehmen ohne SIM-Karte und da 112 einhacken und dann geht das. Die 110 geht übrigens nur deswegen, weil es auf deutschen SIM-Karten drauf steht. 110 ist nicht im Standard sozusagen abgedeckt, aber es geht trotzdem. 112 geht wie gesagt immer, weil es richtig hart gekodet ist. Ja, natürlich gibt es wie immer Missbrauch dafür, ist klar. Aber es ist im Üben auch so, dass in Amiland nur noch Telefone zugelassen werden, die auch gleichzeitig deine Location mit übermitteln. Wo weiter üben Sie diese Nummer? Wir sind ja eine Nerd-Sendung. Da gibt es ganz interessante Techniken. Es gibt ein Verfahren, wo Telefone, die selber keinen GPS-Chip drin haben, trotzdem eine GPS-Location mit übermitteln. Ja, Roddy zieht gerade die Augenbrauen zusammen. Die Idee ist folgende. Nein, das machen sie sowieso. Was zu machen ist, die lassen den DSP im Telefon, lassen den mal kurz auf der GPS-Frequenz horchen und einfach das rohe Gesabbel aufzeichnen. Nehmen die Sample vom rohen Gesabbel, schicken sie ins Netz und die Positionsermittlung wird im Netz gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das welche Telefone implementieren, weil heute ja jeder auch so ein GPS-Chipchen drin hat. Aber die Idee dahinter finde ich schon ziemlich cool.
Sind denn die GPS-Frequenzen denn so nah an den normalen GSM-Frequenzen. Dran, dass du das ohne weiteres machen kannst?
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau, aber ich glaube, die L1 hat nicht irgendwie 1,7 Gigahertz oder so was. Das kann man noch mal gucken, GPS-Frequenz. Also das ist jetzt nicht so meilenweit weg. GPS-Frequencies.
Ich bin ja gerade noch mit diesen Phone-Maps unterwegs und habe gerade festgestellt, dass in Deutschland tatsächlich Phone eher so im Crickets-and-Tumble-Read-Bereich unterwegs ist. Aber in Belgien und vor allem auch in Britannien extrem anders ist. Und auch Frankreich...
Ja, weil die da überall kein Netz haben. Bei uns nicht.
Es hat normalerweise Spanien, wo das Projekt herkommt, irgendwie interessiert es keinen Schwanz. Außer in Madrid. Portugal geht wiederum. Aber Belgien und Britannien scheinen so ein bisschen so...
Also vor allem Britannien ist einfach mal komplett...
Das ist einfach eine Frage, wer die Router da verteilt hat.
Und Polen ist anscheinend noch dick am Start.
Ja, welchen Operator haben sich diese Phon-Leute schon gegriffen, der diese Router da verteilt?
Das sieht mir auch schon so ein bisschen nach Provider-supported aus.
Irgendwie 1,57 GHz, 1,2 GHz und 1,38 GHz. Ja, aber nicht so meilenweit weg. Also das ist schon woanders, aber... Aber hab ich, wie gesagt, hab noch keinen so nicht gesehen, aber hab ich mal gehört und die Idee fand ich irgendwie nett. Jetzt ohne Garantie, aber die Idee fand ich lustig. So, also 1, 1, 2 wählen. Keine Gedanken machen, mit dem blutenden Kopf nicht noch nachdenken wollen, sondern 1, 1, 2 wählen. Ist doch schön.
Wenn man an deinem Telefon gelockt ist, dann kommt da sowieso Emergency-Call.
Du kannst dann auch 1, 1, 2 und grüne Tasten wählen, statt deinen PIN-Code.
Nee, nee, das ist schon klar. Da gibt es ja einen Emergency-Call. Ich dachte, dass man dann vielleicht schon gleich den Call macht. Aber nee, man muss trotzdem noch mal tippen sogar.
Und wir sind aber irgendwie durch für heute, oder? Also ich bin fertig. Also wir haben jetzt zwar noch viele Themen irgendwie, aber die können wir auch gerne noch schieben.
Kann ich noch 30 Sekunden Follower-Power in Anspruch nehmen?
Klar.
Von meinen Freunden mit der besagten Druckerei. Denen habe ich ja nur alles umgestellt auf Mac. Und wir sind auch eigentlich total happy. Aber sie fallen mir jeden Tag, wenn ich da mal vorbeikomme, oder jeden nächsten Tag, wenn ich da mal vorbeischaufe, fallen die mir sofort immer in die Arme. Weil sie sagen, ihr größtes Problem ist, dass das Mail-Programm von Apple immer nur kleine Fenster aufmacht. Oder immer wieder kleine Fenster. Und ich so, hä, wovon redest du? Die benutzen, das sind halt echte Anwender. Das ist jetzt mal eine Anwenderfrage. Die benutzen Apple Mail so, dass sie auf jede neue Mail doppelt draufklicken. Weil das finden sie toll. Das heißt, das macht ja Apple Mail, wenn du mal guckst, wenn du auf so eine reingehende Mail doppelt klickst, kriegst du ein extra Fenster dafür. So, machen die so, finde ich toll. Das sind die gewohnt. Die habe ich mühsam umdressiert, nicht Outlook benutzen zu wollen. Und offensichtlich muss man, wenn man Outlook benutzt, das so machen. Jedenfalls sind die jetzt so gewohnt. Und die sind schon über 40 beide und die kriegen das nicht mehr anders ins Hören. Also klicken sie doppelt. Gut, habe ich gedacht, schön, zieh doch einfach das Fenster groß, weil das merkt sich, dass das so groß bleibt. Das ist auch in der Tat so, solange ich neben denen stehe. Wenn ich nur 5 Meter weg gehe und er klickt doppelt drauf, dann sagt er, komm her, komm her, hat er wieder ein kleines Fenster, das links unten in der Ecke hängt. Und das ist nicht nachreproduzierbar. Ich habe es auch nicht verstanden, wie das ist. Aber ich sehe das. Er ruft mich dann jede Mal, guck ich da hin, zieht er das wieder groß? Solange ich neben ihm stehe, bleiben die Fenster alle groß. Und sobald ich weggehe, 10 Minuten später...
Hoff ich mal eine neue Maus oder schalte ihm sein Trackpad aus.
Vielleicht klickt er aus Versehen mit der Maus, Trackpad. Mit so einer Tralala-Maus. Mit dieser weißen, super streichenden Maus. Touch-Maus, Magic-Maus.
Hoff ich mal eine normale Maus.
Das sind zwei Brüder und die können nicht beide gleich behindert sein.
Aber du hast gesagt, die sind alt.
Über 40. Meinst du, ich geb denen mal wieder eine gute, alte Microsoft-Maus mit dem Rad dran, dann passiert das nicht mehr?
Könnte sein, würde ich nicht ausschließen.
Was für ein View hast du denn da eingestellt?
B-View?
Na was für ein View?
Der eine hat diesen modernen View. Wie wir den haben, so diese drei Spalten. Und der andere hat Doppelklick. Hallo? Machen sie aber. Die haben sich das so zurechtgeschoben, weil sie das hier toll finden. Machen diese Leiste hier komplett weg. Das wollen sie alle nicht haben. Und eine neue Mail wird, weil sie ja dann bearbeitet wird, so doppelt geklickt. So machen die das. Und dann haben sie dieses Fenster. Bei mir sind die immer gleich groß. Nämlich so, wie ich das letzte Mal das Fenster verlassen habe. Nee, nicht immer. Das wäre ja schön, dann könnte ich es ja reproduzieren. Solange ich neben ihm stehe, passiert es nicht. Aber wie gesagt, ich gehe weg von seinem Arbeitsplatz, höre auf, ihm auf die Tasse zuzustarren und nach zehn Minuten schreite ich, jetzt ist das Fenster wieder klein. Und dann komme ich hin und das Fenster ist wieder klein.
Hört sich aber auch an wie ein Layer-8-Problem.
Hört sich an wie ein Layer-8-Problem, aber das haben beide Brüder. Und ich kann echt nicht so richtig nachproduzieren, was das ist. Aber vielleicht haben das ja andere Leute auch schon mal gehabt. Das kann auch sein, dass sie mich freuen wollen. Das kann es nicht unwahrscheinlicher. Aber falls jemand anders noch ähnliche Probleme hat, dass sich Apple-Fenster nicht merken, wie groß sie sind, dann soll er doch mal schreien im Kommentar. Vielleicht kommen wir der Sache mal auf die Spur.
Layer-8-Problem finde ich aber auch einen ganz gemeinen Ausdruck.
Moment, Moment. Layer-8 war Politik, Layer-9 war Religion. War das nicht so? Im ISO-Layer ist doch Layer-8 Politik und Layer-9 Religion.
Und der User ist dann?
Layer-10 erst. Echt? Dachte.
Ne, andersrum. Layer-8 ist der User. Wahrscheinlich sind Politik 9 und Religion 10. Die sind ja sozusagen noch schlimmer.
Das hat ja mit schlimm nichts zu tun. Sondern wer sozusagen bei wem es als letztes ankommt. Es kommt definitiv bei den Leuten zuletzt an.
Wenn es ankommt.
Das wird dann erstmal nochmal durch Politik und Religion gefiltert. Das ist ein schönes Bild. Das habe ich so noch gar nicht gesehen. Da könnte man wahrscheinlich noch ein paar andere Layer einziehen.
Wenn man sich über Layer unterhält, ist das immer ein klassischer Gag oder Gag. Aber wenn man drei Minuten länger darüber nachdenkt, stellt man fest, das ist wirklich da. Das gibt es wirklich.
Also ich meine, so der Homo Sapiens Digitalis hat dann wahrscheinlich aber auch nochmal so ein Twitter-Layer dazwischen.
ADN-Layer.
So, wir sind alle müde.
Ich nicht.
Außer Dennis.
Bis auf ihren ganzen Abendmatt.
Und außer Clemens. Und außer Roddy.
Sind wir alle müde. Wir sind alle individuell. Nee, nee, ich darf ja nicht.
Meine Konzentrationsfähigkeit ist da. Das ist nicht gut, ne? Also, Apple, nächste Mal ist das 10.9 angekündigt, weil da wollen wir dann mal drüber reden.
Oder wenigstens das 10.8.3 draußen.
Ja, da kann man nicht viel drüber reden. Außer, dass der Treiber für die Grafik gerade drin ist. Aber das wissen wir ja jetzt schon.
Vielleicht ist auch der Fall.
Der ist jetzt nicht rausgekommen während der Sendung. Ist ja schon ein bisschen enttäuschend, oder? Also ich meine...
Naja, aber die haben doch heute eine neue Beta rausgebracht. Die bringen doch die Beta raus, damit die Leute die testen.
Die 3 Zehnt. Aber heute hat Apple auch zum ersten Mal zu mir, zumindest eine Mail geschickt, dass es die Prerelease ist.
Ja.
Ich hab vorher keine bekommen.
Bestimmt fast mit deinem Spam-Filter nicht. Nee, aber wenn die heute eine Beta rausbringen, dann doch dafür, dass die Leute sich das installieren, drei Tage drauf rumtesten, nochmal Bugs schreiben oder auch nicht. Und dann kannst du in frühestens drei Tagen damit rechnen, dass sie das Release raushauen. Weil eine Beta raushauen und irgendwie eine halbe Stunde später das Release raushauen, ist so sinnlos wie irgendwas.
Betas haben sie doch schon seit Wochen, Monaten rausgehauen.
Ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Tester scheinen ja immer noch was zu finden. Vielleicht war das mal wieder nicht ganz ehrlich von Apple.
Ja, das finde ich jetzt aber auch erstaunt.
Schon wieder ein Netz weg hier?
So würde ich es jetzt nicht sagen.
Dein Netz ist scheiße, Tim.
Pinkt, sowohl V4 als V6 als auch der dusselige Stream-Server.
Eine Menge geht ja auch nicht.
Aber, ne, der DNS geht auch.
Ja, no known issues.
Wer macht denn eigentlich dein Netz, deine Fritzbox? Hat die irgendwie so ein Connection-Problem oder was?
Was hast du denn gerade für ein Problem gesehen?
Ich komm nicht in den Apple Store gerade.
Naja, das kann ja wohl auch daran liegen, dass jetzt grad der Neuen rauskommt. Der Neuen Mac Pros.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal schön, mach ich mal noch mal mehr Tests.
Das ist ja schon den ganzen Abend so. Es geht immer an, aus, an, aus, an, aus.
Ja, aber ich pinge den ganzen Abend. Ich komm auch zu meiner Testzeit, sowohl mit V4 als auch mit V6, ohne weiteres sofort. Nicht pingen, nein, ich hab ne Testzeit. Kannst du selber aufrufen, nkn.gits.net. Kannst auch nkn4.gits.net nehmen und nkn6.gits.net.
Das ist ja auch ein Routenproblem. Und hier gehen halt manche Routen ab und zu mal nicht.
Nee, vielleicht gehen hier mal. Ich hab eher die Suspicion, nachdem was vorhin mir gesagt wurde, weil halt nämlich schon die pingt. Und da hat Tim mir ja gesagt, dass der Stream irgendwie wieder rockelt oder so was, oder was nicht geht. Seitdem erwache ich das DNS auch noch mit. Und das DNS...
Java für OS X 2013-0011.0. Mal.
Wieder. Ist das nicht der tägliche Java-Update, oder es kommt jetzt schon zweimal am Tag?
Und täglich grüßt das Java-Update?
Auf jeden Fall.
Oder war es das Flash-Update?
Das ist auch ein Fall.
Ach, das ist gar nicht das gleiche. Flash und Java, jetzt stimmt. Jetzt fällt es mir erstmal ein. Beides langsam, beides scheiße, beides wird dann dauernd geupdatet.
Und es ist trotzdem offen wie ein Scheudentor.
So sieht es aus. Wir debaggen jetzt mal hier die Netzsituation und nutzen die Zeit vielleicht mal noch ein bisschen dafür. Genau. Gucken wir mal, was Sache ist.
Nächstes Mal wieder fünf Stunden.
Nächstes Mal wieder fünf Stunden. Und mit Huckel.
Ja, das ist aber kein Versprechen. Er muss dann drei Stunden nachholen, ist klar. Nachsitzen.
So ist das. Also.
Wink, wink.
Thank you for coming, and we'll see you soon.